the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
stage at the American Cup in St Louis
the exciting new format has players
jazzed to Razzle and Dazzle us with
their creative play Irena Crush came
ready to Tango claiming Victory and
setting up a Do or Die game for opponent
begum toker Genova tactical draws were
on the docket for the remaining leaders
but it was kill or be killed in the
elimination bracket four players were
sent packing with Sam Shanklin surviving
a playoff to stay alive in the event the
verdicts are final but the show must go
on day four of amazing chess coming up
next
thank you
foreign
[Music]
to day four of the 2023 American Cup
held at the same release chess club we
started a in front of the Chase Park
Plaza Hotel where the players are housed
throughout all of these events well it's
been a fantastic event so far filled
with trails and Spills let's go to the
studio and start today's action with
Yasser and Joe
we welcome you to St Louis Missouri the
capital of Chess in America this is day
four of the 2023 American cup from the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello and a big warm welcome from the
Saint Louis chess club Studio I'm Yvonne
Ivanka houska and it's a great pleasure
to be calling the action with the one
and only Grand Master yasa sarawan Jovi
it's been wonderful you and Christian
have been great but the games themselves
have been excellent they've been
fantastic haven't they I'm loving it
hello everyone and Welcome to our live
coverage well it's been a struggle for
the players in the open section to win a
single classical game not true for one
Arena crash whose performance can be
summed up in three words Jovi
fabulous three out of three as she is
storming the women's bracket let's take
a look at the women's bracket
deeper and it was absolutely thrilling
day yesterday we saw that Arena Crush
was absolutely dominant against
and that means that tohir Jennifer is an
must win a situation today she has to
take it with the white pieces to take it
to playoffs on the other hand it was a
very tense day for Naji paikitsa and
Alice Lee I have to remember she's just
13 years old Alice and today there will
be everything to play for a draw takes
them to the playoffs but whoever wins
will remain in the championship package
and in the elimination bracket and the
lamination bracket it got tense but uh
in the end it was Tata Abraham
abrahamian who actually made it through
as did a two-star percussion and both of
them are awaiting their opponents from
the Champions bracket to drop down and
speaking of the Champions bracket how
about in the open section in the open
section oh it is so
because I mean you kind of set it there
yesterday these guys are not winning a
game because the margins are so tight we
saw Hikari Nakamura and Daniel Dominguez
braw and uh Wesley so and Fabiana
caruana also Drew in a test game now
it's going to be up to the players with
the white pieces to pile on the pressure
or it's going to be a playoff absolutely
and in the elimination bracket oh it was
I mean if we were talking about
excitement and we were here it got
special because Levon aronian defeated
Sam Seville and it's just very
effortless format and then we saw Sam
Shanklin take kids from Ray Robson and
this one went all the way to the blitz
playoffs but in the end Sam Shanklin
just showed that he had all those
preparations obviously wonderful and
we're very fortunate to have in studio
our good friend Christian uh to tell us
about the highlights we can expect for
today good to see you Christian good to
see you guys great to be back and what a
marvelous performance by Sam Shanklin
you're mentioning Jovi yesterday in that
critical matchup with Ray Robson in the
elimination bracket to stay in the
tournament last year it was Ray Robson
that stayed in the tournament this year
it is Sam Shanklin but let's take a look
as the elimination bracket gets away
rest let's take a look at what's
happening in the Champions bracket well
we do have that big clash between well
the rating favorite going into this
event Hikaru Nakamura against the very
tough to beat leniere Dominguez Lanier
will have the white pieces in today's
matchup and as he told us yesterday in
the interview he will try to pile on the
pressure on His Marvelous opponent as we
can see one win one loss and 13 grass
these guys are inseparable let's take a
look at the second match in the
Champions bracket of course that is the
big clash between Wesley so and Fabiano
caruana yesterday Fabiano I have to say
it came with some interesting opening
preparation but Wesley saw neutralized
that and in fact got a better position
well he took the easy way out and forced
a draw after a transition into the end
game nevertheless with the white pieces
today he will be trying to pile on the
pressure on his illustrous opponent four
wins four losses and 27 draws and take a
look at that they're his Fabiano caruana
the defending Champion as we are
entering this year's Edition and we can
see the two Arbiters there Christopher
and Judith starai as well Westminster
following closely behind and in the
ladies section we have the dominant
Irina crush the only Grand Master in at
the event while she started off this
tournament blazing hot 2-0 against
abrahamian and scored a crushing Victory
against Tokyo jonova yesterday she will
have to defend to win the match with the
black pieces today let's take a look at
their head to head as we are entering
this second day of their match three
wins for Irina Crush no losses and two
draws and in fact two of those wins have
arrived at the American Cup last year
she won one of their matches this year
she started off with an important
Victory and the other match that we have
in store for you is this big clash
between the 13 years old Alice Lee
against the two-time U.S Champion Naji
paikizen one win no losses for Alice Lee
and yesterday's draw guys we have a lot
of class coaches but potentially also we
will have playoffs later on today to see
who's going to go go on to the next
round a lot of highlights indeed but I
had a hiccup I forgot to ask you what
about the format for these double
eliminations well let's remind ourselves
because there are indeed two different
formats for the different brackets in
the Champions brackets the players are
playing a classical game of 90 minutes
plus 30 second increments in it's in the
elimination bracket when you're on your
last life so to speak the things get
really really spicy because you're
playing only a rap two rapid games of 25
minutes plus the 10 second increments
and you know there's also a lot of money
in the pots for 300 000 price fund and
her schedule yes and as we know the
players in the elimination bracket are
actually taking a well-deserved rest
today so all the focus will be on the
championship bracket and there we're
going to see one classical game and if
the match is tied we are going to see
playoffs where things get fast they get
furious they get fun and they'll be two
game rapid playoffs 10 minutes plus five
seconds wonderful as we see the players
getting ready for battle Lanier
Dominguez with the white pieces today
against the top seed Hikaru Nakamura and
like we've been seeing I mean it's it's
really hard for these players to
overcome what I could only describe as
really great uh defense Sterling defense
uh yesterday Hikaru did manage to win a
pawn but the Fortress that Lanier set up
was
was great it was no breaking through so
even you know that extra Pawn wasn't
enough for Hikaru let's see if they'll
go into playoffs but another thing that
we've seen yesterday is also that these
players can create Chances with the
black pieces Western so defended nicely
sure maybe Fabiano took some unnecessary
risks in the opening but if the player
with the white pieces does that then the
player with the black pieces definitely
has the power to potentially get the
advantage exactly
and then of course in the ladies section
uh begum is the only player with her
back to the wall she must win as you
both have explained and this matchup
again Alice Lee came into this uh uh
match 2-0 and the Victory she had
achieved with the black pieces
was described as a 2800 tournament
performance it was a remarkable her
accuracy was off the chart yeah I mean
what can we say she's just 13 years old
big big Talent Big Hope for American
future
under there we see Arena crash getting
ready now I have to say one thing in
naji's favor is that she's actually come
to this tournament incredibly well
prepared she's been springing the
surprises she plays in a very active
aggressive style and someone who is also
promised us that they're going to be in
an aggressive mood is Arena as she faces
begum who is in a must win situation
playing with the white pieces she did
say that she will match fire with fire
if Bear game decides to be ultra
aggressive with the white pieces well
she can do that as well
and I do believe uh their office the uh
Arbiter Chief uh Arbiter Sicilian
by Hikaru
that is unexpected right okay and Lanier
kind of just like okay uh that's nice
no joke of pianos okay Knight C6 is a
kind of a
a Prelude to this fashnikov
[Music]
yeah no E4 okay okay wait what linear
what I like about him is that he's a man
of principle you know he really believes
in his openings he says I've done the
hard work
come test me and now he's not afraid of
going into open Sicilians Knight takes
night are we gonna see E5 on the board
yes
we're not a special cough yet uh
potentially a Kalashnikov that's how I
call it as well is that is
is that the actual name of it yes yes
yeah D7 D6 so without the inclusion of
Knight F6 and Knight C3 we call this the
kalajnika so the the subtle difference
if I can
the subtle difference is I can put it
like that is black is not in played the
move Knight F6 and Knight C3 yet the
difference is so for example white now
has this opportunity of playing the move
C2 C4 and the difference is that black
hasn't stepped in front of his Pawn with
his Knight and sometimes the move F 7 F5
can lead to
uh let's say a very very sharp play uh
this is one of those uh openings uh
Christian that I want to say the better
prepared player usually comes out on top
no absolutely
um and it does seem like uh Hikaru
definitely had this one in store before
the event probably prepared it at home
for many many days with his uh second
Chris Littlejohn and Sam Shanklin was
mentioning this as well it's very
important that they study before the
event a certain particular opening here
Sam Shanklin did that with the Berlin
defense and we could see how big the
difference was between his understanding
and Ray robson's understanding of the
opening and this is probably what Hikaru
is banking on in this game this is a
surprise of course Knight to F6 Knight
to C3 and Danny 5 and going into the
schwarznikov is the typical way to play
this but as you were mentioning Yasser
that Knight is not yet on F6 I'm going
to be able to maybe play Bishop to E7
Bishop to E6 then F5
Knight 1 to C3 no C4 so
this is asking a clear question let's
see H6 followed by B5
push the Knight to D5 and how are you
going to attack that Knight with Bishop
to E6 there are no Bishop to E6 no B5
Bishop to E6
still the Knight is not on F6 still F5
is lingering in the position well the
the difference between playing B5 and
not is Crystal Clear when you play the
move B5 and you're threatening B5 B4
you're forcing the Knight to the D5
Square when you haven't played B5 this
offside Knight on A3 is given the chance
to jump to C4 and I always thought
probably it's old thing that it's a
mistake to allow it's a mistake by black
to allow white the opportunity of
playing Knight C4 but maybe the latest
and greatest in opening Theory uh says
that's not the case uh Christian uh
drill down on the position what would
happen after night there is no latest
and greatest yeah it's just the latest
and greatest in how strong the engines
actually are and this is what we're
seeing right now new engines popping up
on the market and just giving us a
completely different assessment of
certain positions that previously we
thought sure they are much better for
white you're not supposed to allow this
Knight to C4 Knight to E3 idea because
then you're going to control both very
very important squares D5 and F5 and
that's going to give white a clear
advantage and sure that's what the
encyclopedia was saying that's what the
rather new wish engines are saying but
the ones that came up like stockfish 15
maybe a month ago who knows maybe Hikaru
took that engine started analyzing with
it let it go to quite deep into the
position and understood that it's not
that bad and we're seeing that
Phenomenon with a lot of openings
nowadays pretty much anything can be
played if you go deep enough into the
variation and this is exactly what
Hikaru is doing right now Knight to C4
B5 Knight to E3 seems to be the main
line then most likely you will be going
with the Knight to F6 and after Bishop
to D3 to defend the pawn on e4 because I
have a threat I'm threatening to go B4
and then the pawn on e4 is is going to
be unprotected if you do go Bishop to D3
then I haven't played Bishop E7 yet so I
have the extra option once again extra
options everywhere to play the move G6
I'm sure Hikaru knows this Hikaru knows
his opening preparation very very well
as we will see in just a second Knight
to C4
wait what's happening it seems like
Chris bird is there a light went out
over their uh board and it seems like
they're going to try to fix that before
they restart the game Chris bird just
stopped the clock for for the moment
yeah slight shade uh on uh the position
I remember I think it was Curacao uh the
candidates were the lights went out they
stopped the clock and it was something
like Bobby I was thinking uh there we go
back in business back in business Bobby
was thinking and his opponent complained
that Bobby's thinking so his clock
should be ticking and Bobby said like
yeah okay go ahead start the clock
to B8
this is what I'm telling you I mean who
would have thought about this move Rook
to B8 tennis B Rook to ba is that a
novelty
no no no
before it's not a novel yeah
I mean if somebody had played Rook B8 50
years ago they would have said dude you
know like what's wrong with you that's
like like what kind of move is that
you're you're not paying attention to
the D5 squared right the D5 and and
you're getting killed you know uh wow
Rook to B8 break that one down for us
because I don't know a few minutes
I'm not even sure what's happening it
has been played before no I was looking
through the games and through the names
of the players playing this with the
black pieces and I see some very
enterprising players one of them is
dubov dubov we know he has enterprising
uh ideas in the opening and I remember
Hikaru and dubov played a lot of matches
uh online in like chess 24 the Champions
chess tour and things of that nature and
I remember their clash in the dragon if
I'm not mistaken and dubavo was coming
with some very intriguing ideas some
rookie eight moves later on and move 20
in the dragon and getting very good
results against Hikaru so maybe he got
some inspiration from that and right now
we're seeing uh that play out this movie
was playing Mark shootulu is a big
proponent of the this idea adiban as
well so it has definitely been tried at
the elite level and it does seem to work
Rook to B8 I would assume is going to
try to support the push of the B Pawn
you can go A4 and now we understand why
Rook to B8 might help in the future
because B5 later on I still feel that I
have to put my king to safety first
before I start going B5 and expand on
the queen side if I don't do that that
King only eight I mean you're so far
behind in development on the king side
you're going to have problems so go
Knight F6 go G6 Bishop G7 castle and
then at the right moment you're going to
play this move B5 and try to expand on
the queen side Bishop to E3 is also a
move in the position and now once again
we understand the usefulness of the
rookon B8 after B5 there's no more
Knight to B6 Knight to B6 followed by
Knight to D5 so you have to drop back to
D2 we don't have a move yet
he's still thinking Lanier that is he
probably will be thinking for quite a
while try to remember his opening
preparation this is one of those lines
that you don't actually look at it
almost at all sure
variation once every five years seven
years whatnot you've analyzed it back in
2015 and now you're trying to remember
what the engines back in those days were
saying or your seconds right
um the the first move that kind of came
come to comes to my mind I appreciate
your Bishop E3 it might be Bishop E3 and
Knight B6 to uh control the B6 Square
it's like the Knight on C4 is not going
to take this Pawn on D6 it's just not no
so 93 so I'm I basically I moved my I
shifted how you liked me yeah I
recognizing that I've shifted my knight
from A3 to E3 which is usually what
white really aspires to and I'm glad you
to play Rook B8 which I don't know how
useful that move is so after Knight E3
I'm assuming Knight F6 yes and I want to
do something a little bit different I
want to control the D5 Square from afar
I'd like to play the move G3 with the
idea of Bishop G2 castles one day I'm
gonna sink my knight in on the D5 Square
maybe I'm going to tease you and play
for F4 uh is this Theory still I I'm
assuming it is with the move G3 I'm not
100 sure yes
Bishop D3 and you said nothing
underneath the side there's nothing new
Under the Sun I went three two three is
definitely a move well 245. no no 22
games
22 games have you played in this
position the main move is H5
I was thinking that black would just
continue normal right
so so this is what I'm thinking this
move Rook to B8 yes doesn't really
damage my position at all it gets ready
to not be attacked by ideas of Bishop to
E3 Knight to B6 and also I guess over
that move B5 it has the advantage that
the quantum B5 is not going to be a
Target later on so white will not have
ideas of potentially weakening black
structure on the queen side with the
move A4 this is my guess and this is why
I'm saying that because the main line
goes like this Knight to F6 after Knight
to E3 and then let's say Bishop to D3
right now the best move according to the
engine is Rook to C8
so you play The Rook to B8 then you play
Rook to C8 obviously focusing on the
Square uh C4 maybe Knight to A5 Knight
to C4 is an idea Knight to B4 to grab
this bishop on D3 as well could be an
idea and you don't have you're not over
expanded on the queen side with that
pawn on B5 there's no A4 there's no
weaknesses on the queen side this is
what I think black's idea behind this
Rook to B8 is so it's like a waiting
move so to speak it's just giving the
move yes making a semi-useful move to
not weaken my position with the move B5
also not show my hand will I put the
Knight on F6 will I play F5 later on
this is the type of uh dance that's been
going on right now in the opening phase
well it's funny that you use this word
uh not to weaken my position the move B7
B5 could weaken the structure in the
sense that A4 may occur but oftentimes
in this version of calf the move B5 is a
very useful weapon that's right in terms
of keeping the white sites you know
under control and oftentimes B5 B4 comes
as counter play
you say Rook B8 doesn't weaken the
position but I would argue
it is a wasted move you you have an
opportunity of doing something useful
like Knight F6 or Bishop E7 instead you
played Rook B8 and then three moves
later you said oh I'll play Rook C8 so I
would say hey dude you know you're just
wasting uh your ply this is how I'm
seeing it go so if you play Bishop E7
you no longer have G6 Bishop G7
so you took away that option I lose the
arm yourself right if you play Knight F6
you no longer have the option of playing
F5 so that takes away something right as
well this move worked to B8 doesn't
really take anything away from your
position either right but and we've seen
that Rook to B8 maybe some next move
you're going to play Rook to C8 right
it just seems like one of those
semi-useful moves okay uh the Intriguing
uh
yeah I'll we'll definitely keep a close
eye on this let's just uh can we please
check out the game between Wesley so
let's do the honor because so this once
again is the nimso Indian classical
Wesley opened up with D4 Pawn you know
because I always like to see and observe
how these top players open the will
start the game a lot of the time is E4
but I I think he was like no I don't
want to face fabi's Petrov defense one
more time I'm instead going to
guaranteed D4 and challenge there
because Ray Robson in there in in the
fabriano Carolina Ray Robson game did
manage to get a slight pull
uh this particular move order by uh
Wesley with the whole Queen A4 check
followed by Queen to C6 was to induce
black to play the move Queen D7 the idea
is that the queen is worse
on the D7 squared then on the d8 Square
because principally you're stepping in
the knights path uh the square is
occupied uh having said that the to my
eyes the way of taking advantage of the
fact that the queen is no longer on d8
in the night cannot be supported by its
colleague is you want to play the move
Bishop G5 I have seen Gary Kasparov uh
playing H2 H4 and other kind of crazy
things but this move Bishop G5 followed
by Rook C1 would have would be the move
that gets my attention and after Bishop
G5 strangely enough
um a lot of the games that are in our
database uh black ignores the the double
pawns on the king side says go ahead if
you want to play Bishop takes F6 I'm not
concerned by that and C7 C5 is the main
move there shall we have a look at the
ladies definitely and uh
so let's start off with Arena Crush
because she's been very impressive in
this tournament so far starting off with
three decisive games here we are and yes
indeed Arena has been
magnificent okay this is a queen's Camp
it accepted from a very
clever little move order so after the
move A7 A6 if we see the move D to D4 we
could transpose into the game between
Wesley so and a Fabi from a uh yesterday
she played Bishop E2 this bishop E2 I
guess she's anticipating that she will
be able to play A4 against an immediate
B5 so Arena said okay I'll play Knight
C6 D4 and it transposes uh uh into uh
yeah into one of these
um yeah I was going to say and those
games
are actually quite difficult for both
sides to play I have to say exactly
because after Pawn takes porn yep
obviously you're going to capture back
with I would say with the pawn yes you
know and also Bear game is in a must-win
situation so keep the pieces keep the
pieces on the board right and it's funny
that you say Pawn takes Pawn because of
course that is the old English
descriptive right right how do you say
it C takes E4 it takes D4 because Pawn
takes Pawn is the all you when when
you're writing down your move you don't
go Pawn cakes are you telling everyone
better mode
I was raised on the descriptive notation
algebraic was tough to make the
transition a lot of my score sheets
featured both Bishop takes bishop and
Bishop takes F6
they saw my score sheet and said
what on Earth is this woman or this girl
doing it and then they said please can
you use the algebraic and then I go my
father came and he said okay explain
here's how to do it okay but yeah C
takes D4 he takes D4 and we have an
isolated Queen Pawn then this particular
case Bishop E7 I don't I'm not a fan of
the bishop being on E2 I understand you
want to keep the pieces on the board but
is the bishop the most effective Square
I'd say no I would also say no as well
but then you know it's
a light Square Bishop that black has you
know the C8 it's not going to get out
for a while a long time I mean I've seen
ways that you can get out by Bishop D7
Bishop C6 weakening with B5 carries an
element of risk yep obviously that is
the dream if you can get away with it
please do it but 35 Bishop B7 exactly so
and perhaps this is why that Bishop only
2 will play an active role because I can
transfer it to F3 really quickly so
maybe after a B5 I have ideas of Knight
to E5 immediately
so you can take take and then also after
you take on D4 I have the option of
taking with the Knight on uh D4
yeah I wasn't a fan of that one
Christian
it's a movie it has been played I was
checking that basically both of them
have been played
um
but the idea behind Bishop to E2 is
clear that you want to potentially put
that Bishop on F3 on the long diagonal
and stop black from easily playing this
B5 followed by Bishop to B7 which is
ideal setup if they manage to do so uh I
noticed about before so we're going to
get an answer as to what she's going to
take back uh while Arena was thinking I
I know there's also a way for black here
actually to kind of slow play the
position where the move Queen C7 yeah
the idea is you're basically saying to
White it's your turn what what would you
like to do in this position it would you
like to capture well in this case then
you're not you you haven't done anything
and queen C7 is one of those useful
Tempe do you want to play H3 well
eventually I will capture on D4 so it's
like what's your most useful move after
the move Queen C7 Arena didn't do that
she captured uh quickly he takes and
Bishop E7 and I would say we're are on a
familiar ground you know that it's uh
it's an isolated Queen Pawn uh Bishop E2
well that's not going to decide the game
one way or not I don't think so I mean
if I have to pick a side I would
probably pick white because I quite like
the idea as Christian indicated of just
reinforcing the protection of the D4 and
jump in with the Knight to E5
and again ask the question how are you
going to develop your light squared
bishop and I can see some big names who
came up on our screen I see I'll tell
you again sir
yeah Bishop D7 again the bishop has no
great shakes on on the Square uh D7 but
slowly slowly you know you kind of want
to play night before in Bishop C6 big
names but also Beckham has played this
game before Oh really yes I just saw her
uh her name there she played it I
believe it was 2022 May 20 May of 2022
so not long time ago with Bishop E3 she
followed uh I believe Castle was the
move played by her opponent and then she
followed it up with Rook to C1 right
Rook to C1 Knight to B4 as you were
mentioning did lose that game so perhaps
she will have some sort of improvement
in mind over her previous game in mind
exactly let's wait and see she played
the move A3
A3 well there you go that does stop the
move that we were just looking at the
rerouting of the night the weakness of
the isolated Queen Pawn isn't so much
the fact that the pawn itself is weak as
so much that it can't attack the square
in front of it so I think we also allows
black one extra Tempo and allows her to
potentially go short Castle let's say
first okay you go Bishop to a e3 to
defend the pawn on D4 okay and finally
now I have time to go B5
get the setup that I really want B5
followed by Bishop to B7 so that after
night here you play Bishop B7 perhaps
Bishop
B7 and then look to C8 just defend
the complex as it is right
intriguing uh well we'll keep an eye on
this one as it'll it's on a slow boil as
for for the moment and let's jump to the
game of Alice Lee and Naji because
um this was turning out to be a big
strategical battle exactly the slav
defense very very topical stuff that the
ladies are playing definitely and after
work C8
I love this move a C4 C5 because I've
always loved uh long complex strategic
fights and this move C5 kind of lays
down a gauntlet and it says I'm
capturing space on the queen side
try your best do something against me if
you do nothing I will continue to expand
with B4 Bishop E2 castles and eventually
one day I'll get in B5 yeah so you're
virtually required as black to either go
Hog Wild on the king side you know G5 G4
and get your space or to break in the
center with uh E6 to E5 I like this
decision C5 rather than Rook D1 or some
of the other you know crafty little
moves but sometimes you just gotta take
the bull by the horns and say this is
what I'm playing for what are you doing
I I agree with you I mean the White's
position carries a lot of poison because
like you've indicated yeah I mean if
white gets in I was told many years ago
if you just get an F4 B for your and the
words were winning
you could have some Adventures along the
way but ultimately you're winning so
then the question becomes uh do you play
for E5 right away and if you do play for
E5 you know again it's sort of like what
is your follow-up are you you're not
frightening me necessarily uh by taking
the pawn and if you say okay you got
your queen side play I've got my Center
play I say well your Center is not
bothering anybody I don't have a knight
you don't have a king that's uh just a
sanded stranded rather on the king side
instead you can just live with the king
in the middle right and bulldoze let's
go let's go uh with the the pawn attack
okay uh that's a that's a very nice game
uh we'll keep an eye on both of these as
we return to uh the open section and
indeed uh Wesley did play the move
Bishop G5 and a C5 came quickly D4 takes
C5 and Rook C8 also I noted that Rook C8
instead of the immediate C5 has also
been played so I guess they're
transpositional yes now in this case
sorry please yeah no I was just going to
indicate the clock times are telling us
one story that Fabiana carrona is in
preparation I'm sure he is sure both
players are actually in the uh unless
those burn a little bit more time well
Wesley has played this game already has
he harrow in 2016. and how did the game
go question it was a draw it was a draw
yes yes I would assume Bishop takes F6
was the game yes Bishop takes F6 G takes
F6 Rook to D1 yes Rook to D1 Queen 37
yeah Queen to E7 E3 or E4 and then some
exchanges of the bishop take back on C5
and it seems like black is going to be
able to get her uh pieces out in his
pieces out in time in this situation
Wesley most likely is right now trying
to figure out the way to complicate
matters or perhaps he's just trying to
figure out the way how to pull the
brakes and go to the playoffs
um they started two options
interestingly you say that about the
playoffs because I was kind of looking
at the last few games in Rapid because
obviously that must be running through
the player's minds and
you know these 2021 2022 so Fabiano
consistently beat Wesley in these rapid
Blitz
exactly I would not have guessed that
either because you know Fabi I can
remember commentating on this Grand
chest tour events and he was doing
really badly and everyone was like it's
not his time control right but uh you
know he's really focused on that on this
and improved considerably wow I mean
there's some great games in the grand
chest or between the two yeah no he got
that reputation because of the tie
breaks from the world championship match
in London but anybody I mean can lose to
Magnus in the Thai you know in in a
rapid but undeservedly so he certainly
has improved
but in Rapid chess now that you mention
it no no this is
but let's take a look at how they do
oh it's well maybe you're talking about
the recent no I'm talking about 21 22
I'm not talking about that overall
because because I said because I because
I suspect that that that Wesley may have
run up the score in those years
2014-16-18 but uh recently Bobby's been
closing the Gap I wanted to ask you uh
about this position
um Christian because you were saying mix
it up playoffs what have you uh
uh help me out here if I play the move
Knight E5
okay and uh tickle the queen you're
already worse yes I'm worse
did I do much worse after Queen D5 Queen
isn't that remarkable because that was
the move I was I thought you wanted to
see on that I I I wanted to provoke it
because thank you for it yeah that's
right
you might be entering losing territories
amazing Queen to G5
aha defends the pawn on F6 after I take
on uh C5 I will have ideas of Rook to C1
you cannot go wandering around with your
queen to A4 yeah you get checkmated I'm
sorry I I I've missed the transfer of
Queen to G5 I I just thought in my
mind's eye that this was going to
provoke Knight D7 and I was going to
play a dangerous position for white as
well because you haven't finished your
development through the king side that's
true quite problematic if I manage to go
root 85 and Knight to C6 you're going to
be in trouble everything comes with
tempo for uh black and your king is not
safe I remember this game I believe it
was Fabiano with the black pieces at the
U.S Championship where he uh demolished
out of the opening Hans Neiman got a
very nice position out of the opening in
this particular setup of the nimsa with
Queen to C2 and went on to win uh that
game so he's definitely I would call him
an expert already in this type of
structures he knows what he's doing I
have a feeling what's this all has to be
careful in this one okay and help me out
once more if I play the very attractive
rookie one I think everybody would like
to pick up a Tempo against the queen
that's right Dr D1 Queen to E7 and now
let me just do something as simple as
sidestepping the uh pin along the C file
I'll go Queen D2 I'm inviting you to
play Rook take C5 and that will probably
be met by Queen d8 shag if you take with
the queen well Bishop F6 and queen H6
starts to be I will not I will go either
B take C5 or Knight to D7 or even Knight
to C6 and you know what all of these
moves supposedly give black the
advantage come on I'm trying my best
that's why I'm saying it's nice
it's a dangerous position you sidestep
one move wow
from the beaten path and and you're in
trouble help me here
I thought it was going to play Queen D6
best move yes best move and now after
Queen takes D6 C takes D6 Rook to C2
maybe you're very close to uh finding in
quality though black still seems to be
the one in charge right
okay well it's a wild position I I I
shouldn't try to create something new
Under the Sun this early uh for me
um Rook D1 Queen E7 and then black is
better
yeah yeah but I know that's shocking it
doesn't surprise me not after Queen E7
but after Queen to D2 for sure black has
the upper hand wow it doesn't surprise
me because you know these positions are
so Dynamic I mean Black's pieces are all
out his King is safe whites King three
moves from castling yes yes and uh you
know you know the Magnus Carlson right
right yeah your king is one move away
from castling it's okay two moves um
you're in trouble yeah okay
wow okay uh stunning and the and the
clock times yeah the clock times all
indicate that for piano is in his
preparation and Wesley is the one
Wesley's the one who's uncertain exactly
okay uh back to Lanier in ikara for a
moment because uh I was more than
curious how Lanier was going to meet the
move Rook B8 and he met it with what
would be everybody's appropriate
response Knight D5 I mean okay I'm
occupying is a flash Bishop takes D
Bishop takes when you think you're
surprised your opponent he goes nope
absolutely not okay uh you were working
with Fabi in his world championship
match where it was like they were
getting these kinds of
um this version of cough-like positions
where the majorities uh White had the
queen side majority they're very
concrete yes yes so it's so concrete and
very often the engine is saying that
white has and and this was kind of a
thing that the thing over the past that
I I want to forget you know uh the
engine was saying that white is doing
well and sometimes black was sacrificing
one even two pawns at times and getting
incredible play on the king side this is
uh the big big
um branding of this position you want to
go 97 F5 Knight F6 get the bishop out
via G7 most likely G6 uh Bishop G7 and
after that castle and swarm white on the
king side and it's not that easy despite
the fact that white has a nice majority
and nice space advantage on the queen
side is not as easy without an engine
specifically to play this one from a
human's perspective very good decision
by linear he didn't think for a very
long time he understood that he has to
take with the pawn taking with the queen
would have been very very bad for his
position if he would have taken with a
queen after Knight to D4 he's in trouble
Knight to D4 first almost trapped the
queen but also look at the pawn on C2 of
course he's he's a very strong player
he's not going to miss this type of
things right he took with the pawn on uh
D5 we're going to see Knight to E7 we
have seen it in fact we have seen Knight
and this is what I'm seeing Hikaru has
one hour and 34 minutes on his clock
he's still within his opening knowledge
and preparation and linear one hour in
three minutes and Counting big surprise
maybe given some objective advantage to
White
but it's not going to be easy for a
linear to demonstrate how to continue
and increase his advantages
my Bishop with G3 you're G3 yeah you're
so close are you want to go one square
forward I wanted to get the grab no yeah
because Christian inspired me Christian
said Christians said he black wants to
play F5 and Knight F6 and G6 so I
thought to myself okay I'll play G4
you're not gonna play F5 because that's
not what uh why not you're gonna get him
well because it's a new variation well
yeah baby yeah the sarawan attack right
because I'll take and go Bishop H3 but
if you play Knight F6 then Jovi I was
gonna borrow a page from you from your
book which said okay now I'll see in
Shadow but look at this I'll get G5 in
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay G4 I'll give you the credit you're
skeptic it's good it's a good move and
it's a novelty
okay my certificates of participation we
have given it away come on man you know
uh evaluate all the secrets it's all
about the audience I mean giving the
viewers what they need for you know that
extra ELO friendship
hey but uh
G4 does have
something to be said for because
I bet you Hikaru was 134 would melt down
that's just you for one of the things
that I thought would have been a mistake
and would be to allow this type of a
variation you do not want to reach for
your g-pawn this would be a deep
embarrassment after Queen H5 check right
yep I think we've all fallen for that
once or twice or Thrice or in my life
maybe 12 times
so you don't want to play F5 but
there's something going on here
okay but you like G3 and you like G3 for
uh a completely different reason which
was just a fiend Shadow get your get
your king to safety yeah get the king to
safety and then
and then you know
wait okay but you're you you're you're
Trump that white has is his Queen side
majority right if there was a pawn for
example on A5 you would be very quick to
play the move Knight B6 followed by C4
yeah so that's your majority at the
moment you could say your Trump is not
being utilized yeah and so black for his
part is ready to go Bishop G7 castles E4
and be careful maybe the pawn on D5
isn't as well protected as you'd hoped
that's that's true but I I do like your
plan of going A4 A4 okay I mean if you
go B5 you give me the chance to open up
a line and jump in with my knight to a
that's why I'm not going to be worried
about that well and then here here I
borrow a page from why the Rook on B8
might actually be of use
because I am kind of slowing down your
whole Queen side Rush right with uh if I
can maintain the pawn on B6 for a long
time it's not so easy for you to go B4
C4
C5 can I try to do it anyway like Rook
to B1 maybe yes exactly Rook to B1 just
try to go for B4 dang yes I've got my
eyes on the B6 Pawn
oh well there's not you you may have
your eye on the A5 Pawn but you can't
yeah I'm gonna have the B6 I'm going to
put it yeah because I'm going to open it
okay well let's see so our Castle you'll
take okay
B5 Rook B5 okay good so it's not the B6
Pawn that you're after I'm after the D5
Pawn you're after the A5 Bond now I'm
going to start looking at Bishop B6
ideas okay
seven
it's it's a double ticket
after you've also got F3 as well chip
away at the Santa but that's where the
whole F3 F4 black will play f
you know this is where Magnus showed
that you know those type of sacrifices
yeah he can get some King side action
going yeah but the G3 move you know does
make that nice little uh Fortress uh for
your king a double-edged game uh I'd be
very curious to see uh how that would
unravel
yeah and uh in case you've just joined
us shame on you first of all you're
missing out some really great stuff yeah
where have you been you have been
missing out on a fiery start and here is
the situation when it comes to the
Champions bracket so Karu Nakamura and
Dominguez after yesterday's game also
tied as our Wesley so and Fabiano
Carolina so whoever wins today or
actually automatically go through to the
next stage in a Champions bracket yeah
and if the match is tied playoff time
when it comes to the women
we can see that Arena crash did take an
early lead against Tori Genova and she
is therefore in a must-win situation
must win with white pieces and when it
comes to Naji paikitsa and the 13 year
old Alice Lee which I have to keep
repeating because it's Sensational the
match was tied after game one and
everything to play for today Naji does
have white pieces and if you do want to
share with us the fun enjoy the action
as always remember you can do this by
sending us your tweets using the hashtag
the American Cup
indeed and join the conversation but we
we we we we we long to be put on our
toes you know we have a tweet over three
oh whoa unleash it this one is from
and I'll read out it says it's a
question for yasa oh there you go did
you get to know David bromstein what is
your opinion about his game style
exactly well first of all thank you so
much uh for your question and David
Branch team was for me one of the great
Legends of Chess and there's no such
thing as a David bronstein style because
David bronstein was
truly Universal he played so much and I
remember
one of my very first Encyclopedia of
chess openings they had the ecos the
oracles as we used to call them these
five volume books and they've broken
down all the openings into these five
segments ABCD and E and I remember just
going through the notes I didn't like
the table so much as I like the notes
and they would always have bronstein
and it was like what so across all of
these openings David bronstein had ideas
in all of them and it was like it was
just amazing I've got a lot a lot of
David bronstein stories to tell you but
one in particular that really made a
very strong impression on me it was in
The Hague in Holland
and David came to me and he said uh yeah
sir can I ask you for a favor I said
sure like well what is it you would like
he said well I'm staying at a friend's
home and he has your book would you
please sign it for him
and I said well sure of course I will
what's his name and so I personalized
and signed it and I gave it to David and
David said no no no
don't give it to me give it to him
directly from your hands to his hands
and it just struck me as this was such
old school manners you know I was like
David yes thank you for taking care of
my friend David bronstein you're welcome
bye yeah that was it but it was this the
these really really old school way and
he he wore a French beret anyway I could
talk all day about David bronstein truly
one of the great outstanding
Personalities in chess and uh has a
fantastic life story as well definitely
well worth reading about yes uh and also
the source of one of my very first and
most favorite books uh opening theory
and practice theory and practice about
the candidates uh world championship
tournament I wanted to turn our
attention to Wesley thank you very much
for the question I wanted to turn our
attention to the Wesley so game because
I was very curious how Wesley would
handle it he did go about the game with
Rook D1 Queen E7 E2 E4 and immediately
popped up a lot of very very big names
including Vladimir kramnik after E4 and
Rook take C5 I think is the well or
Bishop takes F1 pardon me are the two
moves right Rook takes C5 Bishop takes
F1 yeah King takes
C5 now where do we go uh Queen to D3 I
like your idea Queen to D3 oh do you
want to be safe or maybe it's because of
an open position be safe you know also
also because you know you must be in a
must not lose situation because if
Wesley loses this that's it he falls
down the determination you don't want to
be doing that can we move it to E2 I
Like Queenie too because really one of
the the things I really fancy about
White's position is this uh this threat
this Sword of Damocles which is hanging
over Black's position I'm going to play
the move E4 E5 and I if if I had played
Queen D3 I thought maybe I'm wrong that
you'd have Knight D7 and I'm not
threatening e for e45 as as much but but
Queenie to it I'm seeing has been played
a couple of times and black plays H7 H6
and
more or less it's balanced yeah but you
still have to answer the questions where
are you going to put the pieces because
that Bishop it's been asked the question
right and uh let's suppose I take you're
gonna take it okay yeah and then let's
suppose uh I'm one of those people who
like a safe King I don't like my Rook uh
on H1 so the the nice part in this
particular case is I don't think your
night is supremely Happy on C6 I think
it would be more happier on the F6
Square so G3
the night has to come out to see sex
okay King up and I don't think I can
make much of anything here but I'm I
might try to say I have a nibble I don't
believe it but uh maybe I can con you
[Laughter]
know it feels balance yeah and let's go
uh oh G3
no one has has had the four sides to
play G2 G to G4 oh
with the inclusion though of the move B5
which is something that I thought we
were trying to avoid as black I thought
that the whole idea of Rook B8 was to uh
not necessarily create this uh weakness
uh now that he's put his uh uh sore
thumb out here a Christian isn't that an
invitation for A4 yeah of course you can
play the move A4 but are you in time to
create any danger against people on the
B5 and that's once again why my rookie
is on B8 so let's say I just go Bishop
to H6 or Bishop to uh G7 let's say
Bishop to H6
yeah
yeah no a b a b e
that makes a lot of sense I guess Bishop
to G2 and then let's say F5 it just
makes
the most sense in the position the
engine's move is Knight to F6 but I feel
F5 is more by the the previous moves
yeah and castles and I'm assuming and
now we might have seen Knight F6 yes
yeah yes and now that I have the open a
file uh great right I'm not sure you can
do much with it because whenever it
comes to A7 and maybe it's the best move
right now yeah I can always challenge it
with Rook to A8 ah right and if you take
I take now I have control of the a file
I also have some nice pressure on D5
after I play the movie for this Pawn on
D5 is going to be quite feeble so it's
not an easy position and once again I'm
super impressed by the fact that Hikaru
is still not out of his theoretical
knowledge he has 1 hour and 33 minutes
and well linear is down to his last 52
minutes so
big big huge time advantage and momentum
for Hikaru nakamurai in this game if you
don't mind me asking has there been a
novelty uh up to this moment I mean if
so where was it uh perhaps B5 might have
been the novelty yeah B5 seems to have
been the novelty okay so we were
discussing this position and we were
definitely looking after G3 AT G6 maybe
F5 B5 is the engines uh Choice as well
so Hikaru definitely has analyzed this
B5 Knight to E3 G6 I don't see any games
in the database B5 seems to have been
the novelty it doesn't mesh very well as
you were mentioning as with your
previous move Rook to p8 right at least
not visually and logically right right
but if you go deeper with the engine
analysis this is where you get to at the
idea that B5 is a good move yeah but I'm
I don't know I'm not convinced
[Laughter]
because I'm thinking and look at this
position I'm thinking yeah I understand
that white actually can't just sit on
their Laurels and just go Bishop G2
Castle blah blah blah so I'm thinking
you know I want to refine this idea of
going A4 okay and you know I kind of
inspired by you you know you came up
with G4 well thank you very much I'm
going to come up with B4 B4 B4 okay B4
oh boy
B4 okay
do tell us uh I will play Bishop G6 then
I'll go Bishop B2 Bishop boy two yeah
Bishop B2 and you can wait for it A4 is
my idea okay so with the pawn on B4 you
get to play Rook A5 in certain yeah
positions okay that's fine okay
keep okay okay and now you got here
you're gonna take and play Rook A5 yeah
okay let's do it Rook too well you know
I was just kind of saying that yeah
I mean it's the natural Fallout to your
to what you're doing uh it okay for me
it's double edged why because I
understand you're going after me my beep
on but I really wanted to go after your
Depot right so I I was thinking that
F5 F4 driving away the defender of the
night would lead to very sharp positions
and these aren't the exact positions
that I was analyzing and I was quite
worried about you do take the pawn on B5
but then what then my attack is coming
especially since you're probably going
to give some resources on the queen side
on the queen side and how about your
light squares on the king side you play
G3 you're most likely going to Castle
there it's going to be a slow burden and
my attack is going to come fast on the
queen side I I don't like these
positions yeah I I take it back
I agree I'm with you 100 I will be
honest
flashbacks of that game
against Magnus Carlson and queen C8
right it's not fun uh but before uh boy
that I mean we're we're on the extreme
A4 A4 was played yes okay and uh there
was something uh I always called it the
extended fee in Shadow so if you played
Bishop G7 you fan shadowed your Bishop
but oftentimes they didn't play Bishop
B7
they would play Bishop A6 especially at
least Queens India and I always call
that the extended
fee and Shadow you put your Bishop on H6
uh uh Christian uh did it in our
previous little analysis there and in
this particular case you could
understand why Bishop H6 might be a more
attractive diagonal for the bishop than
the bishop on being on G7
does it form prey to kind of age right
whoops sorry H4 ideas H4 yeah
[Laughter]
we might both mess up our uh castling uh
privileges here because let's go F5
right yeah F5 yeah and then this is
you've got to kind of follow-up I kind
of have to don't I yeah so if I go
Knight F6 do you have some sort of
tactics well the idea was that she was
going to uh exploit the take take yeah
that's fine I take with the pawn
but what is the tactic yeah if you think
I think with the Knight and I defend on
it
I noticed uh and it certainly will come
and in the meantime sure
okay
uh well no I mean I was looking for a
tactic but I couldn't believe it
you know you can just say white Black's
king is not going to be safe like you
mentioned well the actually the funny
part was uh Christian was reaching for
the night and I had my eye on the idea
that I might fall victim to a tactic and
oftentimes I I don't mind putting my
king on G7 as a way of Defending The
Rook on h8 intriguing position going on
here I'm not really too sure how about
the the ladies what's going on in uh in
their match I really want to dive into
and I can see Christian has also got it
up there no no
against Alice because what just happened
in this game yeah what happened exactly
I mean take a look at that
okay look at this the she played Castle
makes a lot of sense right E5 with black
pieces you do have the two Bishops you
need to counter strike in the center
right right white uh wise plan is pretty
obvious you're going to put your pieces
on the queen side and then you're going
to try to expand as much as possible on
the king side against the potential
Castle on uh on the king side for black
Castle makes a lot of sense nevertheless
look at what Alice is doing
G4 saying okay I see a double attack I'm
going to pick up that pawn on H2
I'm a pond grubber but boy that mic is
on a gorilla Mission I mean it may never
get out
why not Bishop to E2
controlled upon uh the square F3 and
sure you're going to get the Knight to
F3 but after that I'm going to take take
get the Rook to H1
look at the h8 square and I have this
correcting idea into D1 Queen takes F3
I'm going to pick up the pawn and it
just seems like I'm going to have a much
better structure and an easy attack
coming against your King can You Castle
King side as black no can you Castle
Queen side as black no so your king is
going to be stuck in the center and I
have a clear break with the move E4 if
you try to stop that with the move F5 so
let's just make a couple of moves Queen
to D1 i36 Queen takes F3 if you do try
to stop that that break with the move F5
well that's sort of problematic because
I have the move G4 right you don't have
the light Square Bishop you don't have
enough resources to defend your light
squares
um around your king so I'm looking at
this position I'm not seeing any risks
associated with White's position I see a
lot of risks for a black in the position
I think this would have given why the
advantage she played Bishop to H3 right
but now this doesn't control the F3
Square so I guess so what if I just
looking for well well this was the trick
I think that Naji has in mind I must
play F4 right but I don't know Knight F3
and then Bishop to G4 and force you to
give up that Knight otherwise like you
said sure give you the Knight right are
you going to take here or take on D7
if you take only one I have time for F5
and I think this is going to be quite a
favorable favorable position for me
because I can stop you from playing G4
at least momentarily with the move
Knight to F6 but the bishop wouldn't go
to H3 it would go all the way back to D1
I'm sure yeah yeah and then you know I
don't care I'm going to
let's open you up on this side
part of the deal
yeah it says you're not supposed to
create counter chances I'm creating all
the counter chances that I can right now
okay it's not a beautiful pot the move
Bishop H3 is surprising because you
think Bishop E2 would be the move after
all the night on uh H2 uh doesn't have
any Retreat squares and you have to play
moves like E4 and or F5 in order to save
the Knight a little bit of a surprise
Bishop issue let's look a little deeper
guys so we're saying E4 is there Knight
takes E4 does she has some I was looking
at that but unfortunately you have F5 at
the end F5 F5 yeah I was about to play
Queen G2 and reclaim the piece and after
you're to continue
you don't get mate
[Laughter]
that's not going to give you that much
right no I mean I was I was hunting and
uh if I don't a piece is a piece after
all yes it is you can take a couple of
Pawns
actually sorry actually let's go back to
that that sacrifice yes okay because by
the way as a commentator I just love the
fact that I can sacrifice pieces
I suddenly thought what happens if you
just go the whole hog
go one more time
yeah but one of them is is going to be
rounded up not convinced I'm not
supposed to get to it I mean Rook H1
would be nice except for it's illegal
yeah I am missing that one yeah Tempo
yeah okay Queen D7 is coming yeah yeah
no um you don't have enough resources to
make your attack successful okay so
after if
or is there can we I'm
I'm looking at sacrifices maybe like
this one
I'm sorry
yeah
yeah no I was thinking that you kind of
had to go F4 first right and then again
that's a Tempo yeah so that it would
provoke data three
and then maybe now you could
well here I played the move Bishop G4 a
moment ago but
um
I mean the Knight doesn't have too many
squares could you get
five is coming everything but it's not
coming actually so go Bishop F2 I don't
think it's coming I think what's coming
is the opening of the position on the
other side okay but now there's like
doesn't that uh isn't that a different
uh kettle of fish yes uh bite on the
Apple here I mean
context Queen takes now you have to go
Knight H2 no that's a much better
version yeah then I've got Rook H1 and
something good is perfect issue even
Queen G2 I think wins oh of course
yeah so so I do have to get ready for
that with F5 yeah but if you go at five
then there's G4 in the air okay look at
that and that's that's dangerous what we
wanted uh previously
um one of the funny points is that in
this exact position Alice is under no
obligation to play E4 and she could
actually start with just start with
Knight F3 and in case you played the
move Bishop G4 then we can take and we
got our F5 and E4 in the proper way I
want to say so maybe Knight F3
um
is the way to go yes no it looks good
doesn't it I mean unless I feel this
compensation but I just don't know it's
I I you know the exact move order for
this is not an easy position to
calculate no uh from a human's
perspective let's go back to that
variation just show you guys what the
engine size is and why the engine
doesn't like this idea for white so
after E4 F4 Knight F3
Bishop to F2 yep we missed one detail we
can start with F5 okay all right you
allow them of G4 yep and now in order
not to be worse but to actually be much
better you go Knight F6 and when they
take on F5 you go 27. easy move to miss
from afar very easy D7 that's nasty if
you find this move you're almost winning
as black if you don't you're worse so
you can understand that from afar you're
not going to be able to understand all
these details and assess them correctly
this is the key in this type of
positions assessing very very deep
variations
okay well uh we'll we'll
Retreat
and do nothing less at the moment and uh
go to a game of Arena because Arena as
we came on the area she's just been on
fire uh three out of three she's CR she
cruised last year she got in trouble in
one particular game but all of her
matches were in the end rather
convincing she's been very convincing
thus far
she's got I want to say a kind of an
ideal position as far as you're playing
against the isolated Queen Pawn look at
Black's development looks really really
good right and somewhere begum has
played Bishop to C4 Bishop to E2 and
Bishop to D3 feels like she's going to
be at least one full Tempo behind in
some Mainline variations Rook C1 Knight
A5 okay uh opening up the bishop
prepping Knight to C4 looks okay to my
eyes how do you assess it uh Jovi
yeah I kind of you gotta win with white
yeah you've got to throw some pieces off
the board I mean that's the only thing
white can do maybe play 95. Let's Go
other kind of moves that I've seen done
but I've never been that convinced by it
is actually to retreat the bishop to B2
B1 sorry and uh Queen D3 and there's
battery against the H7 form but I never
liked that one uh when actually I've
always enjoyed playing against it
because I only play this type of
position with black because I just go G6
and establish a wall right and to remind
everyone this is a must win game for
begging because she did in fact lose her
classical game against Arena yesterday
and uh only a win will take her to the
tie breaks so definitely do or die a
moment and whereas in the Alice Lee game
Nazi by kids so that was a draw so
and perhaps this is why Irina is playing
this move knightway five if you do go
Knight to E5 maybe I can come back with
the Knight of C6 and offer a draw yeah
what do you do now do you take on C6
exchange more pieces now your attack
against my Kings you suck is even less
successful
then we make a draw so what do you do
how do you suck the d-pawn but you can't
can you how do you say it's a question
sack
um well I can tell you by the way this
is how I I drew a game exactly like this
against Michael tal with the black
pieces we had this kind of dance with
the knights and I went to E5 my night
went to C6 and we went back and forth
because the best move
is probably Knight F3 go back to F3
exactly yeah yeah yeah I think this is
what Irina is probably planning to play
on after Knight to E5 you don't want to
go Knight to C4 and change the pawn
structure give white something to play
against and imbalance the position even
more no you don't want to do that you
want to play Knight C6 keep the position
the position as stable as it already is
defend your king your king side as black
and you'll be fine
nice yeah nice Point as we get uh ready
for our first break of the day we've got
to visit our friends at Q Boutique
what's uh what's the special oh there's
a great special offer because the Saints
Lewis chess club chess campus stands in
solidarity with the people of Ukraine to
show our support all proceeds of this
specially designed shirt are donated
directly to the relief of the Ukrainian
people
the shirt also features the Saint Louis
chess club and World Chess Hall of Fame
logos on the back and it's available now
exclusively at qbutikstl.com
looks like a lovely shirt indeed we'll
see on the other side of the commercial
break
[Music]
in 2019 the Missouri Bicentennial
commission along with Governor Mike
Parsons approved the building of a
life-size chessboard to celebrate the
200th anniversary of the state of
Missouri Dr Jeannie sinkfield a lifelong
patron of scouting in Great Rivers
Council board member proposed that the
project be built as an Eagle Scout
project Genie invited 16 year old Andrew
Dowden of troop 6 Jefferson City to take
on this incredibly important project
my name is Andrew Dowden and I belong to
troop 6 in Jefferson City Missouri so my
troop we were down camping down at the
sing fields and Jeannie came down and
asked you know is anyone close to
getting their eagle or needing a project
she had this idea of the Eagle Scout
project chessboard and she wanted
somebody to kind of work with her to see
what we could come up with at the time I
kind of had a project in line but when
she brought up this idea obviously I
wanted to choose it because it was a lot
better idea than what I had started
prior to this project I did not really
know anything about Chess once I got
into this project I downloaded an app on
my phone started playing chess and I
took the chest merit badge down at Scout
camp this was a bicentennial chessboard
for the Historical Society of Missouri
there were a lot of people that helped
me with this project because whenever I
I got the pictures from the Historical
Society to engrave onto the granite I
wasn't very familiar with the technology
needed to engrave on there so I needed
some assistance with that and learning
how to do it and after all that I'm
pretty sure I know how to do it now so
to engrave those Edge pieces I went down
to the Lake of the Ozarks Scout
Reservation and we use the epilogue
laser me and Thomas Yang did I wasn't
really expecting it to end out this big
but as we me and Jeannie were working
um it just got kind of got bigger and
bigger and bigger which I didn't have a
problem with I thought you know I can
take on a little bit more and a little
bit more and
it ended out to be a really really cool
project so we had a ribbon cutting of
the chess board and there were a whole
bunch of people there including the
governor the St Louis chess club the
World Chess Hall of Fame the State
Historical Society which all helped out
during this entire project
Jeannie was there I had to give a little
speech that I didn't really know I had
to do but that kind of of has taught me
a little bit about speaking too so I
think that has helped me too this
project it's made me real proud that
everyone is enjoying it like every time
I go down there somebody's playing
and then they're taking care of it which
really makes me proud because
me sinking all that time and everyone
else that's helped me sinking in all
that time I like to see people use it
but I also like to see people appreciate
it
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
s have certainly come to today's game in
a combative mood but first of all let's
check out the standings and in the
Champions bracket the scores are tied
the very little tells part each player
we have Nakamura Dominguez they are all
after yesterday's draw both in a must
not lose situation as as Wesley so and
Fabiano Carolina
must not lose because if they do lose
then of course they will play down to
the elimination bracket The Elimination
Brackets are on rest today no games
going on in this and how about in the
ladies section right about that bracket
the ladies section we see Arena Crush
she leads one nil over Big Bergen a tug
in Genova and talking to Nova is in a
must win situation playing with the
white pieces nothing else matters she
has to do or die and for Naji pakiza and
Alice Lee after yesterday's very tense
straw both players again in that dreaded
all that playable must not lose
situation because if they lose you're
gonna go down to the elimination bracket
you still remain in the tournament
though but there is also another
exciting event that is happening on
Sunday March the 26th there is a huge
Blitz nine Blitz rounds no draw offers
okay and uh time control is three
minutes plus two seconds it's fast it's
Furious it's fun and get this includes
players from local universities and
eliminated American Cup participants now
that sounds like it's
this sounds like it's just like some
local you know amateur players no these
are the strongest Grand Masters in the
world exactly and that's uh
no I'm not suiting up uh but I
understand it's like a 40 40 player
Swiss and it's gonna be really really
strong a lot of eliminated players yes
we've done it last year as well it was a
lot of fun yeah I I just want to jump
right in on the uh because I'm missing
something and I'm absolutely anxious for
you guys to tell me what I'm missing I'm
referring to the game of Wesley so
Fabiano they've been playing what we
understand to be a very standard moves
we've just seen the position after
Bishop takes F6 and I'm thinking if you
recapture with the queen what I want to
do obviously is I'm I want to take a
pawn obviously that's that's my dream
come true but I don't want to lose my
queen so I need to get my queen out of
the way to the roof so I want to play E5
is there some tactics in order to play
Queen to E4 what what was the tactic
that you had in mind I was thinking
after
okay it does not work but it doesn't
work for a very concrete reason so after
Pawn takes porn you know of course the
queen drops off I'm aware I saw it of
course of course
B7 yes yes and it looks like that pawn
well the pawn will definitely promote so
there's no way to stop Pawn takes work
there is
yes and uh you're welcome to Feast on my
Rook but yeah that's that's a shame by
the way I think I've seen these types of
tactics
and in some of my own practice but okay
so but I did want to play E5
uh by the way nice tactic to point out
there that B7 looked good but if it is
my turn I'm you know I'm assuming the
queen has to drop back I I go Queen E4
and aha now I have dodged Rook take C2
and I do want to take this Rook on A8
um what am I missing Christian nothing
you're not missing anything oh this is
in fact better for white okay this was a
misstep by Fabiano caruana he was
supposed to take on H6 on C5 first and
then follow that up with the move H6 H6
does indeed allow this bishop takes F6
which was played by Wesley saw and the
natural follow-up is not B4 to defend
upon on C5 that's going to allow me to
take it back in one shape or another
after take take a knight to D7 but it's
exactly what we're seeing right now on
the board E5 is on the board Queen to E7
most likely that's going to be followed
up with Queen to E4 and once again the
owner is right now is on black to prove
the compensation and I don't
particularly see it no look I understand
I'm still a few moves behind I need to
go G3 King to G2 and finally I will be
able to enjoy my extra Pawn but how are
you going to Target The Pawn on B2 which
I would assume that's what you're going
to get to
Knight to C6
yeah exactly so if you take on B6
there's absolutely no compensation right
so what you have to do is start with
Rook to B8
after taking on B6
ah yes take on B6 and now Rook a to ba
just a second I just want to pause here
for a moment because suddenly I was
attracted to the move Rook D6 as well
okay okay yeah yeah but but it's strange
because you know on the one hand these
guys are remarkable Fabiano really one
of the world the great world-class
opening experts and what I think you're
telling me is he made a finger failure
in this case yes yes big mistake big
mistake wow I was I'm not surprised
right like exactly because this is one
of the main lines of this particular
position uh this with E4 as you were
mentioning and we knew that after Queen
to E7 if you try to play the move that
you played Queen to D2 you get yourself
in trouble as white right the main line
is by far the move E4 and has been
played at the elite level quite a few
times I see mommy diaro versus kramnik
uh in this position Bishop takes F1 King
takes F1 we've seen this before and H6
was only played once
what surprises me is that after E4
Fabiano started thinking so he was
definitely surprised by this main line
of this particular variation I mean you
chose to play this bishop A6 C5 uh this
intriguing idea with Rook to see it and
keeping the pawn on C5 I'm pre but after
E4 you're supposed to know the main line
if you don't then you get yourself in
trouble if you do then you most likely
equalize Rook takes C5 Queen to E2 H6
and it does seem like black equalizes
without that much effort in the position
but if you don't and you end up in this
position now the engine is saying why
did you just a pawn up slight
compensation for black but definitely
not enough and you were about to suggest
that after the move Knight C6 C takes B6
you have to play a move like Rook B8 yes
because everything else is just if you
don't if you take on B6 G3 and worse
where is the compensation
is it possible instead of current Knight
C6 you could just try to go Knight A6
absolutely yes and then do the same idea
I think there was a game no there was a
game with Knight C6 that is a recent
game in well thirdly recent 2018 between
contour two grand Masters as well and
Kozak uh Adam Kozak to Grandmasters from
uh Hungary Knight way6 is the computer's
main choice in the position and after
taking on B6 once again don't take on B6
allow yourself this idea of Rook to B8
and put pressure on the B file but start
off with Knight to C5 first
again there is some compensation but
it's not clear Fabiano will have to
prove it in this one to equalize and
it's not going to be straightforward
okay so a bit of an opportunity a slight
opportunity Wesley yes and let's turn
our attention to what we think is is
really shaping up as a fantastic
strategic battle between Lanier and
Hikaru and we left it we had left it
just around A4 uh and we have been
debating uh F7 F5 followed by Knight F6
or Knight F6 or Bishop H6 which uh was
hikara going to choose and if I've got
this straight uh Hikaru has been playing
really quickly I mean just he's been
flashing out his moves he knows what
he's doing he really knows what he's
doing and Knight D7 as he's essaying is
this beautiful C5 Square he's thinking
to himself Knight C5 B4 F5 and well if
black gets in all of those moves
Blacksburg choice you remember this idea
of Bishop to H6 promoted by the engine
yeah he played it yeah he played it fast
right now one hour and 20 is that 26
minutes for Hikaru now one hour and 20
minutes for a car and only 32 minutes
for linear
wow 50 minute differential I mean
without a second time control this is
not going to be pleasant for linear
because as you were mentioning guys F5
is coming my Avalanche of Pawns on the
Queens on the king side is coming
what is your counter chance well I mean
I have to say Jovi wanted to play B4
earlier yes to a way of getting some
aggression on the queen side I might be
playing B4 now as a kind of a defensive
reaction because I just don't want to
see the night land on this is C5
beautiful Outpost so I mean I may not be
proud of the move before but at least I
do have an idea of Rook A5 and I am
stopping Knight C5 for the moment and if
you guys remember the match in 2018 you
will never forget it the first game that
we as a Fabiano essay this Knight to D5
idea there was a B4 as yeah the big
novelty you know that's found that
Alejandro Lanier no Lanier found that I
was gonna say I thought it was Alejandro
oh I know that they had done the camps
together you know it was it was linear
who was working
from from home here in St Louis and when
we woke up in the morning he came up
with this idea of B4 has sent it to us
throughout the night we analyzed it he
played it and he actually got a good
position so he's definitely aware of
this type of ideas of playing B4 Bishop
to B2 or B4 just to cement that pawn on
B5 and later or later on Coral it and
attack it interesting situation right
now I'm worried about his time
management how does the computer assess
the position equals balanced yes really
really balanced yeah and what should
Lanier do if not B4 B4 is one of them oh
it is okay
I mean I I was also thinking Vindicated
okay can I ask a question you know once
you've played B4 is the is the follow-up
also going to be
I mean something like it seems to be
Rook to A5 again it's just to cement
upon on B5 defensive as well because
you're not allowing the Knight to come
to C5 it's going to be this
challenge between my attack on the queen
side on your structure and your attack
on the king side against my king so I
will go E4 or perhaps even F4 try to
destabilize the placement of your pieces
on the king side it's not easy I have to
say it's not easy for white it's not
easy for black either but with so much
time on his clock Hikaru and with so
much probably prior knowledge because
most likely he's analyzed this position
at home
I think he's the favorite in this one
and um look I'm gonna go ahead and make
a bold prediction I'm going to take
Hikaru in this one to take down Lanier
with the black pieces and move on to the
next one early yeah yeah it's early but
I still think this position is just wild
so I mean and talking about wild
positions I can see yes yeah I was
anxious again Atlas Lee versus Naji game
when we left it we had seen the move
Bishop H3 and we thought that that Alice
had a nice move Knight F3 deferring the
move E5 E4 for the moment we thought
Knight F3 was the way to go she went
with E4 and then after F4 uh easy to
miss this whole idea of F5 G4 Knight F6
takes Queen D7 is pointed out by the
engines I must say I mean I that I was
never looking to put the queen on B7 in
any of these lines Lanes but that was
the way for Alice to have an advantage
in fact she went with something I find
very natural myself Queen A5 but Rook H1
and now I started to realize whoa whoa
whoa whoa uh Naji does still retain
these ideas I think of Knight takes E4
she does have ideas of just corralling
this night as well I think we saw ideas
of Bishop takes F3 and queen D1 and this
is
this is really sharp I I think visually
without the computer's assistance how do
you assess it guys I I think it's
balanced but I kind of prefer white you
prefer white right yeah same for me if
I'm looking at the position without an
engine by my side right I would say
white is better right just because I
have more space your Pawn doesn't really
matter that much and I feel like I can
play Bishop G4 and take whenever I want
yeah because the engine is saying the
engine is saying black is better jeez
yeah the engine is saying B6 or perhaps
even Rook to d8 get off this pin on the
night on D7 and just get ready to uh
blast the position open on the queen
side and Alice is perhaps for the first
time in this tournament she's down on
clock
mm-hmm 40 minutes against one hour and
six minutes and we've seen this from
Naji we've seen it in uh her match
against Anna zatoski she managed to put
a lot of pressure on her opponent's
clock definitely playing very
confidently right now like a two-time
U.S Champion yeah she is yeah I
definitely agree no I have to say
after Christians put that move on in my
mind after B6 suddenly I can see
why why its position is unpleasant
because yes there is Bishop takes Knight
but you know and yes the black king is
in the middle of the board but it is
defendable yeah well I mean it's
protected by a a
swarm of pieces I would like to say and
now having said that B7 B6 can we see
something very concrete imagine I play
Bishop to G4 okay and
[Music]
now you can put the knight in the way so
you've got to put the bishop in the way
right yeah but there is um book takes
Bishop I was I was kind of hoping for
Knight takes E4 once again
um thinks Bishop is very strong Rook
takes Bishop is very strong oh yeah okay
sorry taking two pieces for uh for
foreign
it's a good good opportunity
okay that gives quite the advantage so
you see how easy it is for this position
to slip right so B6 Bishop G4
now presumably you don't take but you
play F5 do you play yeah F5 let's go
let's go high five okay I was solidify
the position I don't know how else it is
you don't get meat right right and so
we're somewhere here and one but I'm not
enthusiastic I'm not enthusiastic about
White's position at all because you know
unless you've got some G4 business okay
okay thank you for the inspiration I'll
go with the flow okay G4 uh there was a
there was purpose to my Rook h8 I just
failed to uh understand what it was but
in G4 okay okay I'm feeling like I'm on
a roll now I know what I'm doing I'm
hacking away on F5 and G6
okay I mean uh uh all to play for and
again we mentioned it many times begin
having to win against Arena Crush excuse
me I did that wrong oops
here we go and she didn't play Knight to
C6 so after the move Knight A5 95 Knight
C4
Bishop B1 Jovi you're gonna love this
move you mentioned it yes the wall
you're saying it's in force yeah
whenever excuse me that that that Arrow
did not go uh you're biting on granite
yeah you know I always thought that
whenever you had provoked G6 it was
always incumbent upon white to Maneuvers
Bishop to A2 because that diagonal got
shut down now having said that I can't
B2 is is hanging so
um take over for your star pupil here uh
Christian
um tell us why why begum's position is
really good it's not
I wish I could tell you that you cannot
lose uh Faith you got to keep the Fate
this is not a very good position it next
was a key move for Black's defense very
very important you don't play G6 then I
have a lot of ideas you cannot of course
instead of G6 you cannot touch the pawn
on B2 and this is probably the key idea
behind backgames whole setup with Bishop
to B1 because of Queen to C2 now you
move the Knight somewhere I take on F6
and you're getting checkmated on H7 so
let's say you go Knight to A4 take
advantage of the pin everything is
looking good not so fast you're not in
time right now you take back Checkmate
on the board so
G6 was wisely played by Irina crush and
once again she's showing how experienced
she is in this tournament she
understands when to pull the brakes when
to defend when to attack when to create
imbalances in the position this is the
difference right now between Irena and
all the other competitors in this
competition so G6
Knight takes E4 probably a good idea in
the position perhaps even Bishop to A2
that's one of the things that you do in
this type of situations with the
isolated Queen spawn whenever one
diagonal closes up you try to switch the
action to the other diagonal with this
bishop on the light squares so
opportunities on this side have closed
up change it up to Bishop to A2 she
played Bishop to H6 let's take a look if
this one is a good idea ah the the
spidey sense is alert by the way would
you take this yeah take it right I would
love to take that pawn and sacrifice an
exchange yeah you're right because my
king is so safe that's right yeah you're
definitely right about it Knight to C4
Bishop to f8 this is the right idea King
takes f8 and it doesn't seem like this
is a good position for white you're most
likely going to get another Pawn for uh
The Exchange you have a perfectly
secured position for the king due to the
fact that there's an absence of the Dark
Sword Bishop for white and you have the
nice beautiful Bishop potentially going
to G7 fiancetto in there it's not
looking good for white this one from a
strategical point of view from an
objective point of view but you still
have to make that decision as black as
Irina Crush you have to take on B2 she's
certainly looking at it because rookie 8
is the easy move to make sure you just
play it yeah and then you think later
but there's a funny topic and she's
thinking about it the funny part is I
was going to sacrifice The Exchange but
not at all in the manner that you would
prescribe which was kind of funny yes of
course I wanted to take the plan on B2
of course after Queen E2 I wanted to
take the pawn on A3 as well and of
course after you took the Rook I wanted
to put my queen a little bit closer to
the F7 Square so that the move Knight
takes F7 was kind of uh
presented yes and in the meanwhile I
thought you would play Bishop A2 and
then I was going to play Knight C4 with
the discovered attack against Great rook
and I was going to say hey two Pawns
beautiful beautiful I I was going to
take it this way so Arena uh and like
you said
let's say she she plays ball and plays
the move rookie eight I still think that
black is doing fine even after this move
I just see Knight B2 is maybe a better
opportunity yes it should be it does
even off The Rook 38 she's doing
perfectly fine yeah but I was going to
say rookie eight does have the pitfall
of uh this bishop
A2 move that you've been referring to
because often Knight takes porn I mean
maybe you could yeah yeah yeah you know
Knight takes
in the building yeah came into the came
through the front door you've been
practicing your uh puzzle Rush no I I
took I took them boys for advice from
one of our grand Masters and he said uh
you know you've got to do puzzles in the
morning as soon as you wake up
but not puzzle Rush yeah actually
specifically said just tactics and so
I've been uh trying to get my rating to
3200 I might not be I might be down to
23 40 or whatever in real life but in
the puzzles 3 200. I don't know I think
that's quite low actually yeah the big
guys are over four thousand remind me
not to challenge you to a battle uh of
these uh tactics
yeah and uh just to remind you as again
that began
in a must-win situation she cannot
cannot take a draw otherwise she will
get knocked down to the elimination
bracket and in the match-up between Naji
Pakistan Alice Lee they tied the game
after they tied the they drew is what I
want to say right we got the tide we've
got dry Jazz yeah Yes we made a draw a
draw yeah
Classics She's Not Afraid of EX change
giving up material in order to get a
good solid position I've seen it many
times I was really impressed in the
elimination game yesterday between a
match between Levon and Sam Savion uh
how often Lavon was very pleased to
sacrifice in exchange I mean we all know
the great tigrant Petrosian was a love
sacrificing exchanges but
we're seeing a couple of exchange
sacrifices and in this particular case
by the way I must say it's not even a
sacrifice we're actually getting plenty
of material compensation to pawns but
even better than that we're getting rid
of this darts word Bishop this dark
squared Bishop with a Pawn on G6
um that's the one Bishop that's the one
piece that could really hurt Black's
position uh the Knight on C3 is
non-threatening the bishop of B1 is
non-threatening but that Bishop on H6
and that was when why I was so happy to
bring my queen that a little bit closer
to the king side as well Queen takes
stopping these ideas of you know Knight
F7 and Bishop A2 especially because I'm
just going to play Knight C4 maybe even
yeah I think in this type of situation
though I mean you can't be playing
slowly as as white you know you have to
mobilize the Rooks that's your only
chance and I would be there just putting
my nut on e4
as white as whites yeah put my knight on
e4 and then just kind of
okay okay I understand you know the
long-term prospects are with you but for
the time being let's go let's go on the
sea lion and see what happens okay so
all right I'll just I'll just play along
for the moment takes
Bishop takes and this was like I I'm
really been counting upon this move I
want to say as my way of not only
staying in the game but actually gaining
an advantage because this is such an
annoying gosh darn
strike against The Rook right I mean you
just you hate playing the move Rook C2
but what what are you going to do you do
you're an exchange up you want to
maintain that as your material and
balance okay we'll keep an eye on this
um Christian uh what is uh caught your
eye in the linear game well a couple of
uh things have happened and I was
looking at both of the games in the
Champions bracket of the open section
and check this out Queen to E4 this is
where we left it a few minutes ago
Knight to C6 not Knight to A6 was
Fabiano's approach and they're still
following this game that I was
mentioning between contour and Kozak
take on a B6 and now instead of Rook to
B8
they're still following that game this
is the position we currently have the
clear follow-up in the position would be
to go G3 King G2 right right and this is
the question are you in time
to destroy the pawn structure and create
a weakness that you can actually get to
as black on the queen side so you can
start with the move B5 right Rook to A4
ah Queen two E3 or E2 and B4 right
something along these lines you're going
to try to Target my pawns but
what happens after D6 I'm stopping the
action of the queen against the pawn on
A3 so now the pawn on A3 is indirectly
defended how do you continue as black if
you try to put the queen on B7 and say
that there's some action on the long
diagonal I can match that with the move
Queen to E4 so it's not that easy to
create that final burst of energy to get
to my opponent B2 which I think is your
target that you're trying to get to so
very difficult position Wesley is trying
to figure out a way to stabilize the if
he manages to stabilize the position
then he's just a pawn up as we
understand he's going to be better and
he's going to be torturing Fabiano
caruana for a very long time but he
needs to find the right plan G3 King G2
and respond to all of those moves as I
was showing now let's see what linear
versus Hikaru this one instead of B4 he
played the move Bishop to D2 which makes
a lot of sense right Bishop to D2 you
probably want to go Bishop to A5 put
some pressure on that Queen on d8 he
played the move Knight to C5 and this is
the position we currently have on the
board but good news for Lanier finally
Hikaru is thinking after Bishop to D2 he
taught for uh more than 10 minutes and
he played this move Knight to C5 Queen
to E2 seems like the main line in the
position and now the question is what
happens after the move F5
crazy position guys B4 where do you go
A4 or D7
probably D7 D7 right yeah
and I would assume this is partially why
the bishop D2 is also having a very nice
Square because after Knight to E4
there's no more Knight to C3 ideas to
get to E4 back into the game so
knightway for C4 perhaps for white F4 is
that a move as well
look black Black's plan is pretty clear
I want to play the move F4 or E4 how do
you stop me from creating this expansion
on the king side as white what is your
counter chances lie
yes it kind of
yeah I'm perplexed that that their games
are difficult I thought he was going to
go Queen A3 when I saw the move Bishop
D2 uh we do have an updated graphic on
how uh the results of the tournament
this far have impacted the players
rating yeah cool graphic very cool and
it's just in the open section
Rusty Hikaru Nakamura but you know the
funny thing was they started off in the
uh fideo world rankings as being
Nakamura six and then um Carolina seven
and then Wesley eight six seven eight
and now Hikaru by gaining those 2.5
points has jumped up to number fifth in
the world I see and uh of course
Fabi and Wesley remain the same and wow
Sam gaining 1.4 points and someone who's
losing three points is a Samsung
and that's because he lost one game in
the classical yeah he lost one game yeah
yikes okay uh uh it was funny though
also what you were saying good news for
Lanier's fans is that Hikaru stopped and
think well I was thinking about that for
a second so imagine Jovi you're playing
some young punk you know it was really
booked up she it goes bang bang bang
bang bang bang and you're like suffering
and you're like oh gosh you're rolling
with the punches and you're trying to
remember your prep and then you make a
move and then she stops for 15 minutes
then you go did I just blunder
I got it I'm not in the computer prep
right anymore you know like so it was a
good news that uh that that Hikaru
stopped or was it bad news I think it's
good news overall yeah Hikaru has
stopped because I do remember playing
one of these young talents and how siren
when he was like 12 years old and I kid
you not like every move into our Tempo
my position got worse and worse and I
was suffering and bang you can make a
move and then he'd go and then at some
point he couldn't contain his um energy
levels right and he had to do what all
young kids do like just run
[Laughter]
my position was gruesome and I saw this
jumper this red jumper
and I thought crumbs crumbs my word is
exactly crumbs uh 95 and uh we're
waiting for Lanier and again I thought
that the idea behind the move Bishop to
D2 could have been to make some sort of
a battery based on Queen A3 and Bishop
B4 and as soon as I said that we just
did see the move bit Queen E2 keeping
the queen centralized at least for the
time being and your take would you like
white or do you I like black I don't
know why uh I just feel this bishop on
G2 is just too passive for my taste
what's your thought I
I I don't know I mean it is it feels yes
I can see that black has a very
comfortable position but you know of
course in the long term and I white will
be eyeballing that pawn on B5 does have
control of the airline it just has to
hold off this F5 Pawn Avalanche that is
coming the way but uh if you can do that
I think white has great prospects but
okay yeah this is the big issue though I
mean I I did like your suggestion of
going B4
because
first of all one thing oh no no no no no
it's it's black move as well but that's
that's the question
you just went Queenie too what if I stop
you from yes exactly and then focus on
F5 I have time but then you give away
the C4 square and that's always
something that when I'm playing this
particular Pawn structure with white you
know I jump for joy because you've given
me something that I can to play for yes
exactly
where do I go back
I I trade the Bishops and you want to
trade the Bishops I think so I and well
let's I know it says we're K7 quite
comfy okay okay keep going yeah yeah and
uh
we just
now um yes yes yes you're not going to
check make me on the light squares and I
have the H3 Square do we have yeah no
well what I can do
aggressive thesis some tactics maybe
tactics yeah C5 and D6
right
that's right
um
I'll take only five as well yeah take
only five
now you go Queen F6 wow
uh this is not what I signed up for when
I was playing F5 because I I really
thought I was the one getting a king
side attack not that I was having to
defend but perhaps it works for you just
barely just with that uh attack on The
Rook on A7 yeah yeah you have Knight C8
I think yeah beginner's luck there on
that one lucky me uh but no I I that was
not my attention to allow this kind of
uh and maybe I I should in fact you know
just chase that uh Critter
I mean that guy's a little bit scary but
now do I have where do I put the Rook
if I go to A5 then I cannot move my
knight which is a bit unpleasant I can
however have ideas if we'll take C5
let's go to A5 let's stay yeah
the one good the one piece I'm actually
afraid of is your night on C4 and how is
this position after Rook take C5 wait
wait wait sorry but Knight to B6 is no
longer attack my 1965 exactly yeah
Knight takes C5
yeah I was gosh darn it I would I really
needed that move E5 E4 to shut down the
uh Bishop on G2 and uh I I did it in the
wrong move order apologize for that F3
chip away or maybe F3 yeah F3 is is yeah
um always an interesting movie I mean uh
earlier we had a tweet asking me about
David bronstein and David bronstein was
one of these players who really blazed
uh pioneering trails in the king's
Indian and one of the things he loved to
do is when he was black in such
situations after a move like F3 is to
play the move F4 yeah and the idea is he
would sacrifice a pawn but somehow he
had transformed
the
ugly White ponds that would get
blockaded so he was really uh uh
remarkable in that but F3 I would
probably just trade uh I'm not as bold
as David bronstein clearly and uh Knight
to B6 and by the way a lot of people
don't know this but in that movie From
Russia with Love It was the borispasky
versus David bronstein game that was uh
portrayed in the movie by ER by Irving
Fleming
um I don't know it's a it's a very
intriguing line I I think this is the
game of the round at the moment uh
between uh Lanier and Hikaru just so
many cool ideas
shall we take a look at the ladies
definitely because uh we are hearing
that Alice
the kid two International Master Norms
to her name she's also defeated many
Grand Masters online in the project to
say many uh to come as well
heralded by Fabiano as a great talent so
I'm in here Rook C7 intriguing because
we were looking at B6 and Rook B8 ideas
but Rook C7 yeah
oh a G4 looks slow I really thought that
Naji was going to be playing moves like
Bishop to G4 so that she could
yeah introduced yeah with the Rook she
played G4
I find that move slow B6 and now Alice
well Alice is the one with the
initiative we can see very very clearly
that Knight C4
and Rook B7 and
white is going to be on the back foot
and then well she is maybe she needs to
stop pedaling as well you know put the
bishop back to F1 I know it looks it
doesn't look great but whatever I think
that's necessary yeah the C5 is coming
C5 I think that's uh you have Bishop B5
so very good
I need some play but at least wait a
little bit but you can increase the
pressure via Bishop B4 right and then go
C5 and finally you give yourself the E7
Square for the king
um I don't see any reasons I think I
should take the move Rook h8 check
seriously so I don't think there's any
reason why I shouldn't just give my king
an extra the luxury of the square do I
have ideas of Knight B5 now but 95 you
just go look C8
but maybe maybe white shouldn't be so
maybe I I like the idea of going ponte's
porn open up the G line sure and now
okay
Bishop on F2
truly that Knight on F3 I mean yeah I
mean you understand it's a bad night but
it actually controls some importance
first right like a g wand
D2 it's not such a bad night anymore
like all of the sacrifices that white
had moves like night and including
Knight B5 by the way is you have to
because this Knight is on this silly
Square you always have to realize that
you are inviting Queen
right yeah it's only one Queen D1 now
the queen comes back to and now it might
be two that night delivers the almost
outside night that was uh that we were
ridiculing is the hero I mean wow so
yeah I I do like Alice's position after
this Knight B6 Rook C7 it's a great
position very very imbalanced positions
in the ladies section and it does seem
like Irina is putting the finishing
touches in her match as well
in in her game she did play by the way
Knight takes B2 we did not see the move
Queen E2 by begin
much like me she kind of saw her A3 Pawn
as being uh important she played Queen
B3 Knight to C4 Bishop takes Bishop
takes and we're up to date with the
players I I like the exchange sacrifice
oh it's a great exchange sacrifice yeah
yeah it really happens
a sacrifice does it it does not feel
like this actually no no no no and uh
just to remind ourselves that Arena can
move on with a draw and in the case of
Naji and Alice Lee They drew their first
game and whoever wins that this game
will qualify on to the next round in the
Champions bracket whoever loses gets a
second life but they fall down to the
elimination bracket alrighty and we'll
take a break
we'll see you all on the other side
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
[Music]
founded in 1839 the University of
Missouri is steeped in Tradition the
recently founded Mizzou chess program is
a partnership between the University of
Missouri and the St Louis chess club
Collegiate Jess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of Excellence
Mizzou has always strived for the best
Mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institutions
ethos of respect responsibility
Discovery and Excellence to the
chessboard
[Music]
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield
and Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess
club is a non-profit organization
committed to promoting the game of chess
locally and internationally we bring the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills the
St Louis chess club welcomed chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
cup 2023 and just to remind ourselves of
the standings in the Champions bracket
yesterday was a peaceful but very
tenseful day as everyone Drew in the
open section but everyone has come to
the board in a fighting mood today
everything to play for it looks like the
players do not want to take it the tire
breaks at all nope I ask that maybe they
won't be able to avoid it in the ladies
section what is the brackets the
Champions bracket going on there as the
elimination tournament has a free day
today yes and in the Women's Champions
bracket we see that Arena crash while
she has started the tournament with a
perfect score and she is leading in her
match against tohen Genova by at one
point and it means that a draw is
sufficient for her to progress to the
next stage and for Naji paikitsu and
honestly well it is a fight on right now
but in yesterday's game it was a draw
so everything to play for um I think we
are going to be treated to a lot of
decisive action well on the board well
the game that certainly has got uh our
attention in fact we've been riveted to
it for quite some time ever since Hikaru
has said an open Sicilian is black in
his game with Lanier Dominguez it's
captured our attention and we've just
seen these last two moves uh b2b4 we
back here we were we were actually
looking at the possibility of B4
ourselves for black and we wanted to
play Rook A7 so as a Prelude to B4 Queen
C7 defending the A7 Square was played by
Hikaru and well Lanier said B4 you don't
really want to play Knight A4 because
after C4
the night feels a little bit offsides
doesn't it I mean it is it's not that uh
attractive anymore on the A4 Square
which is why Hikaru dropped his Knight
back and now Rook a five asking
questions what are you going to do about
this Pawn on B5 okay from Black's point
of view uh they're the questions that I
would be asking myself is can I take a
pawn
my uh Bishop takes E3 Bishop takes E3
well I can't take the pawn on C2 anymore
but should I be playing Rook C8 and
making my own counter play against the
pawn on C2 uh these are the things that
I would be asking uh Christian Jump
Right In this is uh I mean in the next
few moves
is going to resolve who's got the
advantage that's right yeah no that's
that's uh and you were asking the right
questions can I take the pawn on C2 and
Bishop E3 has to be played right now
because if you start uh taking on
defensive tasks with like I don't know
Queen to B7 or things of that nature
you're just too slow I'm going to go
Rook to A1 Rook to A7 is a big problem
you're going to have to make defensive
moves for a very long time you don't
have Rook to C8 anymore because it broke
to A7 you don't want to see that on the
board you need to maintain the offensive
as black so you have to take on E3
question is what are you going to take
us why I suppose with the F Pawn or with
a bishop yeah I was gonna defend the
pawn yeah with yes but at least right
now Rook takes B5 doesn't win a pawn
anymore because your opponent C2 is also
hanging so I can start thinking of ideas
such as Knight 2 F5 perhaps okay
going after this
night and and if I take this one though
just to follow through with the whole
plant so take can I take
and you are right I cannot take yet on
C2 because the Knight on D7 is uh
unprotected
if I go Rook to B8 you want to go Queen
to seasick don't you don't exactly so
I'm going to take on E3 first and give
myself another Square for the queen on
A7
Rook B8 and that's yes maybe maybe Rook
to B8
but then Queen A7 you take on D6 I don't
know this is not that easy
the second D6 I take only three but they
hide the king and that Bishop is
defending the cat exactly it certainly
is that yeah it's not that easy
okay so Rook A5 and Hikaru just kind of
blitzed out I want to say maybe his
first
16 moves or so and he had more time than
it seemed when he started game is is if
things equalized I know Lanier is a
little linear loves burning his clock
what's the time situation when it comes
to the time situation between the two I
think Lanier was burning the time on the
clock you're completely right 19 minutes
how many moves how many moves how many
moves they've played 21 but there's no
second time yeah there's no second time
control that's it so that's it yeah
that's the rest of the game
that's it and uh for Hikaru he has just
under 50 minutes that's a lot of time
that is a lot of time but let's uh
remind ourselves at some point it was
almost an hour differential now it's
only 30 minutes so definitely linear has
understood uh his task he needs to speed
up because if he lets himself go into a
complicated battle with only a couple of
minutes on his clock yes 50 minutes for
the car that's not going to play out no
in his favor so I like what he's doing
look he sped up a little bit B4 Bishop
D2 Route 25 he was at like 25 minutes
now he's only at 20. so he he he's doing
well yeah and uh I kind of also wanted
to ask both of your opinion on the
Wesley sir against Fabiano Carolina game
because when we saw you know we saw that
uh he had won a pawn yes but there was
some perhaps nebulous compensation no
it's a good company
is really restraining now Fabi has
managed to actually get serious
compensation and has he weathered the
storm he has indeed yes yes he has
indeed weathered the storm now uh that
majority on the queen side is immobile
you cannot play before you cannot play
B3 that pawn on A4 is doing a tremendous
job of stopping that B Pawn from
becoming a passer in the position also
with the setup of The Rook on C1 and the
Queen on B5 you can never move the Rook
from V2 once you move the Rook from E2
Queen to F1 is coming on the board and
your king is starting to feel the danger
so
you're probably going to have to just
Shuffle the pieces right now Queen F3
Queen E3 just stay like this wait and
call it a day because you're probably
not I'm not going to take on P2 by the
way as black even if you go Queen to F3
I'm not going to go Rook to B1 Queen E4
take on B2 because that's going to allow
you to get a past pawn and that might
become dangerous for uh black what I am
going to do I'm just going to wait okay
so H5
can I ask the saline question therefore
what if I try to
mess you up you know what I'll buy the
bullet okay let's take on H5 wow why not
why okay
the thing is though yes you if you do
capture that pawn with a queen you know
black can always kind of give a check
let's go King G7 first yeah can you do
seven yeah and then if you take it and
then Queen D5 cannot block that check
with the queen because of route you want
no that would be that's how you get your
3200 uh
and allow me to go Queen to D1 because
check mating cool right exactly are you
getting getting me from behind I'll I'll
agree with that completely but okay you
took my Pawn okay
um
do I feel do I feel the spirit of Nigel
short
S
I get caught right away
okay look there was this was the Bold uh
option right I can also go G5 and just
stay like this well that was my question
I I I hadn't really anticipated you
going for the capture so much as this
and I wanted I was trying to hope that
maybe on a good day I could play King H2
and Rook G2 and I would say hey I'm the
one opening up the G5 I certainly can
but after F4 I think I'm going to pass
with the move uh G4 yeah pass by
I mean what about here though you can go
yeah now you have this F2 Square yeah
that's true king to H2 by the way was
played none of this will happen
um which sort of allows black to go H5 I
was afraid the moment you play H5 you
shut me down yes yes sorry but wait wait
could you've been you've inspired me
yesterday please let her know after King
H2 oh and if you do go age five yes you
want to go G4 now G4 really my goodness
well this is
I understand it's not your pieces yeah I
was afraid I was afraid of putting my
king on H4 because of Rooks exactly
but now that we put the yeah that is a
queen check that I still get away with
it but no the position is
not what we wanted when we were playing
G4 but I very dangerous I think that
that is King H2 is a kind of a draw
offer I'll just move my king back
which begs question uh after takes we
thought okay why it's a solid Pawn up
but uh he lost this uh important Tempo
he didn't play King G2 he played Knight
to D4 which allowed this Rook to A4 was
a very good move
let's not take anything away from
Fabiano's defensive capabilities in this
one Rook to A4 was a very very precise
move because after you take uh get this
exchange going on in the position the B2
Pawn is going to be a forever weakness
exactly right now
and uh I it sure it no longer feels like
it's upon up I mean yeah yeah and and
you managed to get this bind with the
queen on B5 and The Rook on C1 as well
so and the queen cannot really leave the
long diagonal the White Queen from E4
because then all sorts of checks and
we've seen how unpleasant those checks
can be in the position
um I think Fabiano has found the system
and the placement of the ideal placement
of the pieces to make a draw in this one
yeah the more I'm looking at this though
I really don't like Wesley's decision of
playing King H2 could we just look once
more I mean if you really want to uh I
do I want to kind of mess black up a
little bit here all right because show
me again what do you do after I take
yeah let me play F4 okay
and I'll tell you uh it's our pre-move
Rook F2 and F5 I shouldn't remove that
yeah well I mean just to let you know
now that you weakened your king ah Rook
to be going to be one okay so okay so
now I've I still got the queen A8 check
business don't I but now I go uh
yeah but yeah it's a perpetual and then
you can go queen of two right no no Rook
H1 Rook H1 check Rook H1 check now this
is for sure a Perpetual there's no way
that we can you're not going to be able
to do anything yeah I'm not running
anywhere you can take my Pawn but Queen
G4 Queen E2 and we've actually seen this
setup in uh the game between Sam
Shanklin and Ray Robson yesterday very
similar structure exactly okay fair
enough uh yeah I I'm warming up to G6
takes H5 as well I think Wesley just
understands he wants to make a draw and
go to the playoffs all right playoffs uh
we like playoffs we've been seeing some
very exciting games in the playoffs I
must say uh let's jump to uh as we've
been mentioning throughout Arena crash
has been absolutely absolutely fantastic
in the tournament thus far and all she
needs is a draw today to clinch
um the match and she would go on in the
Champions bracket her last move was Rook
on C4 to A4 a move that wins my heart I
must say immediately just eyeballing the
pawn on A3 and that is a very very good
one those are two connected past pawns
on the queen side that uh that Arena
will have and and it's one of those
situations where you actually don't have
any compensation or any active play left
in the position I mean I I I'm starting
to think uh I better just like find some
sacrifice and and blow things up because
if I wait for Bishop to D5 Rook takes A3
I'm going to be signing score sheets uh
this looks very very good for arena and
again because of the draw odds even
better than that what's going on in
Alice game when we left it we really
liked what he did she played Knight
takes B6 we saw these ideas for black
that were looking incredibly powerful so
powerful we even wanted to play Bishop
F1 and just stop Knight C4 now she
played Bishop G2 okay so Alice has
that's Alice have to pay attention I
think I no no against Bishop F1 I wanted
to play F5
against Bishop G2 I can't play F5
because the pawn would be hanging so
Knight C4
um check
shall we try yeah you have to try
something something okay and oh but if
you put it there yes
is there any
no there is nothing you wanted Knight
takes E4 it doesn't work because of this
queen coming into me too I mean it
worked before maybe it will work again
nope it didn't work it worked for black
yeah yeah it's it and it still does and
it's yeah okay bad for what all right
so uh I can switch the move order a
little bit to uh Jovi I can play Knight
takes E4 F takes Bishop takes
so the idea is if you take my Bishop
I'll take the Knight and you don't have
creepy too but you do have Queen takes
A2
Queen takes A2
and that's depressing
C4 Bishop takes E4 I was depressed by
this but oh yeah
I've got this bishop A3 nasty stuff yeah
five some crazies right oh Bishop F5
that that at least gets a draw and it
might even do an even more damage than a
draw so okay wonderful we found a trick
okay so the trick we found is that if
you play Knight C4 Rook check we do have
this and Bishop takes F3 but let's go
into that final position once again okay
so Queen takes A2 Queen takes A2
yeah can I start with Bishop A3
um
in these in these kinds of positions I I
believe in the rule get on your running
shoes and
start running oh you don't want to take
it I don't know I
wanna go ahead I want your your pieces
to be but what's that was there really
nothing
you I'm not checking it right now no I
was I was actually just bluffing uh at
least
if you take it at least I have a draw I
thought Queen A1 and queen C3 and then
you have to defend them I'm intimidated
by the engine
and this is this was uh at least a draw
yeah but you can still yeah
yeah
okay so well I I've if I'm white I I
would be thrilled to give it a Happy
Wheels yeah I'm a pawn down and it looks
to me coming into this exact position
that uh black is about ready to to
Really uh attack and I'm wondering you
know like how do I defend how are we
doing on time so okay by the way we do
have Knight C4 on the board yeah we do
uh Alice has just over
20 minutes meanwhile uh Naji has 30
four and a half minutes
but it's so many possibilities here I'm
glued to Knight takes E4 right I mean I
I did I don't think I have time for
anything like King B1 I'm just gonna get
killed Rook B8 I'm I'm afraid of even
you know Knight B2 actually I think C4
loses on the spot Knight takes E4 loses
on the spot why maybe in their Queen
takes the simple and efficient route to
B7 get lost
[Laughter]
the simple and efficient Rook to B1 why
is that simple and why is it efficient
can we ask if I take a night correct
text I take a night
I've got that's two nights wait what
and if you take my queen what's
happening what
I assumed it was computer generated
analysis and now he says what no no but
how okay I think you're a queen of
course you do and I took a rook so I got
two Miners and a rook for a queen you
must be getting checkmated I I don't
doubt it I just uh please uh do the
honor let's go Queen 283 Queen A3
I assume I have to go back
[Music]
do I have ideas of just the F5 now and
C3 F5 CC even though C3 Sims C3
you know the problem I love my minor
pieces the problem is the bishop on F2
is hardly contributing in any uh fashion
to the defense of my king or even to any
offensive action C3 F5 and I think I'm
just being done
yeah I agree that that is that's sad
that's sad so Knight takes E4 Rook B7 is
a showstopper
well what's my alternative to Knight
takes E4 right I do have um okay so
you've got Rook h8 okay King D7 that's
one Bishop takes Knight two
um
I got the drum roll but I'm ready
go F5 try to create something right yeah
but five don't we have that you run into
the same issues Rook goes to Beast well
we do have picks I take and queen F5 and
Bishop G3 and I don't know I'm praying
at this point
that's good
yeah F5 okay it feels like at least you
are uh generating some good counter play
I like that
um
Bishop A3 probably not good huh
it's like one of those western movies
who's going to yeah first yeah yeah you
shoot out I do like that quote I think
it's from a western movie because there
are two types of people in the world
yeah and then those who bring loaded
guns and those who do the digging
which westerns I don't know one with
Clint Eastwood oh excellent excellent
uh John Wayne and Clint Eastwood
the true Cowboys of
Cinema Knight C4 okay uh I really Knight
takes E4 rookies I mean that is such an
easy you know you you you get yourself
wound up you know you see all of these
sacrifices and you see this bishop F3
and rook h8 and you get yourself to the
point that yeah 94 94 and then Rook B7
oh no what did I do
that's terrible so where we were going
instead was check bishop f8 or it was
King D7 I apologize Okay Jade I actually
played Bishop takes F3
e takes F3 and F6 with the idea of
captures and queen F5 Brooke is on the
board indeed it is
the seven we expect to come quite
quickly and we have been playing King D7
rather quickly but there is an
alternative right
oh she did already I was about to say
there was Bishop f8 but King D7 and now
no choice right Bishop takes Knight
an F5
um maybe okay you you always do you do
you find yourself at the board sometimes
flipping a mentally a coin should you
play Bishop F3 first followed by F5 or
should you keep the bishop no because
you don't get to my king and now I have
Rook B7 right yep
you take on F3 I don't even take back
that's exactly the point
so there is no there's no mental
flipping here at all we have to start
with Bishop F3 which almost begs the
question can you play rules
yes you can
and then what do I do
you're asking too many questions
not a Prime member
now you actually run for the end game
with Queen A4 which is a pretty
depressing thing to do that you have to
do in this position not to get
checkmated and we entered this end game
which
the engine is saying that black is
enjoying a significant Advantage you
don't have time to go Rook to H3 because
of Knight takes B2 Knight B2 and then
Bishop to A3 and this is wow the pitch
Pawn F2 is just such a bad piece right
exactly the difference in the position
is that my pieces are so active while
your pieces have a very defensive stance
you take on F3 I take on B2 you have to
run away with the King it's not looking
good this is the dream position for uh
Naji pakiza right sorry for early sleep
so perhaps this is what she's
calculating after Bishop takes F3 Rook
to B7 as you guys were mentioning is
very precise it takes F3 still seems to
be doing quite well after Queen to B4 or
G5 but it gets dicey and definitely it
looks at least visually very very
dangerous by the way none of this will
happen because you play the root 2 B8
makes sense
to B7 that looks like a very decent
movement how is this position guys
how do you guys assess it I know how I
assess it with the engine right
[Music]
yeah no I mean if I if I've seen Rook B8
I I I'm drawn to it I like black uh I
like the extra Pawn but uh
I mean again I feel like I'm a moveable
knight takes E4 and you know uh turning
the tables if you will so yeah Rook B8 I
I couldn't understand why I'm not
because I'm attracted to this move
actually I think it's very very good
move actually on a practical level truly
because you know you have Bishop takes
Knight in the uh F5 is not possible
right and you're keeping this Knight
takes E4 kind of tactics in reserve yeah
and the only
I mean obviously this is a Cutthroat
position so yeah it has to do something
so exactly it moves are kind of jump out
at me I just maybe move the bishop out
to be
four
I I find myself maybe that move as well
it may be that I'll put that one back
and then have a look for the
Alternatives what else is there well
it's almost like you would love to kind
of play Knight to D to to stop all of
these ideas of f4f5 and Bishop takes F3
but I do well that's the problem this
bishop on F2 which has been bothering
nobody the whole game suddenly has a
role that it could play in this case it
can play Bishop to E1 so maybe we we
need to find a better uh yeah the final
breakthroughs like see
five very caution to the wind but of
course you let go of D5 so let me also
rewind that move yes
so what if I try to play this
strategically change it from my kill on
the B file mindset to just let's
exchange pieces and try to apply this
for a long long time Rook CA
why do I have to trade pieces
well if you don't then maybe I can run
away with the King and that Rook on B7
doesn't have that many squares left
right uh 28 or King to d8 let's take
into d8 King d8 yeah just because it
feels a bit more safe
uh well you mentioned this ending with
Queen A4
do I have to go
I mean I
I feel like I'm a one-trick pony the
only I've got Knight takes E4 on my mind
and it's kind of been but it doesn't
work right I take only four you take an
E4 I take on F3 Knight D6
Knight D6
oh dear okay that kind of hits a lot of
bits and pieces doesn't it I guess it
would take only seven and take on e4 but
I don't think it's enough it's not the
joyful exchange sacrifice that arena is
enjoying yeah no no no no no no
okay uh it still goes to show that Alice
is the one who is pushing the action
here and you wanted to say that if I was
forced to trade how did you you were
about to tell me about your great
strategic skills well I'm I'm upon up
that's that's my uh strategy
the training you see yeah you see how it
works you know but it's a good thing
right I mean it seeps in it's like it's
just slowly slowly it's almost
everything calm down for that philosophy
okay Knight takes E4 it can continue to
be a one-trick pony right
but do I have Knight E1 now wow
that is a nasty uh trick isn't it Knight
E1 forking the bishop on G2 the queen on
C2
and yeah that's that's just that's
outrageous but it's a really good move
Rook C8 played ah the Alice the talent I
just love the way how she can just
switch between attacking like a mad
woman and then suddenly nope let's just
switch you see that's just unfair you
know when you're 13 years old and you
come at me with all great guns blazing
and tactics I feel good I'm I'm proud of
you that you're a tactician and that's
what young kids should be Tactical
you can't be both strategical attack
that's just not that's not fair that's
just that's cruel talent and it is
that's an amazing move for C8 wow Alice
uh Brave yeah Bravo again we think that
arena is doing very very well uh she's
got she's sacrificed in exchange she's
got two pawns and all she needs is a
draw and she's doing she's thinking
about the draw right now yeah she's a
cruise control someone who perhaps isn't
also not thinking of a draw yeah or
maybe teaching on the edge of the draw
is the game between Wesley so and
Fabiana caruana okay because we saw
Wesley return his extra material but now
they're in this queen important ending
where that apron is going to be running
up the board sorry I uh Let me refresh
the board and update it whoa uh that's
one thing that I didn't want to see for
Fabi right right the queen and pun
ending right
uh we left it here after King H2 and
somehow we just thought well they will
get to a drawing position this is we
will whoa whoa whoa this is lost this
might be some very well calculated draw
right I've got the queen Behavior yes
but I will be able to use that on the
e-pawn and that's why he played E5 as a
decoy so I go E4 okay E4 B6
did the queen behind us
and that uh now I understand so my
King's perfectly safe and you're gonna
use the pawn yeah
of course okay and if you try to defend
it
a a Mind Freeze there pardon me if you
try to defend it with King G2 after yeah
Queen A2 King G2 ah I can still go E3
you can go King G1 right that's what I
would do okay and after E3 phone text
but where's your king going
to Infinity
spoken like somebody you read
Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy
Infinity and Beyond you know uh
uh yeah I think there's not a lot of
infinity going on there we're going to
have to lasso you uh back into Earth's
orbit here
um yeah E4 the e-pawn is an important
decoy boy I tell you I just really had
this Mind Freeze like whoa White's King
perfectly skit say okay could you kind
of obviously you can't go running up the
board with the a pawn right but you can
consolidate like maybe improve the queen
and so for instance leave the pawn on A4
put the coin on E3 okay go
like your Magnus Carlson you know you
introduced your king into the into the
works and you know but okay so how are
you dealing with Queen A4 or A2 okay so
first of all move the king your Apostles
hanging
I know exactly well I mean it might just
be a very well calculated situation Oh
by by the way wait wait wait wait I
don't like this I take only four yes I
take enough to I go Queen G2
but then the queen gets Queen behind
somewhere now you've just got Queen A5
yeah yeah
not enough no no it's a bit too exposed
like somehow if it were not an apron or
maybe a B Pawn you know the king could
work closer and closer yeah but this I
don't think it's enough no
no I had the Jabberwocky would be a
winner yeah I'm not sure even in that
case uh how about Lanier and icaro
because that whoa whoa
whoaire was the one who had control of
the a file a moment ago what has
happened okay we left it and you said
that ikaru had to play the move Bishop
takes E3 and I have to tell you by the
way that that is a very very awkward
move for top Grand Masters to make
because you know we're taught you know
to treasure the two Bishops and not to
voluntarily go into these two nights
versus two Bishops and giving up the
dark red Bishop okay Bravo Hikaru Knight
F5 Rook A7
okay Lanier kept the two Bishops but at
the end of the day
active Rook active Knights how do you
recommend what's going on here
what's happening
um struggling I'm struggling here I
understand because I actually prefer
Black's position you do okay yeah
because it has there's a lot more
harmonious
and uh the bishop on G2 is really not a
great piece although it can drop down to
F1
the drop down to F1 gift meet upon
exactly but then you know the Knight
does have nice posts you know and I can
plonk itself on D4
quite messy
correct yeah I know this is uh
this is not one of those positions you
want to have with only five minutes on
the clock and Lanier only has five
minutes only five minutes wow so he's
going to be stuck glued to the board
absolutely until the end of the game no
bathroom breaks no nothing nothing like
that but uh
it's very complex because you know this
Knight on D7 isn't a great piece either
so maybe let's go Knight F6 right right
it can go to Knight F6 and then I jump
to G4 so if you control it okay so the
one thing I don't want to see is the
Knight dropping in on the D4 Square so
let me let me just chill for a moment
with the move C3 I'm I'm keeping reserve
the idea of Bishop F1 when I need it to
capture the pawn on B5
we hear crickets
everybody's out I know I mean but I was
also thinking
Queen B6 Justin okay
control the night circuits and then I'm
thinking that the bishop on DT can I go
E4 now yeah
so Bishop takes E4 is going
19.993 first or Knight G3 first
well okay I mean let's just see how good
or how bad is it I've got Bishop E3 yep
go for it ideas yeah do it now
I'm gonna go to you into making that
move
I need all the support I can I'm gonna
get
uh
yeah it's it it is
yeah it's double-edged stuff guys it
really is and uh with I'm with you 100
uh with five minutes on my clock
oh this is tough for Lanier and a
reminder of where you where we stand
yeah and it is a very tough situation as
you caught it because in the Champions
bracket yesterday so everybody draw
their game so it means everything to
play for in this game and if the match
is tied we are going to see playoffs
we're expecting that in the game the
match between Wesley so and Fabi it
looks like they're cruising their draw
so playoffs will be coming up
later today they believe it is that and
in the ladies and in the ladies
situation well arena is in a very
pleasant position having won yesterday's
game against begum she just needs to
draw and she will Coast through to the
next stage whereas in the match up
between najli paikitsa and Alice Lee
They drew yesterday so everything to
play for today and of course if we do
see any ties then we are going to see
these playoffs and it's going to go to a
two-game rapid right and if the match is
still tied then we're going to see The
Blitz
and if the match is still tied
the adrenal impact Armageddon I really
want to see an artist yeah me three I
mean I'm ready for it and I just wanted
to go to uh the game of Alice Lee we
think arena is really uh in a very very
comfortable Cruise uh position if you
will all she needs is a draw and frankly
I would be surprised if she's simply not
winning at this stage uh these two
Bishops are fabulous this uh two
connected past pawns the weakness here
the incredibly safe black king I mean I
actually live for these types of
positions as black she's looking great
but the big question is what's going on
with Alice oh they did trade on C8 and
take it away Christian is
is Alice she's a pawn up yeah she's
she's upon up uh her King right now
without the presence of the white Rook
on the eighth rank is feeling quite safe
quite safe no Knight takes E4 no one I
takes C4 right because I have this
Knight T1 91 is key in the position so
it's a remarkable move and hopefully
Nazi is not going to forget about that
because if you you can easily associate
and you have this idea of Knight takes
ec4 for a very long time in the position
and you're like okay what am I missing
yeah let's take on e4 and then boom
Knight to E1 drops to E1 and the game is
over so she has to be careful she's
dropping down to her last 20 minutes we
remember she was up on time quite a lot
I believe it was something along the
lines of plus 20 minutes right now
they're very close in their time
management so this one is going to go
down to the wire
but I'm really kind of struggling as
white I mean Nash issues here and I'm
sitting there saying to myself okay I
have to get rid of these Knight takes E4
Knight takes D5 types of ideas
but
what am I looking at how do you do it
yeah but what should I do instead I mean
um B3 you probably don't want to play
because of all the darks were weaknesses
right
that kind of like invites I don't know
but by the way A3 ideas exactly be in
the position right now we don't know for
sure right so I I mean I'm struggling
but there is no threat apart from Bishop
like what did the Romans do for us yeah
exactly exactly
still one of the great lines the life
Brian yeah uh no I'm struggling uh and I
well especially because I I I really do
look for active plans I try to find uh
that's a human nature yes and where's it
an act I I mean I'm finding myself drawn
to King B1 not exactly the most active
move I was also drawn to that just
because you've got to do something and
maybe your king is a little you you're
protecting A2 okay so let's go King B1
okay I've got a problem though 92 or
Bishop comes out oh I've got a problem
well you just can go you can go B3 no
because Knight D2 comes killer blow yeah
no no no oh that's no let me show the
audience what you might have missed
uh
by accident by accident
yes uh yeah
um so I'm having and Naji you can see
she's uncomfortable her body language
she's looking around like what am I
supposed to do I have an idea please A4
whoa whoa
84. okay well you know what can we do
yeah you gotta do something whoa yeah
and I'm just thinking B3 is the next
move
wow okay B3 is great you are really
Brave yes but yeah she's got to do
something okay we've got to do something
I mean the other alternative could be to
actually there's another alternative
that I did think rather than A4 is
actually just to go
the king's not safe on the queen side
move it to the center say it say it
put your King on E2 uh-huh
can I go Bishop to B4 now okay
that's right on F3
she she's had enough of this night
this the the this night was some kind of
like uh torture
uh but now
oh you got rid of the night but
if you don't get rid of this Pawn
that pawn is actually huge
just to give you a heads up please
linear is down to his last two minutes
oh let's go there because I think Alice
could decide the match in her favor
today uh in this game she certainly want
to say with a victory we're gonna jump
back to Lanier's position for just a
moment because what did you say how much
time two minutes two minutes two minutes
well now he's under two minutes yeah but
uh just to remind everyone of the time
control the players do get an extra 30
second increment per move but there is
no second time control
whoa Bishop H3 inviting Knight D4
strangely enough that was the one thing
I wanted to avoid is white which is why
I was playing C3 here's Lanier provoking
his opponent into playing uh 94. what's
his intention help me uh Jovi what do
you think Lanier intends after 93
well 92 check
and then I move my king somewhere and
then to F1
okay but then the queen can come
and
aha this bishop takes uh-huh night
there's night I'm just thinking of all
the forcing moves right you've got to
get that you've got to rescue that night
though so I was thinking Queen C
maybe Queen B maybe Queen B6 okay I like
it you're threatening uh ideas of Knight
take C3 with a nice discovery
Bishop D2 Bishop David too
just got caught
yeah wow so no 92 so after Knight D4 C3
no no trickies right
wow it just feels like this is a
position that should have a trick but uh
do you need to do you really need to
move that night for instance could you
and I was gonna suggest something
ridiculous Queen C8 Queen C8 wow
it's not so ridiculous because if you do
get Queen takes C2 then you're you
you're combining the forces one doesn't
work
takes F6 followed by G4
and then you cannot move the Knight
because of G5
yes that is a nice trick that is a
really that's a beauty
beautiful looking trick doesn't it yeah
we got tricked yeah
yeah it's a Christian uh but there are
some final one final kind of trick that
you can do as black what's that instead
of Queen C8 it's you can go H six
Bishop H3 in the current position
786. what's this bishop takes like King
takes and uh good General
he's from the front that's right
oh gosh don't try this at home kids
right this is only because we had the
liberty of being able to take back
and thank goodness I mean it's it's the
uh the the plus of being a commentator
right I was wrong
so no one ever I never said on the show
it's never been said
um what does the engine uh make of uh
this Inc this what we're struggling
let's uh he seems like Knight to D4 is
the best movie and after C3 yes Knight
two what what no what are you doing with
the night there nobody plays like nobody
plays like this of course so Knight to
E2 King to F1 still within the drawing
margins but only with one move Queen is
Queen 27.
yeah what if I just go Bishop to D2 try
to Target that Knight ah Knight takes C3
what and then Knight to E4 and then you
don't have a good way to defend what is
this okay this is
yeah forget about it nobody's going to
play like this
um
you cannot take because I just simply
take back only three and take on D2 and
then I'm going to have a winning
position wow very difficult ideas to
calculate and to understand H6 the move
that you were recommending Jovi is
probably the most human move in the
position just go H6
Force pretty much white take on F6 King
takes F6 and at least right now you have
more or less a quiet position you don't
have to worry about any sort of crazy
ideas for white
um I think this is what he's going to go
for but then after Queen F3 we still
have the Salient question what are we
doing about G4 and then we're just going
to play this position Queen takes F5 and
queen to C7 and I'm going to say that I
have enough compensation for for the
pawn
okay uh let's jump uh to Alice Lee uh
because uh it just uh varusian or
colleague in uh on the production staff
is saying there's an opportunity here
for uh Alice and I think it was
associated with Bishop to B4 oh she
played she played B4
you see she's trying to do something
active exactly that's that's psychology
right there that's chess psychology
well it's chess that's what she tried to
do we we
I I find like I just don't enjoy myself
when I'm sitting there struggling and
I'm defending and I'm like I'm not
having fun I mean like you Jovi I want
to push the palms and go for it but uh
right here right now is where VAR says
Bishop B4 and oh that's just a whole fun
game right so you take on D5 I take on
C3 you have to stop the queen
and then we exchange the Queens oh
that's on D5 and how do you ever
approach my Pawn on that we don't that
pawn on F3 is huge you have to lose so
many templates you have to go King D1
team you want G1 or Bishop G3 King F2
and finally you get to that pawn in the
meantime I'm going to run my king down
the a file right King B7 King A6 I'm
going to get to your a pawn and that
she played it
you know the the the the the strange
thing is if the black Pawn on F3 were to
change colors and become a white Pawn I
still might prefer black
the fact that it's a black one after
three just means this guy it's got to be
winning and Bishop B4 she's played uh
what we think is actually a killer move
starting to feel it guys yeah she is
starting to fit in this would be a club
exactly because it would mean that she
would just go through to the next stage
and Naji which will be demoted so to
speak
uh Groundhog Day of last year right
where uh yeah it was like the number
Alice and Arena were going to that clash
and Arena won the match and then again
yeah one uh the elimination uh match too
so uh Palace is ready to book her seat
into the next Champions bracket
very impressive play from the 13 year
old
before piling on the pressure wow and
what have we've noticed about her is
that she calculated
very quickly
yeah this looks beautiful terrible
terrible position for weight I'm not
even sure I mean the only thing I could
potentially suggest is Bishop E1 at this
moment because anything that allows
Bishop takes C3
uh is lights out
I mean this is actually the computer is
saying minus six minus six the game is
over okay according to the engine right
now this game unless some huge swing
happens this game is over so it's almost
as if uh we're not going to be seeing
any playoffs in the ladies because Arena
we think it's just doing fantastically
well we think that Alice is doing very
fantastically well we kind of lost track
a little bit of Wesley and Fabby it was
a queen ending it is a queen ending and
Airborne is still running up the board
White's King
it's just a question of can it escape
and unfortunately I don't think it will
ever
so find a safe haven Queen to eat too
now right yeah wait a minute why why
won't I find this
queen can come to F1 I don't know
anymore Queen G4
or queen yeah you keep contact with the
yeah anytime uh you go Queen G2 there's
a pawn up for grabs on Asics and that's
a good one yeah yep that's it that's
simple enough Fair
yeah yeah and it seems like Fabi is able
to calculate this quite precisely well
for somebody who probably made a finger
failure out of the opening and got
himself upon down good recovery
excellent recovery
I mean Wesley it didn't seem like Wesley
did anything wrong but then he didn't do
anything with his extra Pawn so do I
have
any opportunity if I manage to get the
queen to weigh one so Queen to C3
followed by Queen to A1 it's a in
afternoon yeah
but you have Queen F1 so how are you
gonna no he wanted to go Queen oh he
wanted to go to Queen C3 Check Yes
Quincy three check and queen yeah so say
king and now yeah but I still think you
have a Perpetual right right Chuck
that's pretty easy jack
yeah unless I want to give you
everything my pawns on
on the king side it doesn't look good no
I wouldn't advise and I don't think I
should probably do that
that might be a bit too many times I
wouldn't advise it no that that game
definitely looks like it's heading for a
draw and a playoff Queen D3 uh oh just
when I was about to move away from this
game
um Queen to D3 came on the board
version of the queen E2 idea because it
doesn't allow Queen C3 anymore exactly
so now you go A6 I go Queen F1 right
let's see if Wesley is going to try
um or if he's just going to play A6 and
make a draw
that might actually be the case
because Wesley is very objective he's a
very very attractive guy whenever he
sees that there's no more chances he
generally doesn't try for very long and
I I really like this queen D3 because
even ideas of trying to get the queen
behind with Queen C1 they're no longer
available because of Queen to F5
right so it kind of freezes you freezes
your options just takes away that
opportunity and after Queen to D3 it
just you've got F5 and you stop in Queen
C3 as well yeah I I agree Queen D3 is
excellent yeah yeah very precise very
very precise
and let's jump to Alice Lee because she
might be the first player to uh thanks I
think it's a race between her and Irina
Crush as did you will win their game
first
Arena has been a very impressed the form
but here
no answer from Naji no no she down to
her last eight minutes right now no
exactly
um for what I mean the computer does say
plus six so we know it's pretty pretty
bad wait a minute what is Arena thing
doing
she took on D4
allowing
Queen takes G4 no Queen takes G4 yes so
I'm guessing Bishop Bishop takes porn
you can just meet that with King takes
and then but then the queen queen B6
check right so King F1 and there goes
the queen Rook takes G4 Rook takes D6 no
no no King takes F2 no no King F1 King
F1 right now I apologize but you can go
and she's played King F1
you probably do have to go into this end
game so you take on G4 I take on D6 you
take only one I take on D1 back and you
have four Pawns
for the piece
but that's not well never mind I take on
A6 yeah that's not what we wanted what
what what what what what what what
so she took on G4 she has taken on G4
okay Rook takes D6 of course pretty much
forced so that's that was a strange
decision then why would you go into this
ending
that isn't
a super clean
as it was a moment ago but I think it is
relatively clean is it because she just
needs to draw okay
yes perhaps from that perspective yes
yeah she's not risking anything you know
you really aren't you know you just
wanted to play Bishop takes Jesus well I
was thinking that is a very good point
yes yes also you can go H H5 as well
it's black who's playing for a win
that's for sure that's for sure
you're not going to finish the game with
Checkmate but you don't need to no no
you don't uh a drawable dude a draw
we'll get you through the next round by
the way now she played the move Knight
to B1
Knight to deal night to be one night to
B1 let me jump to that game okay
it's not looking good for not a fun move
no not a fun move to make allowing Queen
takes a too
just doesn't seem um and but what after
we takes you to like what's your
follow-up
on
I take back and then
five yes Throw It Forward I don't care
how close you are yes you know I'm not
done with you yet
okay
we're quoting the uh the night right the
black the black knight from the Monty
Python's Holy Grail his legs have been
chopped off
yes
uh yeah Queen takes A2 that just uh
looks very very powerful
oh my goodness uh it look looks bad I'm
I'm more than intrigued by the game
between Lanier and Hikaru because how
much time
is oh he hasn't moved after yeah he's
not really trying to to calculate uh
more than one move ahead and make his
decisions right for more than one move
ahead so he can blast a sequence of
moves and potentially put more pressure
on his opponent exactly
that's what I like to do when I was
playing against Walter Brown a Time
trouble addict is I would get it in a
position where I I did my very very best
to calculate four five six moves
play them quickly and then think again
like okay like wasn't this recommended
by Simon Webb in his books chess for
tigers as well I didn't read it but if
he recommended that you know like Well
Done science there was some kind of like
waiting and then you do some bang bang
bang and uh yeah that's what the tiger
came in exactly okay so here strangely
enough well not what am I saying we're
not worth H6 was recommended you're
you're moved by the computer good
General leading to disarming and stuff
he didn't play H6 no I didn't think he
hasn't played this game he hasn't played
a single move though but just because
the the this is this is like alien chess
is getting ready to play a move though
how do you play night on F5 to C2 where
it's absolutely doing nothing but
because you recommended it Hikaru
he's such a great calculator
he's not gonna play this no no no no way
but but how would the sequence go
because this is such a confusing I I
would never uh head off in this
direction myself as black 94 C3 Knight I
I I'd get stuck with 92. yeah right and
Rook D2 Rook A1 and the computer finds
the equality rookie
Rook here here let's go for a Perpetual
no kidding wow okay that's just that's
not gonna happen that is alien chess yes
yeah no way
his his thinking he's thinking he's kind
of figuring things out and we're going
to see a sequence of moves coming from
from one of the things that you had
mentioned a couple of times in the show
uh Christian is I mean I know you're the
college coach for Missouri University
and you're always looking at the chess
engines and you know recommendation of
one engine versus another engines are
improving all the time but you uh from
Norway uh you have this Cc
or something yeah this is super super
computer that's dedicated to magnus's
games right but it's like stock fish
apparently
[Music]
yeah engine yeah on a computer or
something yeah did you ever
try to do a comparative check like is
how much stronger is this super computer
than a stockfish no no I'm I'll tell you
what I do when it comes to technology
okay between us between me you when I
was watching and Christian right right
whole world don't share it with anybody
else please keep it a secret because I'm
a bit ashamed what do I do okay so I'm
gonna pick up okay use this guy my phone
no kidding yeah I literally get my
repertoire that I've kind of hatched up
with my computer and then I pick up my
phone and I say for instance I'm
preparing a line in the caracan right I
play White and my my phone plays Black
and whatever it comes up with you know
because it beats me all the time anyhow
so whatever it comes up with I go and
put in my thing and I think look
good enough Magnus is not better than my
phone right so it's good enough
intriguing well now we know uh now we
know your training technique secrets
did I tell you about my toaster
got the most amazing chip now I'm not
going there sorry uh why is Hikaru on uh
Hikaru hasn't moved no Hikaru played 94.
he did not yeah I knew it yeah is he
really gonna go no no no he's gonna go
to E2 I really cannot believe that he
would go to C2
no he goes
um oh I should have taken you guys up on
a bet oh this is an alien are you
kidding me tonight C2
well if there is a sequence that's going
to make linear pause it was this one 94
followed by Knight to C2 there's no way
he was expecting this no way
I mean you know if you look at the
decision what's the what's the idea
behind it well exactly I mean today's
modern chess engines if you if you had
an adjourned position and you you came
and you told me that the sequence of
moves was to jump from
F5 to C2 I properly chide you and say
well what is your site doing on C2 I
mean that is I mean why is it better on
C2 than it is on he has the idea of
like going to maybe we're kind of like
overthinking this his whole concept
maybe is is just to go Knight A3 Knight
C4
and then what what's your night doing on
C4 I mean it's looking pretty it's him
it's on an outpost it was it was looking
pretty on F5 too okay night went okay
but now that your knight is danced away
you can't
the linear you know start tickling that
other night the other night like look
you you're the one misplacing your your
your your your Steed uh if you go back
to D7 man
possibly
try ideas of Bishop E7 and Bishop E6
you're introducing your little friend
yes E7
by the way Lanier under a minute yeah 45
55 seconds right I just don't know how
you do that by the way without
you know not just getting incredibly
nervous I mean you know the match is
literally on a thread find the force
variation after Queen F3 which is
perhaps Rook to D2
I mean I understood that there was some
kind of a repetition
uh but Queen F3 would be the move that
would attract my attention because why
not I mean uh Drive the night
and sorry no no it's fine and what maybe
I go Knight to G8 is that right that's
what he's trying to do
yeah
wow okay so there were nights on F5
and F6
and the Knights are now on G8 and C2 and
I'm sitting there scratching my head and
say why is this an improvement for black
no idea this game as a beginner's
example of how I was about to say yeah
right I mean
um all of our beautiful guidelines
Bishop F1 okay
okay so you've done as much damage as
you could on this diagonal I assume this
move is a kind of a greetings
when the night does come to C4 like I'm
ready to pounce and I'm still completely
stunned by this 94 Knight C2 me three is
just unbelievable
I wouldn't if I if I'm at the board I
wouldn't know what I was doing even if
you know people came to me after the
game and said wow that was great that
plan you came up with I was like I it
wasn't good like I'd be really
questioning my
my understanding so Hikaru definitely
came into this game with very aggressive
intentions well the whole opening Choice
the open Sicilian he does not want to
make a draw he wants to put pressure on
linear
he got what he wanted he got linear down
to his last final minute
he needs to find some complications and
maybe this was his way of
expressing himself in in that direction
right to D4 Knight to C2 well I'm sure
you know Hikaru has such a following on
the internet I'm sure a lot of uh people
on the internet are confused they say
well car is one of the greatest Blitz
players the world has ever seen why
wouldn't he welcome a tiebreaker with uh
faster and faster time controls well
I'll tell you one thing if this one is
going to work out in his favor
there's 94 Knight to C2 is going to make
for a juicy YouTube video
[Laughter]
yes these streamers yeah they're all
about content oh yeah yeah oh yeah
they've got to create they've got to
create content each and every day and so
if if he plays you know a really
confusing game I mean he's got like a
week of content to talk about it's gonna
be a lot of views yeah a lot of views a
lot of views okay uh how does the
computer evaluate the current position
uh after this move Bishop F1 battery is
better pardon me Hikaru is better Hikaru
is better is better Queen to F3 was not
the right one
way to F3 was
Lanier uring by playing a very human
move yeah no I that it looked it looked
very natural to my eyes yeah Knight to
A3 right now is a move Queen to C8 is a
very powerful move Queen
to C8 yes I mean I just played the move
Bishop F1 presumably to tickle the pawn
on B5 and you're saying Queen to C8
makes no sense right right like I mean
I'd pounce with two feet four arms and
three noses I was like worried Bishop
takes B5 now Rook A3
and now we're okay three uh-huh the
point is you can't defend that pawn it
doesn't make human sense guys but it's
beautiful geometry though that's
beautiful but yeah like this queen to G4
hits D1 perhaps not that perhaps okay or
maybe yes yeah maybe yeah maybe that is
okay
it's the same idea right Queen to ca
Target that point on C3 yeah without
necessarily dropping the pawn on B5
Bishop position right now you have
Knight to D4 or Knight takes B4 uh got
she move because the Knight doesn't have
any squares so you I mean I would be
playing Queenie too in a heartbeat right
uh but when you when you stop and think
about it and you realize Rook to D3 oh
91 oh nice Fork 20 seconds for linear
and Lanier is
wow I mean can is this also an
invitation to repeat the position
because of the queen E2 presumably
You're Gonna Go Rook A2
no I'm going to take on C3 oh yeah of
course
Bishop to C1 and Rook to B3 not Rook A2
I was about to say I thought it was an
invitation like you said to repeat after
Rook A2 would I play Bishop G5 Rook B3
rather quickly
D3
no because of night takes before
and uh linear again clock is ticking 16
seconds and going down
but the real question is how do I stop
Knight takes B4 it's not easy seven
seconds is that five seconds yeah three
two three one two three
just played one with one one second
and he did it almost like not usually
like yeah let me just put Michael but
wait a minute
the pawn on C3 it is that is a losing
move
right now is in a winning position
Rook takes C3 Bishop B2 but now we have
Knight F6
uh that's a beautiful Tempo against the
queen exactly
but let's see that again look how close
you said one second one second
there's one second very deliberate he
puts the queen properly in the middle of
the square
presses the claw one second
wow
I mean my hand would have been shaking
yes yes I would have I would have
whacked the clock and made everyone
aware that I didn't have too much time
Bishop yes B2 okay so Hikaru can toss in
a very nice Tempo gaining Knight F6 he
can drop back with the Rook
um
it now the vultures start coming right
because it should be winning uh what's
the easiest Joe V issue just what would
you do drop back with the Rooker play
Knight F6 I think I'll go Knight F6 I I
couldn't introduce the piece with some
time exactly I mean the only question is
I mean do you want Queenie no Queenie
two isn't even a problem right or it
could be well the reason I like Knight
F6 is because it really does ask the
question where do you want to go with
the queen if you go back to E2 I love
this I simply love this and how his work
takes nights yeah and you know it's sort
of like that game of Alice Lee she has a
Pawn on F3 I've got this gorgeous Pawn
on C3 that should be winning and we see
repetition the players are repeating the
position so we're gonna see them agree
yeah I guess they haven't played enough
times yeah no they're just confirming
that it was a draw and we will be having
a playoff come a little bit later I
think that'll be about 5 30 viewers time
let's put it that way
okay well our first playoff yeah I look
forward to that as we jump back to the
current position between Lanier and
Hikaru uh ikaru has played this really
really well and you're really taking
advantage of Lanier's clock
mismanagement I'll call it that because
that's exactly what it is and linear
often is intimate
stew on this position because I do
believe Alice Lee is just about to
finish her game okay okay
it doesn't seem like this one is going
anywhere but an easy victory for uh
obviously Knight to E4 you cannot
approach that pawn with the move King to
F2 I'm going to
take that pawn on F6 as well I'm going
to pretty much pick up every single one
of your Pawns wow and you're not even
going to be able to touch my F3 Pawn no
you're absolutely right this is actually
resignation then just as you described
Knight goes plunk on e4 and the pawn the
a pawn yeah it's a beautiful decoy as
well I mean you you would probably even
say black was winning without the a pawn
both yes it's on the board right it's
gonna go running black might be winning
without the A and the F3 Pawn it's that
bad yeah is that bad yeah
yep another location is just gonna March
towards oh well F2 beautiful
I'm not sure I actually don't I like I
like the march of the king
you can take your time with it you know
it's completely winning yes of course
either way it's just a very strange move
you know I suspect that she might even
March towards the
the queen size you might just forget
about these balls and just go A5 A4 King
will come forward yes recipe for Success
yeah absolutely amazing performance by a
13 year old yeah only dropped half a
point out of the foreign classical games
that she played she hasn't been playing
anything but classical games actually
yeah because of her 2-0 and now what
looks like one and a half and there's
the there's a resignation well done
well done Alex means Alice moves on in
the Champions bracket while well still
have a chance in the elimination bracket
and she's waiting for the loser between
tokyojanova and Irina crush is that
correct yes I believe that is correct
yes
no excuse me we let's be accurate yes
I just wanted to turn our attention to
game of Arena crash because again arena
is in the beautiful situation of needing
only a draw to clinch her birth into the
next round of the of the Champions
bracket and she has count them up one
two three four five Pawns
against a knight
and pawn but that night is Tethered to
H2 so irina's
[Music]
I mean it's a two result game let's put
it that way at this moment uh but our
congratulations to Alice Lee let's jump
back to the game of Hikaru and see uh
what has happened because after we left
it after Bishop B2 Knight F6 how how can
you not play the move Knight F6 is just
so irresistible
Rook to B2 Bishop C Bishop
um
C1 eyeballing Bishop H6 check and queen
tags and I dropped back queen d8 queen
E7
and we've now caught up to the players
the times if you don't mind yeah so the
times are
under a minute what Hikaru has 13
minutes to enjoy the position exactly
now Hikaru is a pawn up at uh he's
looking for more
um what do we what do we reckon he
should be doing here is Rook takes uh C4
uh a nice a nice Munch or is there
something wrong with that Rook takes
Rook takes B4 Rook D2 sorry excuse me
there's an issue there is an issue but
uh you know you can just simply use okay
you are threatening with beer porn but
the beef beef will also drop in return
you know I would can we get the night in
into great knight of six it's funny but
I was really wanting to get the queen
into play I'd love to play E4 and E3
don't I have Queen A2 as a Potential
Threat yes
especially if you go E4 because that's
right diagonal
but you you said you like Knight F6
maybe just Knight F6 bring the Knight
into play night night F6 94 ideas
694 ideas
hmm I kind of I I don't know I'm looking
for something a little bit cleaner than
all of this
how about just simple Knight to D4
that's a move is that uh but you can't
put pressure sorry please okay
um no I lie after Knight D4 yes I think
it's a good move yes then Bishop
comes out
to E3 Bishop to E3 yeah
pardon me on Instagram uh I'd love to
play Knight F6 I'd like to invite you to
capture so that I can bring my queen
you know something like this let me just
put some pieces on the board I apologize
and something like this where my queen
is you know I'm playing good night
versus bad Bishop right
um
this is not the current position this is
the position
I I'm just done by this whole sequence
that Hikaru found night D4 and Knight C2
because you know intuitively it's not
good it's not something that you you
want to do it's something that you've
calculated and you convince yourself
that the Knight is actually profoundly
good on season and look he's been taking
risks this whole game yeah from the
beginning with his opening Choice all
the way towards yet so Props to Hikaru I
mean absolutely you take this type of
massive risks and it pays off you might
be paid off yeah
by the way uh um maybe it was on move 36
that maybe yukaru spoiled it a little
bit after Rook B3 Bishop C1 why would
you play Knight G8 maybe you could just
play
no H5 Bishop H6 check yeah I think he
wanted to cover the H6 Square okay I
understand so you know for a moment
there I was wondering just to stop
Bishop H6 but he would do it any in any
way and uh wow in the meanwhile we have
a guest in studio with Christian Alice
you're continuing your campaign in the
Champions bracket this must feel good
right now especially after a victory
with the black pieces yeah so
um I felt like this game I was more of
hoping to stay solid and like not lose
that's more important
um but I felt like I had like no idea
what to do in the opening but I felt it
was actually very interesting
um after I was able to after she castled
queenside then I was able to play this
move Knight to G4 yeah so she's I think
sort of forced to play Bishop B1 and
then I win the H2 Pond after that I
wasn't sure I thought like it was a bit
awkward for me because um after she like
played Bishop H3 and it was this move
Bishop to E2 that seems to have uh
played in her favor did you consider
this move at all or
um yeah I thought I would play E4 and I
was actually a bit more concerned about
Bishop G2 and then uh she might have
Like Queenie two ideas but after E4
Queen to eat but I guess I have F5
that's interesting I didn't really like
that move but
um apparently then I probably will play
like Knight G4
so I guess the difference is after
Bishop E2 I wouldn't want to play F5 and
Knight G4 because uh the G6 pawn and
then also like a trip upon that's right
so I was planning to play E4 after that
and then I hit up three and I thought
that
um I thought that was actually Pleasant
for me
um because I would be able to like win
the pawn and I think the big difference
is that she's probably going to take
take and then make space for the queen
to Corral your Pawn with Queen D1 Queen
F3 this seems to lead to a very complex
battle but you are pretty happy with
this position right yeah I saw uh I
thought I had a good chance it's like B6
I was happy about because I don't think
it was possible like
um earlier before we traded off the
pieces
um you mean some around here yeah I
didn't I thought B6 uh then yeah there's
D takes C5 so it wouldn't be nearly as
good although I guess it's still
playable
um but I was more happy because I was
were to close the center so she wouldn't
have any E4 idea since my king is still
in the center
um and you got to this position and she
played this rather awkward move G4 it
felt a bit slow gave you the tempo to
play B6 and open up the position
that must have felt good and inspiring
for you yeah I thought um
[Music]
but that was also too slow yeah
um so I was happy with this B6 move and
then after
um Knight takes B6 I felt my position
was very good because I have these
really interesting ideas
um
so I was sort of focused on this idea of
Knight C4 and my idea is I want to play
Bishop A3 so if she doesn't do anything
um then I have this bishop A3 b6a3 Queen
takes A3 uh King D1 Knight B2 kidney two
queen A6 and that's I think let's just
play a move between three
um 92 King E2 Queen I said and I was
happy with this queen A6 move and I
thought I definitely have a lot of
interesting ideas and if she goes the
other way to B1 then The Rook is coming
yeah and then like grippy two and Knight
D2 and Knight B3 this is game over yeah
so she had to go for this rock to h8
Rook to B8 idea to cover up the B file
that Rook to B7 was coming with
tremendous consequences and this is the
move that
we found very uh very cool to see look
to see yeah so
um here uh I thought if she did work B7
then her work is like just really bad
I'll probably picking eight uh and I
always have ideas of like Knight B6 or
Knight D6 and the work is just not happy
326 as well so after she traded
um I thought I was better I was pretty
happy with the position and what I was
hoping for is instead of Bishop takes up
three
um I thought she could if she didn't
Knight takes E4 of this move 91 so
that's pretty nice
um but I think she probably saw it
otherwise uh
um but here it's good because she
actually has no easy way to get to the
F3 pawn and uh after Knight B1 Queen
takes they do she doesn't have many
moves left that are possible yeah this
position is just simply lost and you
converted it with clinical Precision
Alice uh you must be sensing already
that semi-final know what's your thought
about that I didn't think too much about
this today I thought I was trying not to
lose so I thought there might be a
playoff and I was fine with that
um but for right now I'm happy of course
to advance and
um I'll be playing either probably a
vegamar Arena so either Irina or beg him
but it does seem like Irina is in pole
position to take this one home yeah so
it would be similar to last year I did
lose two matches against her last year
but that definitely was some good
experience for me so I'll try my best
I'm not expecting too much but hopefully
it will go better this time guys any
questions no no just congratulations
Alice and good luck in your next match
thank you and once again let's refresh
our brackets after this uh as this
Champions leading to this number one
versus number two Showdown definitely
and you can see Alice is the first
person through to the next stage and she
will meet either the Victor or the arena
crush or tohenjo Nova and wow looks like
it's going to be a real crash at this
moment it does look like that and in the
elimination bracket Naji will be playing
against
so that's also going to be a very
interesting fight as everyone is
struggling for their lives they only
hope that they're in the last chance of
saloon exactly just looking at the game
of Arena it does look after this move B3
at a certain moment You're Gonna Go Rook
B6 B3 you're gonna have to give up this
H2 Pawn in order and you're you're just
gonna fight I mean even in a dream world
where you get recognition versus Rook
which is a real dream
uh yeah uh not is not working it's just
not working because let's see uh Let me
refresh the board for a moment because I
think Irena just played great practical
chess you know she it seems like she
understands the open Community
understands exactly what she needs to do
and here I just I loved her decision to
kind of go into this end game take those
four points I know you guys were that
was critical but I'll definitely say no
she made the right choice yeah I mean
you're not risking anything draw to
advance which is the main goal in this
competition for sure you want to advance
you want to maintain all your available
lives that you start off with this is
the easiest path to achieve that yeah
and after rookie two Bishop G2 G5 is
like the march of the ants right
which is at the board that's not
inspiring for us the white pieces no uh
Bishop F1 uh just on the board
keep keep the king cut
you know as a professional Blitz player
you put the Rook as far away so that
when you never get Fork you know if you
put your Rook on D2 and your king
marches to the E5 Square you could get
embarrassed by a knight and I think we
should check out what uh Dominguez
versus absolutely absolutely because
let's jump right to it when we left it
on seconds
22 seconds and going down and take a
look at that night wedged on F3 yes is
playing through the moves yep and queen
B2 last turn kind of intimating like hey
wait a minute you know this Rook takes
E3 ideas in the position as well as the
simple and direct Rook takes before that
somehow doesn't feel right Queen A6 is
this the invitation for Knight F6 to eat
to GPS
twice
you're ready
and Knight G4 I
and I understand why I mean it was nice
dreaming right now is to exchange the
Queens with Queen A1 right finally I
will not have to worry about getting
checkmated but wait your Bishop on E2 is
hanging no yes if you don't play Knight
F6 yeah okay then I have Queen A1 so
something like Rook to B4 for example
yeah maybe I'm not even going to
consider trying to get my Pawn back with
Bishop takes F3 but rather just exchange
the Queens yeah and he's done Knight F6
because the the threat of Knight G4 is
just so absolutely compelling and you
need to go wow this Rook on E3 uh pardon
me this night on G4 hitting E3 as well
as the Rook uh threatening Rook takes E3
um no Lanier is I mean look with no with
no time on his clock he's no I mean I
think he's facing an impossible time I
mean can he Survive by H3 H3 yeah I was
also wondering whether he could survive
back then Bishop takes Knight H3
okay at the moment the queen is kind of
tethered here right so I do have a move
like Rook A3 and asking you to
then the cream will come back to C4
can you just take that pawn on B4 is
that
well you're asking a question
that everybody with true chess knowledge
and understanding
would like to ask as well I would
suppose in this particular case
I will try to maintain the material
balance right Bishop takes F3 and King
takes F3 is there something more potent
you you want more yeah yeah because
Bishop takes F3 right now is not a
threat with the Rook on the third round
exactly Rook takes E3 which is very very
powerful I mean can you just so so for
example though right so hpod so the idea
what uh Christian just uh mentioned is
the idea that with the Rook on the third
rank Bishop takes F3 is going to be met
by Rook takes E3 so H5 but is there
something
you almost like want to wind up for some
we also have Haymaker
I mean you also have G5 G5
Hikaru is also falling down to his last
five minutes so the difference in it's
not awful it's not as extensive anymore
H5 H5 yes when in doubt push the age
Golden Rule Number
there's a lot of gold in those rules
I just plucked that number nowhere by
the way don't take me so seriously right
um but I kind of got an insight there I
was uh doing with Elizabeth Pates uh
commentary and it's sort of like she had
rules for all of these middle game
positions as well and I thought hey
regulations you know Germany is very
very very regulated Society we do this
and we do this H5 I like it just asking
Lanier who's got no time on his clock to
come up with something decent
King F1 okay
with nine seconds well that's a kind of
a relief for Hikaru because it means
that Bishop F3 is never a concern so
perhaps at the same time Queen A1 is now
in the air again because the pawn the
pardon me Bishop is defended
okay
who's like also the queen queen E5
centralizing
well it's more like he wants to defend
this Pawn on D6 and me threes takes E3
right now Queen takes G3 oh yeah C3
Queen takes G3 I think it's the game
over if you allow me to do that that's a
killer so I think you have to step okay
yeah well Bishop F4 Queen F5 gift me
this part but also Queen E5 is obviously
ready you're you're ready now to play
Knight takes D5
how much time does uh he's got four
seconds three two
and how much time one second no not
again how does he do that I mean he's
he's do I have H4 H forges
H4 that looks great ridiculous the idea
being that you can't play G4 and allow
Queen H2 H4 Bishop F4 is might be his uh
idea
hey we've been told that uh there is a
killer blow in the position Rook takes
Bishop we'll finish and then probably
you go eight and after that age four
right that sure feels uh clinical
doesn't it Hikaru is smelling something
yeah he's sensing it okay these guys
dreams about these type of tactics no
boom
that's the blow yeah that's it he finds
this type of tactics every Tuesday every
Tuesday during the title Tuesday with a
couple of seconds on his clock this is
easy cake walk foreign
of course what we're talking about is
the tournaments that are played every
Tuesday on chess.com they're called
title Tuesday Blitz event and it
features The Who's Who of Chess I mean
everybody shows up the top
100 players in the world
there you go
handshake and our congratulations to
Carlos he's the first to book his seat
into the next round impressive very
really impressive game by Hikaru I think
so too me too from the opening
throughout middle game throughout what a
champion yeah
and that's why he's the number one seed
coming into this event we do we will
have a playoff Wesley so versus Fabi who
will be challenging Hikaru into the next
round but in the meanwhile we still have
one remaining game in the classical uh
and that is between
um Arena and babe
and uh all Arena needs is a draw to
continue her
um
campaign yes
and it looks like she's doing a great
job she sure is I mean she's got four
connected postpones
White's King I'm not great exactly I
mean the only thing she has to be aware
of is that the bishop on F3 is loose
right and one fine day you you would
like to secure it I mean it it at first
blush there was this double attack right
the Knight could hit the Rook The Rook
will hit the bishop and you think oh no
I blundered until you do see this move
and what you say you anchor the bishop
with the move G4 and that's all she
wrote that's wonderful for white pardon
me a wonderful for black and that is why
vegan played the move Rook A4
uh trying her best to maintain the
defensive line G4
um wow uh to result game of course
and uh in one case uh
a draw will get her further in yeah
what was that she participated Rook A3
yeah and uh rugby two Arena and Arena
saying okay I mean I'm not playing for
rating points I'm playing for the
qualification for the next round is she
really offering a draw yes she is I mean
I mean probably a position of strength
obviously but uh so I guess yeah yeah
there is absolutely no reason to to risk
even though you're not actually risking
much right so I don't know I I would
definitely pay off you know you why
expend all the energy
grinding out a win when a draw is as
good as that good point yeah
and once again uh refresh where we stand
with the open yeah so after that very
convincing Victory Hikaru Nakamura is
the
Champion stage meanwhile we are awaiting
a playoff between Wesley sir and Fabiana
caruana as their match was tied and it's
very
unlikely a playoff in the ladies but in
the elimination bracket in the
elimination bracket it is lenia
Dominguez who gets set down and now has
the face off against Sam Shanklin
whereas Levon aronian is awaiting the
loser of the match between Fabiana
carwana and Wesley so I mean but this is
still insanely strong exactly I mean
when you look at the elimination bracket
and you imagine Wesley so and or we're
probably playing off against LeBron who
got you same to yourself what kind of
tournament are you guys running
these guys are the ones who are being
eliminated I mean like Magnus to show up
what was going on
and we do believe that this game is
likely to end in a repetition yeah and
she's saying that rookie 2 is her
intended move and Chris bird the Arbiter
is just double checking on his monitor
that that will be a third time
for begum it's one of those deja vu all
over again it is but at the same time I
think it was a very good learning
experience for her well at a certain
moment the learning has got to stop it's
time to do some teaching okay remember
she's playing very been playing very
well I mean the first two games are very
impressive against numsova and here I
mean Irina just showed her why she is
Grandma Grandmaster and it is a good
learning experience and now she has to
take that because she'll be facing off
against atusa focaccian in the next
round right and this is to be honest
after the opening and after that
exchange sacrifice the best result for
Baguio because if you lose once again
then you go into that rapid match with a
very very low morale right you make a
draw okay at least you didn't lose you
didn't feel that stink of losing a game
of chess which we know it can be very
very potent so this is what right now
begging has to do she needs to
understand that she still has one more
life to go in the competition she will
be facing atusa in the next round so she
has to go back home train as hard as
possible for that match and go get ready
for for it and put on a good performance
right
well as we get ready for uh the Fabi
versus Wesley show I'll put it like that
we expect that to be coming up very
shortly about
5 30 or so but we have a guest in studio
Hikaru an impressive performance all
around you started off with this very
intriguing opening Choice how did you
come up with the Kalashnikov yeah I mean
there are a couple things first of all
uh you know I'm just here to have fun so
why why not play something to surprise
my opponents uh you know I did it
against Sam against Lanier felt the same
way
um yeah I mean I've I've played every
saline Under the Sun against we've
obviously played many times um but I
just want to do something different and
he spent a lot of time and I think in
the one control format it's very very
difficult if you've got way down on the
clock and somewhere in the middle game I
felt good but I lost the threat a little
bit
um I mean the first thing is like yeah
obviously if you go back here I mean and
this Rook to B8 was very intriguing as
well yeah well I mean this is the Parham
line Max Hood Loop plays this all the
time
um but yeah I mean the thing is uh like
Knight D5 is the best move
um like 95 takes takes a 97 but I mean
the big thing here is that of course uh
the computer doesn't even okay the weak
engines don't even say what the best
move is yeah of course yeah I mean I
don't play chess so I can say this but
yeah G4 is obviously the best movement
it's very very sharp and nobody knows
what's going on but if you don't know
that's the move it's almost impossible
to play and yes we're actually guessed
it and uh he didn't have the engines
yeah I mean it's easy to uh it's easy
when you're not playing because I mean
if Yasser was playing he plays G4 and
lose every everyone's gonna pretty much
tell him like you know you say don't do
this don't do that you push a pawn you
lose like a clown and you're you're just
a total idiot so I mean it's much
different because when you're not
playing like if you suggest movement is
bad I mean there's nothing can go wrong
really but when you're in the moment
playing obviously it's very difficult
and um I had a feeling that linear
wasn't going to play it I thought he
would play G3 and I mean I thought it
should have been completely fine in this
opening um but somewhere I lost the
thread yeah I like I thought yeah that's
okay don't worry I've done that um but
yeah like if you go back to round B4
around move 20 yeah like keep going keep
going yeah we castle Yeah somewhere
around here I thought I should be fine
but I lost the thread when I went Knight
C5 I don't know if B4 was better or
before it was one of the top moves I
think and F5 as well because basically
what I decided was some yeah I just
miscalculated the Slime Knight C5 Queen
E2 Queen C7 and and I just I just
completely underestimated B4 and F B4
and Rook A5 sorry
um and then like yeah already here I
mean probably for a computer it's still
okay but I I didn't feel very good about
it because I thought I had it all under
control and then I didn't and I didn't
have to give up the bishop yeah I taken
them play 905 and I it still wasn't so
sure though
um
I played Rook A7 which I thought was re
I thought he could actually take the
pawn too I was yes I was a little
surprised that he didn't do it because
it looks kind of ugly after Knight takes
E3 uptakes E3
but I'm not able to win back the pawn
right away and yeah I can play ignite B6
or something but if I'm not getting F5
and E4 in like say just play just play
Knight P6 or okay fine whatever just
play Knight B6 I don't know some stupid
move King H1 F5 King G1 E4 like if I get
this where the bishop on G2 is very bad
this should be very good for me but the
problem is I thought that in this line
uh instead of like King H1 of course
after Knight B6 that white can go like
E4 here at some point
yeah maybe maybe it doesn't maybe this
position doesn't work but I thought like
if I'm not getting F5 E4 I thought that
white white should just be up the pawn I
mean okay obviously here I guess it
doesn't work but yeah but yeah like I
thought here that I was in trouble then
he played Rook A7
and I thought I was once again
completely okay keep going yeah
where are you playing for an advantage
right now or well see here I thought it
was completely fine and then about three
moves later I I thought I was suddenly
in a lot of trouble okay this was the
critical moment though you played Knight
F6 Bishop G5 King to G7 and G2 H3 and
you spent quite a lot of time here
almost 20 minutes so I can actually go
King G5 wow I mean I spent a lot of time
because yeah it's on 97 and 97 was what
I want to do but takes takes an F4 uh
and originally I thought I had Queen A7
King H1 and queen D4 but this actually
loses to uh Queen F1 I believe yes and
then you take the check on E5 and the
king is completely exposed so this was
the original idea then yeah I kind of
thought I could maybe take on F4 but it
just I don't know it looks so ridiculous
and now you go to Jesus Queen F6 Queen
E3 or something
Queen F6 Queen E3 and yeah you're
actually winning this one
yeah I mean from a distance I saw that I
could place but it just it looks it
looks so bad so this was your main
line that you were calculating yeah I
was calculating this for a long time and
then finally when I when I just saw my
Kings to open and I started looking
other lines I thought I came up with
this Knight E4 idea I mean initially
actually I also thought after see after
C3 I could play Rook A3 here but this
actually loses I think is why you can
take and go Queen E4
and if I take on C3 there's Rook D4 Rook
C1 King G2 takes Queen F4 now you have
some Knight beat I
P3 here which is okay yeah I mean this
loses of course because Rook C1 Queen F4
yeah actually Queen D4 first is better
but you can even take the check and then
check on E3 yeah yeah but
so Knight B3 okay I mean yeah again
chess yeah yeah so then what I thought
was done so then after C3 I came up with
this other idea I thought well now I can
go Knight C2 and put the Knight on A3
and then put the Knight on C4 this is
actually what I thought I mean it looks
kind of weird but if I get the Knight to
C4 it's only both of those Knights are
very well placed yeah
um so this I thought was an idea and I
didn't see what I didn't see a way for
white to win here so I figure if it's
not not winning and Lenny being low on
time I can just kind of go and do
whatever and probably the best for him
would have been to go Rook dito Rook D1
and yeah but it's very hard to because
like you don't know like is should white
be better should white should black be
better like if the game goes on who's
better it's not really clear with the
Bishops versus the knights so I thought
yeah Queen after I think was a mistakes
after an IGA I mean White's probably
still okay but now I think it becomes
very hard to play because in the long
term the night on G8 should be better
than the vishwan G5 yeah and of course I
can always put the other Knight on A3 so
and very cool idea towards the end was
uh this H5 move yeah it doesn't seem
like you have anything more to do but
finally yeah I mean he kept defending
ridiculously while I was waiting for him
to make a blunder and then he kept kept
playing good moves
um and yeah H5 I don't know if it's
actually winning but I mean ideas oh it
is okay well I mean it's also hard for
me because I don't have the moves like
originally I thought he had blundered
Rook A3 I thought Rook A3 like Queen C4
and some 95 or something is good but of
course on Rook A3 there's Bishop C1
instead of Queen C4 and now I think if
anything white might be better that's
right that's right yeah yeah so you
close the show quite nicely with this
yeah Checkmate that you would probably
see every Tuesday in New York something
like that yeah I mean it would have been
nice if I like he well I guess Queen
g1's made in one but if I could get 95
93 would be even better but all right
it's too too much you will be playing
the winner of Fabi versus Wesley how do
you see that match play out which is
actually starting interesting yeah I
mean I think that's a coin flip it just
depends who who probably who gets a
better position out of the opening
um or who's up on time when they get
into the scramble I don't really see any
big difference between either of them I
mean Fabiano I don't remember was this
last year's championship or the previous
one who Fabiano won the last one right
so it would have been two years ago
there's that Wesley won in the
tiebreaker but in like I'm thinking of
that tiebreaker and I think Fabiano got
a much better position maybe even
winning then of course got too low on
time messed it all up Wesley ended up
winning so I I think there's very little
difference between them and it doesn't
really matter who I play Hickory thank
you very much congratulations once again
we'll see you tomorrow sure our
congratulations as well fantastic game
by Hikaru as we get ready for the
playoffs and who will meet Hikaru in the
next round yeah that is what is going to
be decided in the next few minutes the
players are seated at the board and
there we can see Hikaru
just easily Breeze through that cave I
mean it was amazing to see his
calculation but he said it himself it
will be a coin flip between Wesley so
and Fabiana caruana and there we see
Dominguez War face off against Sam
Shanklin whereas the loser of this next
playoff will be meeting Lavon aronian
tomorrow
and for the ladies and in the women's
section that's all been decided no
playoffs needed there it is Arena crash
against Alice and Lee I mean both
players on red hot form number one and
number two yeah I mean you live for
these moments in the elimination bracket
and in the elimination bracket we see
that Naji paikitsa will be playing off
against Tata Abraham abrahamian whereas
begin will be paying off against a Tusa
so they are still left in the last
chance of losing but business in hand
here it is it is the playoff between the
big two Wesley so Fabiana Corona number
seven against number eight in the world
whoever gets the better openings yeah I
have to say I feel like Fabi has been
very well prepared up to a point but
then you see him make a tiny slip up and
then he's defended very resourcefully we
need to hook Chris bird to the show and
tell him okay we're ready to start let's
go okay yes
there we go handshake there you go off
we go
and once again to remind everybody it's
a 25 minute plus no exactly 10 minutes
10 minutes five seconds yeah I was so
close on this one
was five then they play three plus two
then they go into the Armageddon right I
was thinking of the elimination
and they're off
I need some help I think this should be
5a6 we have a standard rui Lopez
let's see if uh Wesley maybe uh will
take a page from shanklin's book and
take on C6
Lopez no he's none of them Bishop back
and uh but it's very nice to see them
not playing at Berlin but will we see a
marshall that's the next question right
B5 well I'm no a classical or Archangel
uh with Bishop C5
I'm happy that I'm not saying D2 D3
these are this is where the theoretical
battles really uh start here
C3
yeah and let's go A4 First bishop to B7
Bishop B7
X it's all very standard right but I
have to say one thing Fabi has chosen
the sharpest line in this Royal Lopez I
know because I used to play this myself
many many moons ago how'd you do
I lost red well I I won some games but
then I got smashed off the board by
Natasha boykovic and after that I
thought I'm not touching it yeah I'm
keeping my character sour sourd you uh
terribly I it's like certain players
love the dragon and it's in their blood
but sometimes you get so badly wounded
it's like you drop kick in the opening
and the defense out the door keep in
mind what Hikaru said he said that
whoever is going to get better opening
positions or will gain an advantage on
time and right now Fabiano is up two
minutes
wow that's a significant in the 10
minute game especially so early on in
the opening right and d2d3 uh kind of
shows that he like backed down from The
Challenge I want to say c3d yeah c3d4
uh and uh well
um
let's see you can go for the Knight C3
Knight D5 lines they they seem rather
tepid and I think this is should be
doing uh C3 was played C3 you should try
to find the more tame approach in the
position try to quiet the game a little
bit as white as Wesley because he's
falling down on time and it's obvious
that Fabiano is very much aware of what
he needs to do in this position I'm
really surprised I see on my screen that
it says rui Lopez morphe morphe defense
variation which I I would never
associate this with Paul morphy uh
a7a6 is basically Paul morphy's
contribution on move three
uh not this stuff this stuff is like
really modern and you know Ultra sharp
so in general when you play so shy with
the white pc3d3
it feels like you're combining more than
one plants you started off with A4
hinting at the fact that you're going to
attack the pawn on B5 then c3d3 doesn't
make a lot of sense do you go for D5 and
try to be aggressive or D6 well I got
the answer from Fabi yeah we didn't have
to wait too long but I have to say with
c3d3 I mean what do white is trying to
do is actually try to get D4 one and do
it at a time when black is not ready to
kind of catch them it was by question
why not D5 instead of D6 but okay we're
going to get that answer a different
time well here I mean I don't see Knight
D2 Knight F1 as the root I would see
Knight A3 which would be a fight C2 and
Knight E3 as a route to the center he
didn't he played Bishop to G5 and if I
were white I would just say guns but he
doesn't he actually does make the trade
and he's gonna go Bishop to D5 so the
idea is you give it the the two Bishops
that you ensure that with this move
Bishop D5 black doesn't get to keep both
of them and this bishop so white is
saying I want to play Knight versus this
bishop and probably once again he's
looking at ideas of playing B4
taking on B5 and playing Knight to A3 so
let's make a move for black something
probably not very good I apologize I'm
just putting so we can at least
understand what Wesley is aspiring to do
which is to grab this Pawn on B5 so
that's why in this particular position
the theoretical move is what uh
Christian oh
B4 B4 yeah to make sure that you don't
end up with a sore Pawn on B5
makes sense
although I must say suddenly
Bobby stopped
he played H6 Allah Tempo everything was
going very very well he's gone for AB8
which has been played before really just
in one game
so
okay
it's a little confounding move isn't it
okay so if I play okay Rook B8 Wesley
doesn't need asking twice before on the
board I mean we know what Wesley's up to
he's he's trying to create a weakness
upon on B5 sometimes what they do is you
just give up the B4 Pawn so after Pawn
takes porn
putting a lot of pressure on that B5
Pawn exactly
asking it does him I was saying that
this is not Theory but it was played
between Sophie Mia and kubichka Anna
perhaps Jovi you know these two players
of course I know it's a female very well
she's an international Master very
dangerous player very aggressive and uh
the move that black played there and it
makes a lot of sense is actually to pay
Knight E7
Knight to E7
and after the trade of Bishops and Dare
I ask
what happens if I take a pawn well I
think the idea is to go Bishop takes
porn
I was hoping you would do this because I
have this nasty little idea right 94.
that's your queen
is on the same line as the Rick oh dear
oh dear yes oh dear so that's that's
that's not good that's the Cheapo that I
had in mind so night so I'm that looks
like a very difficult position right now
for Fabiano how do you defend that pawn
on B5 not easily and if you don't and
allow my queen to go to wave four and
Target those weaknesses on the queen
side I mean this is not looking good
that can't be right because by the way
Fabi has less time on his clock right
now than Wesley at one point he was up
two and a half minutes right Knight A3
yeah
putting the pressure because Wesley
stopped and he played C3 in Bishop G5
some kind of deliberation and he was
probably just you know recalling his
files and what he wanted to do and then
suddenly Bobby who had been playing
okay he takes on a easily stopped and
exhaust that sometimes Right Wesley does
this type of
pause and think and try to figure out
what even if he knows the theory he will
still pause and choose what he wants to
play by the way up to this moment I
think that this has been played before
including your 97 move but takes on
um pardon me takes on A4 is actually the
novelty perhaps the novelty and Knight
to C4 I like the queen takes a42 I
didn't see anything wrong with that
Wesley's probably thinking it it's nicer
to take with the Rook
he would
this I have to say is a very
uncomfortable position truly black right
now no joy no and I have to say usually
in these kind of Archangel positions the
white Bishop you give up the B Pawn but
the white Bishop is hovering on G4 this
bishop is on B7 is such a bad piece and
it's a 97 played 97 Bishop takes he's so
happy to get to to capture that Bishop
off the board Bishop takes and Rook
takes and now instead of a weak Pawn on
B5 is a weak Pawn on A6 and
Bobby's actually decided he's going to
hold on to that pawn for as long as he
can yeah he's played the move Rook so in
anticipation of the one idea of Knight
G6 to Knight F4 that I see for for for
for black G3 King G2 meeting you at the
pass before you even get there is a
setup there but I feel like I want to
cause you to play the move Knight to G6
so that I can dominate that night with
G3 so I'm going to wait for you you need
to I'm going to get ready to double up
on the a file take the pawn on A6 and
when you play the move Knight to G6
that's when I go G3
did you see that little idea it was one
of the ladies that did that um
like her opponent had not put the piece
directly in the center it's kind of like
it's a polite way of telling your
opponent hey put your pieces in the
center of the board Queenie two uh as
you said
uh Wesley
yeah just pressing wait for it to go
night too
which he doesn't
he he goes for the strike in the center
with Queen to E6 perhaps preparing him
well he recognizes he recognizes that 96
Knight F4 is going to lead nowhere
frankly and perhaps even help white yeah
so F5
opening up a different
line okay well let
Dare I ask
can I take the bond Rook Rook A1
sometimes chess is uh simple simple game
simple is a simple dose I mean but okay
presumably Fabi wants to hold on to that
pawn for as long as he can
okay just checking
uh and after okay someone can you go
E4 like how are you going to increase
the pressure
in the position I like G3 and King G2
just sidestepping this bishop but then
you know I'm gonna go F5 try to mix it
so you're taking your time he's watching
oh yes uh all day I wait for F5 I mean
F5 I can go Queen A2 so yeah I would be
very very attracted okay
G3 exactly now
well we see that the players so the idea
once again if you go G3 F5 King G2 uh
you've played F5
a rook A3
gun
okay now he has to go for it it has to
go f
but as okay so hang on a second after I
move like F5
if he decides to pull the trigger okay
are we gonna see Queen A2 why not why
not and Knight takes Bishop is in the
air one takes Pawn is also threatened
yeah the move F5
it comes with a little risk associated
as well so perhaps what I can try for is
just oh let's say I take only four once
and you dig back
if I go King H7
my Spidey Sense tingled there King H7
yeah okay nothing untoward happened I
agree no I know you take only six and
I'm actually out of time I cannot take
take that was my plan and try to shy
away with other go look at Faith but
now you can force the trade of the
Queens with Knight xp6 that's right
that's just that's just a nasty ending
nobody likes that ending yeah uh black
is going to need uh more than this guys
Rook A3 on the board a real challenge to
Fabi as the clocks are even even yeah
four minutes 58 seconds five minutes and
13 seconds for Fabi and we're really
looking I mean I'm I really want to play
the move D5 and if I have to play F6 to
play D5
well I'm not happy but I've got to do
something I miss the queen is coming to
A2 truly nice back to C6 he's not going
to be is he you know what I think he
might do no I I I mean he's kind of
following that whole idea you've got one
weakness we defend that weakness with
our life I mean the the the the the
visual of the double Brooks underneath
oh my God oh my gosh that looks like
Ray's Pard there's a chess Grandmaster
Hans Ray from Holland a Tavern was named
after him and the tavern's name was
raise apart and it wasn't meant to honor
Hans Ray but it was meant to mock him
because the night was so badly placed on
me it's a Race part we raise horse but
he might actually want to go there I
know I think he will I do too I mean
I'll be honest with you I think it's a
great idea I think you know we've been
unsuccessful with Dynamic attempts and
when that fails you just have to grit
your teeth and seize the defense
58 Rick A7 Rook A8
nice by the way uh I've been chiming in
for some time it took him a while but G3
G3 King G2 is coming up and just asking
into the show you know this is like one
of the things that certain openings do
tend to do this particular choice of
opening has landed
fobby in an awkward spot he's just
playing defensive chess and there are
other uh there's like Sicilians where
when you lose upon you get you know
compensation A5 okay that's that's a big
that's bold
if it works
he takes A5
okay because
D3 D4 so you've got to take with a knife
why can't he take it back with the
Knight yeah you do but isn't this a
problem Knight takes Pawn takes now how
are your night
like if I play D5 does your knight get I
guess well it does
it get back yeah
take take on D4 first
a pause
because you I can take with a tempo
right eye takes
I mean my intention of course was to
take and to do something like this
Knight takes B6 and he's done it yeah
and now let's let me just this is the
current situation right he's still not
out of the woods but it does feel like
it's much more pleasant than it was
three moves ago let's say yeah but it's
an A5 move was was important okay but
once again B4
okay that that's a switcheroo
the old Switcheroo saying that okay you
had to walk one weakness I focused on it
for a very long time now let's go to the
next one
wow and probably fobby's going to say
okay I'm doubling up on the B5 now
I mean we saw this one game of Ray
robson's where it was a real real master
class in the ending we might be seeing a
middle game by Wesley so which equally
is an extraordinary masterclass Rook B4
that's a heck of a move what about D4
now oh that looks now that the Rook has
been lured to the A6 Square I'm loving
this move d4 that is Juicy but she's not
reaching anything
towards that move Rook to B5 and 90 only
after Rook B5 now D4 is a threat
wow he's really trying to focus on that
pawn on E5
but what is the idea after the night
Retreats you're just taking and going to
go D4 you
know I wasn't sure seriously I mean yes
taking on A6 and D4 yes anything to be
said for Rook B3 yes
it's awesome as well
yeah because I I mean it's like I've
I've just about have Supremacy
everywhere better on the king side
better in the center better on Queen
side
yeah no it's not a difficult task not an
easy task to defend this position with
the black pieces for Fabiano no
yeah
three minutes after he's 96. next to C6
the thing about Knight B7 then I'm going
to trade by D4 and the Knight on B7 is
lousy looked in lousy and uh here by the
way I'm a pond Grabber so I would be
asking questions like Rook takes and
queen A3 okay I have some ideas in case
you go to B3 okay I have an idea Queen
H3 that was you stole my idea oh sorry
give a guy a chance sorry my apologies I
mean she really stole that did she ever
she reached right into your mind
took it away then took it away uh no uh
you know what
take that Rook play King G2 uh no more
Queen H3 no Queen H3 businesses prep the
move Queen E3 yeah but wait one second
you've got news like
I'm just trying to I thinking now that
you have to unbalance the whole
situation so move the night and I was
thinking E7 he did it he did it he did
it
yeah we go D4 now or D4 do you have no
but 19 G6 is going to be met by Rook
takes E5 wait a minute
D4 opens up a nasty
but you've got Rook A2 and you also
also has a full well we'll check this
out we'll we'll fall for the training
for the Trap that's okay but how is that
I don't think that's good for you I take
one F4
not good for me no I would I was so
proud of myself I was about to do king
F1 give myself some sort of
congratulatory perhaps Queen C8 Queen F5
metal and the
ring
in it
this looks really really good uh Queen
to E3
um where do we stand pardon me Rook 2 A3
was the move but after Rook to A3
doesn't that give white the option of
closing things up with C4 and then later
on focusing on the V6
Knight to E7 Queen E3 and now Rook to A3
was that this is the current position
yes yes okay
this is a very tense game right now
truly
C4 I mean but after C4 do you still have
ideas of Knight G Knight G's through six
sorry maybe even Knights C8 I'm a little
bit more attracted to the move no Queen
C1 rugby three apologies apologies yeah
and perhaps this C4 on the board
and so we're expecting yeah
I mean I was wondering Knight G6 you can
get aggressive with Knight G6 and queen
G4 right well I wanted to go Knight F4
H3 is gonna shut you down so if you go
Knight G6 I just want to make sure that
I don't suffer the consequence of Queen
G4 Knight F4 check and guess what you
can kiss your Pawn goodbye
okay nicely refuted Noel no no no no no
no that's uh that's what pond grubbers
do
um C4 and the clocks are
the last one
okay so with the Knight super passive
now it's time for this Knight to do its
own little dance what do you want how
does it get to D5 that's the 92
91.95 Knight G2 Knight E3
well for the moment Knight F5 is on the
agenda G6 stopping what what what what
he's given up the point at age six and I
think about the Rook takes D3 Well he
kind of visibly rocked backwards when he
realized wait a minute wait a minute
there's Knight F's three three and ig5 I
mean that's that's a big question but we
have six Queen G7 defends it who knows
Wesley trusts his opponent
King G7 H4 taking even more space I'm
not sure how I feel about this move H4
I'm not I'm not sure mostly because I
allow this queen to come to G4 so easily
something about the move Knight H4 I I
was thinking we were going to go Knight
to
uh D2 to B1 that's right to C3 to D5 and
I liked it when the Knight went to C8
immediately
quote Walter Brown
um F6
these guys are going down the wire I
don't know what the queen is actually
doing on the if I play H5 it just needs
to make a move right now but H5 looks
very very attractive
he's going for the plan with Knight B1
yeah I always like the the the knights
love outposts that are well defended
Rook A5 definitely not going to trade no
we're not Rook a and give you a pass
Pawn not on your life Rook a three
Knight to B1 that was the whole plan you
did not like that Fabi shook he said was
like oh no I missed that
okay one I'd see three
despite the fact that you are having
some control around my king on G2 you
don't have a follow-up Queen E6 but the
Knight finally landed on the gorgeous
Outpost Knight D5 and that really should
spell Doom I think right now the B6
Bobby is
Queen G4 just trying to be as irritating
as possible by by lurking to D1 don't
play Queen F3 because Rook to G1 will
come on the board and finish the game
that is true
queen queen D1 is lurking Knight C3 goes
back to defense it doesn't
like allowing
Rook A3 these guys are full of tricks I
know isn't it the truth they're so
resilient
so difficult and resisting playing F3
Rook back to A1 yeah don't go after
clocks times the clock times are Fabiano
is around 40 seconds and Wesley now
ticking close to a minute and he's back
on D5
okay so in this case he's actually
threatening Knight to E3
Rook to D1 Queen will go to C2
and he was he's got 93 uh
I apologize and he's got Knight E3 for
king queen and Rook but the Rook is
simply gonna but if he goes back to wave
one right now do I have yeah yes oh he's
he's allowed it he's allowed Knight E3
and Rook takes B6 because there is a
discovery Against The Rook coming up
Queen to D7 so he can snare upon oh
thanks be six pics
no he snared the pawn
okay there wasn't even a chance for you
know exploiting space with D4 but okay
pawn more
Knight to A4
F4 by Wesley by the way earlier in their
game today Wesley did manage to win a
pawn but not the game it was actually uh
pretty darn good defense by Fabi he'll
have to do it again F4 Queen E8
D4 default G4 D4 D4
I like Knight G4 Knight G4 perhaps take
on E5 first and then Knight to G4
that would provoke F6 and then Queen C1
I like it I like where you're going
what's better than being one Pawn up H5
okay
but how do we feel about this you cannot
take back with a Pawn on G6 because
Queen A7 comes on the board correct is
with the King but that means the Knight
gets that gorgeous outpost on F5
normally that's good enough for some
kind of chat meeting let's go Knight F5
right right 95 Knight takes D3 Queen D1
and the queen comes to G4 that's not
looking promising for black no he's in
the he's a you bet that is such a
powerful night on F5 Square now
he's had to tuck his King under the in
the corner but I mean still you have
moves like to get ready to defend upon
on H6 with the queen on the six three
one E6
guys
no no no Queen A7
Queen A7 Knight D3 Queen E3 he's played
Queen A3 I like this move but I like
Queen A7 when you see now moving a seven
and he's done it
good catch and now black has to go
Knight to D7
nothing else Works he's done it
Queen to A5 the queen is coming towards
d8 getting closer and closer to that f8
square the Glorious f8 Square going to
G6 Queen to d8
Queen C7 D5
Queen to E6 that's uh oops that's a
clinical move by
I've been making that move with two
seconds two seconds okay there it goes
there goes a pawn that's Pawn number two
Knight to G4
I'm assuming Queen F4 Queen F4 looks
good because you just hang around five
with one
no he hand checked communication is that
what it's called
when it comes to D2 okay this is not
that easy anymore oh no he he he that
Queen E7 would have been right Bobby's
fighting kicking still 10 seconds for
Wesley this is not over
C5
F6 not H4
well we do have
six five what is happening
on some tracks Queen to B7 is a big
threat it certainly is Queen B7 is nasty
you go King G6 Queen will land on
and Fabi with seconds on the clock
five seconds has to go back with the
Knight that's not not a good sign C6 on
the board right C6
Queen to G4 he's got nine seven
and I think he's gonna throw in a few
checks I wonder whether you you very
much definitely help his cause because
Queen to E7 Queen takes F6 is coming and
that's it there it is
what a tense battle wow
but I have to say I was impressed that
Wesley got an advantage and he kept it
the entire time that's really hard to do
against these guys you you slip up for
the moment
they're out but what a victory uh in
this first tiebreaker I impressed
truly kept control
it didn't allow fat single chance one no
one there was one moment when you could
have potentially escaped this was the
moment he played the move Rook to A3
which allowed this consolidation of the
pawn structure with the move C4 after
that Knight D2 Knight b193 comes on the
board and that pawn on B6 is going to be
doomed what he should have played was D5
defending the pawn on B6 at the same
time as freeing up your position if you
do take on D5 I'm going to take back
with the Knight you can exchange take
take and now I take one C3 this is going
to be a draw so D5 that was the critical
moment he did not find it he played the
move Rook to A3 and right now he is in a
must-win situation with the white pieces
in order to continue this match
wow I have to say that that was such an
impressive game these tiebreak games I
mean
they're quite high quality I mean that
Ray Robson Sam Shanklin ending I mean
Ray won the game and lost the match but
what a game he won that was great and
this was impressive impressive and uh
well Fabi is gonna have to bring his
most impressive form because he is now
in a must win situation maybe we'll take
a quick break as we just once again this
is our playoff picture yeah you can see
Wesley was triumphant in that game and
he will now face off against Fabi with
the black pieces Fabi needs to win
nothing else is sufficient
oh I think we're going to take a
breather right yeah exactly
[Music]
as uh this game will be coming up in
what about five short minutes it's not
it's not going to be long three and a
half minutes so quick break and we'll
see you on the other side
foreign
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess is
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions in our Galleries and sign up
for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
thank you
can you hear it
it's the sound of Hope
[Music]
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
[Music]
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
[Music]
personalized Health Care
and active communities
it sounds like life and it's what you
hear when you really listen
listening to you caring for you we are
Ascension
chess and St Louis is back with nine
major tournaments throughout the year it
all kicks off in March with the second
edition of the American cup with 16
players across two Fields fighting for a
300 thousand dollar prize fund in this
double elimination tournament with both
classical and Rapid time controls for
the first time since 2020 the Cairns cup
is Back featuring the world's best
female chess players competing for a 180
000 prize fund beginning June 3rd
seasonal Classic Events are back
starting with the spring chess Classic
on April 5th the summer chess classic
August 2nd followed up with the St Louis
Norm Invitational and the winter chess
classic wraps up the year in December
September brings back everyone's
favorite
all right it seems like the games have
started well the game has started
Fabiano caruano with the white pieces is
in a must-win situation against Wesley
so who is as calm as collected as always
but nevertheless right now Fabiano seems
to be playing the same thing he did in
the classical and perhaps he will have
an extra idea we've seen how important
those are we've seen that in the match
between Shanklin and Ray Robson so
definitely there is a flying age Pawn
right there
Castle B5 what is white going to do in
this instance are we going to see D5
that is potentially an option are we
going to see D takes C5 or Bishop to D2
big big question right now we see Queen
to E2
is actually one of the main lines
Christian yes and uh yeah
and definitely Fabi seems to know this
particular
position of the Queen's gang with
accepted and according to the main line
Theory the big move for white is
actually to blast open in the center
yes take the pawn on C5 or D5 both but
main most most players play D5 but uh
Abby has gone for the pawn capture
okay they take C5 we're most likely
going to see Queen to C7
you don't want to go to A5 because after
Queen A5 Bishop D2 that Queen on A5 is
not feeling very comfortable now white
needs to be in time at this particular
moment yet Bishop to D2 followed by
Bishop to E1 and then make the
connection between the Rooks get the
other Rook to C1 and try to play press
for a slight Advantage for the remainder
of the game
um how is black going to react with this
instance in fact just looking at the
database I can see that there's only one
response and that is to put the queen to
C7 indicated yes right that's it
but Wesley's thinking perhaps doing his
usual strategy just trying to remind
himself of uh the analysis that he's
done so many times at home
I have seen these positions where
sometimes you do play Knight to D7
but 1987 Knight to E4 yes it's just one
thing I really don't like Queen C7
sorry I meant to I meant to say it in in
this kind of a way so C4 E4 Knight D7
and I have seen these so the idea is
capturing on C5 with the bishop ends up
as you say you know Rook comes to C1 I
have a feeling like I see some Knight
takes Knight to D5 yeah
all systems go for happy well that's and
guess what that's what he has to do
right you know like right uh so after E4
let's imagine maybe castles with the
idea of playing Knight to D7 takes C5
even
yes yes I mean that's what Bishop G5
most likely is going to come on board we
we Queens Gambit accepted players we
kind of just roll with these punches we
just kind of yeah yeah E4 E5 yeah yeah
yeah and then uh we trade things off
Wesley is very good at the neutralizing
yeah so this just to remind everyone at
home that these players are playing the
playoff it's playoff the rapid playoff
and whoever
well Wesley is in a must win so not
Wesley Fabiana carrona is in a must win
situation if he if he wins he will take
the match onto another form of tie break
where play gets even faster three
minutes plus two seconds there'll be two
games and if you still can't tell them
apart then we're on to the my favorite
Armageddon right but uh Wesley if he
manages to hold on tight and not fall
off that horse then he is gonna go
through and remain in the Champions
bracket and it is Fabiana carono Who
falls down to the elimination bracket
and he wolf face off against aronium
exactly
um guys I I know this is a just a
strange moment to ask this question
because I can see from the database that
Knight D7
um
has not been it has not been played but
well once you I think we rejected Knight
D7 because of Knight D5 because that was
one of the options yeah that was a scary
option I understand uh but you do
understand why Knight D7 you kind of
find it attractive because if you can
play Knight takes C5 it does come with
the tempo against the bishop uh the
reason why I was asking is because there
is this kind of like really funky no he
did castle castle on the board with the
idea D6 Bishop takes f three but can I
go C6
yes
okay let's jump back to the game castles
on the board and this has been played
before Bishop G5 top move but uh E5 okay
he has an idea prepared to E5 and now
you see your knight D7 with the idea of
taking that point tonight I'm dreaming
of Knight D7 takes C5 to see upon
sacrifice
try to get to D6 or are we Christian I
have to ask you was E5 a good move it
doesn't strike me as a very good it
looks like a very decent move yes a
decent move very decent move excuse me
novelty though it is a novelty no one
has played it before I mean I have this
kind of
sign that you know
when you see E5 on the board I'm not
sure this is a signal to attack on the
king side and so that's why I do think
that Fabiano needs to reinforce that
point he has and it's just therefore
I'm expecting the bishop must be
preserved put it on that beautiful
diagonal pointing
around
it is what it is
I'm keeping that Bishop alive we should
be one I know and now you've trapped
your rook in the corner like I said
and I think probably in for the penny in
for the pound
um I mean now could you
guys
uh night before he was chasing that
Bishop yeah I don't I don't know about
this uh this E5 Bishop F4 idea I I
again my Queen's Gambit accepted uh way
of play is I'm happy with black this
bishop on E7 means that you don't get to
play your sacrifice yes you're dreaming
of playing Bishop eight seven and Knight
G5 you don't get to do it and if you
don't get to do it I of course want to
play Bishop takes F3 and Knight takes E2
so but I have I have an idea
and you know desperate times call for
desperate measures that's good but the
Rook to D6 oh okay Rook to D6
okay okay well I haven't calculated
of course not uh but yes sir F5 once
you're giving Joey what she wants no we
didn't want this take on D6 with a room
and just take with the bishop back just
with the pawn but Jovi wants to
sacrifice I felt I felt Jovi am I giving
Joby what she wants
me
I wanted a great gift yes oh my goodness
okay uh well this is the kind of action
that uh Fabi needs and he did by the way
play Rook C1 no no but guess what if
you're gonna let me take that Bishop
that kills your attack that just kills
your attack Knight takes C2 and boy uh
Wesley's feeling that with that capture
a lot of the fears that he might have
had in no more
there is still something to be resolved
for Wesley because for instance you do
have B4 in the air okay The Rook is
eyeing up the queen and the Knight will
transfer itself to E4 and then from
there it can go to D6 and if you're
feeling particularly frisky F6 so
perhaps the most forward way was Rook to
C8 now we're gonna go before I go Knight
to E4
precisely I was about to say can we turn
the tables on who's pinning whom along
the C file with the Moon Knight A4 or
Knight E4 that's exactly what West is
doing yeah so that neutralizes threat
number one which is what you were
pointing out there uh
Jovi
by the way
um seven minutes seven minutes and 45
seconds for fobby five minutes and 20.
so that's second early long think that
Wesley had
uh it's it's paying off yeah he he
thinks early on and then he figures
things out and then he plays Super
precise moves by the way the more you
look at this position you even more you
begin to question whites is this a good
mission is it a good Bishop Bishop
is this night good it can be it has
potential I mean let's not dismiss why
it's attacking possibilities well let me
take off some pieces I was thinking
knighted G
Rook dhg5 but it's keeping it simple I
think I would go okay Knight to D4 play
it Rook to d8 Knight to G D4 played
um it feels like something is hanging
I'm not a I'm not a happy camper here
I'm telling you guys uh feels to me like
Wesley is taking over the position
he certainly is but once again he has to
worry about his time
D7 looks like a very natural and now if
you play B4 I was kind of inclined to
get out of Dodge here with queen d8 and
how are you gonna meet Rick D do I have
rookie too D2 yeah uh where is this
night going yeah it doesn't matter I'm
going to take only six
minutes and 15 seconds oh I know
Queen's Gambit accepted players there
you go
is on the board
56 is also another square that the queen
goes to Queen Bishop once you see Bishop
A8 and queen B7 you cannot unsee it it's
like that's where you need to go okay B4
B5 B4
then we're Ultra Ultra safe no more B4
and chasing my knight B4
and black is fine you like that move
people B4 is beautiful isn't it yeah
very very much it's it's a cure C the C5
Knight
and uh just Knight A4 okay
he's looking to swap more pieces
after all all he needs is a draw let's
not forget the obvious
that Bishop on B7 is just an angel or a
demon depending upon your point of view
I mean isn't it sort of ridiculous how
good these guys play with so little time
it is
it it's almost painful it's like they
find these moves with seconds like
Lanier today I did get uh solidly out
I'll play but amazing how many good
moves Lanier can play with just a second
on his clock yeah I was seeing Knight
takes Knights porn takes and I'm
probably expecting
the bishop to step back you mean you
have to keep as many pieces on the board
otherwise it's just going to be Bishop
C5 perhaps e35 Bishop
sorry a question I was thinking English
be 3.85 just attacked upon only five
game looks like uh
okay he's going for the attack
there is no attack to go for though yeah
Queen to G4 Rook to D5 was Wesley's
response yeah H6 probably Bishop to f8
absolutely that's the whole point that
Bishop is just such a beautiful
defensive piece and you keep your your
Pawn Shield intact and there's just no
attack Wesley's taking over right now
truly the threat is the obvious Rook to
d8 and attack the Knight on D4 feels
like you have to drop back with the
bishop to E3 now
this is really nothing done other than
just go
Bishop E3 he's four Bishop E3 drops the
E5 Pawn doesn't it I was going to give
you that pawn well I was going to take
it I don't know why because you would
have taken it
we'll both be happy H4 okay
you got to do something he has to go for
it
yeah but it is just one porn that's
marching up the board what's scary
touching the king in that position oh
really King age eight that's a
preventive move before he even had a
threat I was expecting Rook to d8
seriously uh H4 looked very slow to my
eyes he didn't play Rook to d8 he played
King
so the idea is he wants to meet H5 with
H6 and there's no more Bishop takes H6
that is true
the the king is no longer uh going to be
pinned Bishop to Bishop to E3 are you
going to take 25 now
well uh yes he really wanted to take on
E5 so yes yes but do I have yes F3 now
you do have Knight F3 but this Rook
takes Bishop
I love these exchange sacrifices with
two Bishops I'll put my Bishop on the
center of the board I get it I get it
but this is probably what he wants to
see Fabi that is as well just to remind
them that if Fabi does manage to pull
this one out of the bag and win this
game then the players will move on to
another playoff or they'll play with two
games with three minutes plus two second
increments anything else any other
result and Fabi is to the elimination is
sent to the elimination bracket where he
will face lavono Rooney and queen C7 by
the way I
boy I tell you I would have grabbed that
E5 Pawn with two hands and two feet uh
Queen C7 uh not allowing any kind of
imbalance and still saying to Fabi okay
I don't believe in your attack H5 H6 as
a Christian explained no no breaking
through there and in the meanwhile Rook
V8 in order to trade everything on the
they spawn on A4 as we saw on the
previous game it's doing a great job at
keeping the the majority on the well
majority keeping B2 and A3 let's try to
defend that one only five with Knight F3
Knight F3 okay that's a good news let's
trade off everything
okay I guess one on A4 or you're not
worried about it I didn't realize it was
hanging of course you can take the pawn
on A4 apologies
that was my idea with Knight F3 but
uh-huh I've been I mean there are some
consequences of the king going to age
eight and if this Knight
can make its way to G5
I think that maybe uh in this case this
is one thing you can we need F4
Queen F4 asking questions related to
that F7 Pawn well we can drop back with
the bishop well also can you not go King
King G8 and say yes
I do too
just uh keeping the F7 pawn and nicely
protected
Wesley down to two and a half yeah one
and a half minutes against four minutes
and 11 seconds for Fabiano
okay Edge once again another very tense
game between these two kids truly truly
it's like the queen takes E5 no he's not
just came to G8 I was about to say queen
takes E5 Bishop no you would never no
allow Queen also it's not Wesley's style
not at all he doesn't like to gamble
that was a 30-secondish pause or they're
about that was a significant amount of
time
worried about whoa Knight F5
really oh that is a thunder in the
position can you not just
take the night I made the night take on
D5 and how is that position I mean I'm
starting to have some pressure you have
a lot of weaknesses
A4 is a weakness F5 is a weakness
and okay Rook takes work
has to be played the Bishops of opposite
color though is that not beautiful for
Wesley but we still have major pieces on
the board and we know that the main
factor of assessment is initiative but
you know this is where yasa's idea comes
into play Bishop to C4 Bishop to D5 just
cutting off the I love this move by the
way I'm all over this move if you take
the pawn on A4 I've got check and maybe
Rook to C4 H4 Pawn would be hanging
right I mean the main thing is not to go
G6 and allow the black the dark Square
Bishop sorry
guys sorry
how do you feel about this one do we
feel that well father no
no I don't think that there's any any uh
these Bishops of opposite color where
the black king is so safe King h8 makes
a lot of sense you don't want to be here
Bishop F6 try to create something like
that
spoken like a real Fabby fan what to say
I don't think yes this is what I'm
looking at so for example you go Bishop
G5 Queen C5
could you kind of go after Bishop G5
F6
it's legal but it's not not recommended
yeah it's legal it's legal it is
I you're you you're really kind of uh
encouraging uh
Rook to D4 okay not exactly sure what
okay H7 H6 just
you know putting everything on on tap
could you also go
no I'm obsessed with this idea of Rook
the eighth
but it doesn't really work why not he's
going for it
okay I thought it didn't work because of
Rook C
4 is for attacking the bishop but then
then again you know I have to trust in
this F6 idea that I have which I know
you guys are not a fan of
very happily uh threat the trade Queens
in this case
Rook
I mean
fabulous is going F7 Pawn completely
into a dead end I just don't see him
breaking through on the king side King
at all tuck the king away
King H2 there's still some pressure for
white
definitely this is kind of one of those
annoying situations where Wesley can
feel that the draw is in his grasp but
it's not quite there exactly Queen to C7
gift meet upon
okay
threatening the F7 Pawn I feel Wesley's
getting a little bit too comfortable in
the position no no he's not being
complacent I think he's playing it very
well actually once again uh no big
threat F7 F5 no ampisson incredibly safe
King by Wesley uh he's playing this
very practically I want to say I don't
see how are you how are you going to
make an aggressive move tell me your
threat
there is no threat I mean what you have
to do is you have to move your
H6
and then
yeah it's it's not easy to find the
e-port precisely so that is exactly that
e-pawn is just
not to be
four okay but allowing F5 there is some
Bishop B6 business nobody believes me F5
threatens Queen takes E5 check
yes with
Glee
I I definitely so I F6 ss6 not F5 whoa
but F6 allows Bishop B6 wait a minute
Bishop B6 F5 Bishop B6 you had Queen
takes C5 exactly
but this is a bit different well now I
have do I have to move my queen
no I don't know one thing I don't think
you want to see is The Rook end game so
I don't think you want to take on B6
Queen takes E8
rook tc8 and Rook takes B6 I think
that's a difficult end game probably
not completely convinced but uh I'll go
with you on that one 47 seconds I think
Wesley missed this move I I think he
should have played F5 and that was the
big difference with the pawn on F5 you
had Queen takes C5 after Bishop E6
exactly but with the pawn on F6 Queen
takes E5 hangs The Rook on d8 after a
trade big shocking move and for Wesley
Frozen to completely Frozen 22 seconds
clock is ticking down and here captures
the queen
and he's well he's going into a bishops
of opposite color kind of position Rook
to D Rook to C8 yeah well all I can tell
you is that this is the best position
far we had in a very long time truly I
agree with that
uh and I think that Wesley understood
that the move F6 was simply a mistake
that's the first really well egregious
is strong but
mistake you know that Wesley has made in
this match so far Bishop he said it was
C3
yes that's the dream square of course
and of course the Rook can also go down
to B6
so it comes to E8 to protect the acorn
Rick comes to B6 and now now fabby's got
some nibble oh here I mean Asics and
Bishop to C3 and the tide has turned
there's definitely something something I
mean Bishop C3 you're going to have to
close that diagonal by playing F5
but then you're just simply going to
play with the pawn down I mean true look
with only 17 seconds on the clock this
is not going to be an easy defense for
Wesley saw Rook takes A6 F5 not even
waiting for Bishop C3 but boy what a
mistake he could have had that pawn on
F5 quite some time ago f3h6
but practically speaking
I mean it's it's a fantastic moment for
Fabi because uh he it's a two result
game he's got an extra pawn and an extra
minute yeah
and also
you know you can just imagine a
situation where the white Rook will park
itself on the seventh row truly
so he puts the bishop on B3 which does
defend all of his structural weaknesses
exactly meaning E6 as well as A4 A4
okay this means that it's time pardon me
to go King F4 G4 G5 Rook to A7 and hope
that we can uh
G4 I'm going to trade that with like two
hands
okay with two hands yes yes
why would you like to put your Pawn on
H5
I'm supposing so but
um are you going to go to G6 as I'm not
so sure
okay so Leslie obviously is just waiting
okay he's saying go ahead uh improve
your position as much as you can I'm
gonna move my king back and forth my
Bishop is going to remain you know ideas
of Bishop E7 Bishop F6 if you get the
king to H7 now so you have to be careful
good point
King H7
drops back into its shell I do like what
you said of and that was also Jovi what
I was asking you about H5 if you get
your Pawn on H5 and your Bishop on F6
then you can just keep black you know
stuck essentially on the king side
Bishop comes back to C3 C3 and uh it's
not threatening cutting off the king
well there are some ideas in here right
of um Coming okay G4 here we go
honestly it was very very quick to say
thank you for clarifying the structure
on the king side there with uh that move
G4 takes takes came fast what Fabi would
love to see is H5 King H6 and Wesley is
very very pleased that he can maybe take
everything of the king side
yeah if he manages to do that put the
bishop back to B3 yeah it's going to be
an easy draw that's going to be the draw
and there he is immediately uh and I'm
thinking Rook G8 just
okay I like that I do indeed uh but I
take on H5 take on H5 take on H5 take on
H4 simplify the position as much as
possible okay take on it I took your
advice but I would have liked the past
Pawn myself
Rook G8 King H4 King H King H by King H4
and I have a past G bar yeah okay but
the thing is this simplifies his mission
he knows exactly what he needs to do
right now
don't get Chuck mated and it's almost
impossible to get checkmated without the
king without a Viking my Bishop has one
square in the position that I want to
keep it at B3 truly
I liked your king going rogue because if
the king does go Rogue then you may be
able to trade exactly sacrifice The
Exchange you kind of know the keys King
goes to G6 no okay but it's still in the
air though still in the air absolutely
23 seconds 35 seconds for Fabiano
later but this is the type of position
where both sides can just make the moves
our Tempo The Rook coming down to G1
boy I
that's such a strange move for me I
would be keeping my Rook on the light
squares you know like Rook G4 Rook G2
obviously not putting it in a dark
square that would allow me to blunder my
my my Rook uh you know I'd fall for
something like Bishop f a check
Wesley will probably 57 Rook D1 yes good
turn good move okay the black king cut
off
so long as it's on H7 you're never going
to get made it there
um can we win a pot no we can't part no
apologies one thing that white wants to
do is give that Bishop to F6
let's get that Bishop closer to your
king maybe I will start dreaming of
something
I don't have much even though yeah but I
Can Dream yeah and you've got 14 seconds
to fulfill that dream
hands back
by the way again that's not where I'm
putting my eyes yes I'm white I'm not
putting my Rook on the lights coming to
D1 correct
uh and Rook D5 we could expect a la
Tempo but no uh Wesley was he realizing
that the clock is ticking down
a different brand of Chess that is such
a strange move for me
okay your Bishop F6 is on the agenda
okay he wrote the B4 Bishop to B3 back
no to H1
crazy move I would have expected King G6
to just get your king and now the king
is in well finally but yeah King F5 King
and four yeah you're doing great now
suddenly and now you can give a check
correct the white case three why not
although you are driving the white king
could go Rogue it could go Rogue up to
D4 up to
C5 okay we're expecting
again why are you putting your King on a
dark Square King G4 well look here he
goes I mean he's trying to trick him
okay now you have to go Rigby one you
have to get the temperature starting to
see some tricks in the position
when do they how do you feel about it
it is I think it's been it's been uh how
many moves without a poor move
that well we have the 50 50 move rule
where if one side hasn't made a capture
or a pawn move then it's a draw it's a
draw and there were it was a few moves
ago it was 29 moves left the problem is
they don't know that oh that's a strange
move what is he doing as Bishop is
hanging off
is truly playing with fire
jeez this is such a strange way of play
for me Bishop D5 oh now he's safe again
finally the King goes back well isn't it
just King F7 here Wesley Rook to B3
That's The Bishop's square that is the
Bishop Square is The Bishop's Square
it's okay King F7 escape with the King
right bring your king to C6 that that's
a nice square that makes a lot of sense
wisely traveling on light squares this
is good yeah this is good uh Rook to D3
King to D7 let's go
to D3 yes King 37. okay there's about 20
moves left before a draw can be and now
the now the king the white king is is is
shut in Bishop to B3 don't allow Rook
takes A4
or Rook F5 check also uh makes sense
but now I now I think it's an easy draw
King to C6 is it's got to be easy
Rook to F1
because white king is just cut off why
didn't he play King the C6 and just stay
on the f file or start giving it now
it's a just the check of the king yes
keep checking keep checking yeah but
don't let the king back on towards the
center right no this is fine yeah yeah
I'll put the bishop back on his dream
Square correct
I think this might be over guys I don't
see a way no
more moves
the players won't know that but I do
believe the Arbiters at a certain moment
75 moves or so they're obliged to step
in dismiss the game
right so King C6
King C6 King D5 Queen C6 makes a lot of
sense
he's trying to give the bishop to F4
right to get the king back into play
exactly but King C6 King D5
your king will be
wonderfully safe on the E4 Square
you're not going to get checkmated in
the middle of the board with a rook and
Bishop no I think Wesley knows it yeah
he can feel that he finally can breathe
a sight of relief almost yeah King D5
give me the E5 Pawn I love that pawn
let's go King D5 what what isn't that
Rook text no Rook F3 checks
play with fire he really loves it
Bishop back to B3 and he's let the king
back now the king can come into D5 but
okay King to D5 come on now
all right I like the way that Wesley has
set up a nice technique you know he's
just simply gonna cut off the white king
okay rookie
rookie four and now King to B5
how many moves how many moves are we
there I think we're nearly there I feel
like Calvin and Calvin and harps are we
there yet he's he's talking with the
he's looking
yeah he can claim any time he doesn't
know it he doesn't claim it right now
but he should claim it
and the worst thing that can happen is
that Fabi will just gain a few extra
minutes and and and then he will know
your five moves away your eight moves
that is a very good point yeah I mean
and that knowledge is golden
I completely agree I think it's very
good technique to do that
yeah
but I seriously I would play the move
Bishop D5 and I would say I'm gonna make
a a claim
I think the claim is going to be made
whenever the position is changing
so when he knows that he doesn't have a
way to stop the position from changing
like rotating then he will make the
claim yeah
it's also a psychological battle right
yeah it's like neither player wants to
give the other player a minute on the
clock it's like what and the
satisfaction right almost
um and they know that they might meet
again later on in tournament okay
so King B5 Rook a five check King b six
I would go King B7 Bakers can be five
I would go King C4 me too the King on D3
oh definitely
yeah I mean Bishop D5 King C4 King D3
can you ever get in trouble here like in
C4
Bishop D5 wait a minute uh King A5 no no
no no no no no no 20 moves
and the King marches King goes to D3 I
love that move and key to D3 yeah that
will be and suddenly it's the white king
yes yes yes yes yes yes precisely that's
what I was thinking as well
yeah yeah this one
doesn't seem to be going anywhere in D3
the rogue rogue King I'm gonna I'm gonna
borrow that and call it an original by
the way
yeah are you worried at all about Rook
takes D5 okay
no
no there's nothing to worry about Bishop
to B3 yes
and the more moves that they make the
closer they get to the Arbiter Chris
bird stepping in and declaring the game
drawn so there's think there's 15 moves
left until the Arbiter can do that
so it's almost tempting to actually play
for the win it kinda kinda no Fabiano is
praying that Wesley is going to get
ambitious with Rook days before but by
the way let me get ambitious let me play
Rook takes B4
[Music]
I mean okay King takes beats no now King
takes B2 well then he'll go Rook takes
A4 and suddenly there's no more 75 move
Now The Rook days before is really
something you don't want to do
because you're not do you really care
about the rating the rapid rating no I'm
not playing for the win I was thinking
that Rook takes B4 was uh
clarifying the draw actually funnily
enough
but it is a strange again I'm thinking
Wesley should whoa whoa whoa whoa
discover check C5 is a move
he's gonna yeah
before he can take that decision
he's claiming
I think Chris bird is asking him with
what move do you want to claim
you have to make a move Wesley
the problem is Wesley does not want to
make a move because Rook tc5 is
available
it's over this one is over guys you're
right
quite the match quite the playoff as we
expected it was going to be a very very
tough one our defending Champion Fabi is
the first time he loses a match in 2022
he went through winning all of his
matches but now he's going to have to
come from the elimination bracket yes
we're gonna have to see a comeback from
Fabiano if he wants to win the American
Cup but what a battle
Wesley moves on to face her Karu that's
also uh very very promising
let's take a look at the brackets
definitely and in the Champions bracket
we saw Hikaru Nakamura put in a powerful
performance to go through to the next
stage where heresy was touch and go for
Wesley so but he made it and he will be
facing off against Hikaru Nakamura and
Fabiana Carona is sent down to the
eliminations bracket and talking about
the eliminations bracket
big pairings even there you know you
think you think you're safe no you're
absolutely not it is Fabiana carono who
is meeting livon aronian you know I'm a
very strong player and then we have Ward
number 15 I think lenia Dominguez facing
off against the extremely well prepared
Sam Shanklin and these guys are on their
last lives so whoever loses their match
will be eliminated tomorrow exactly and
in women's number one versus number two
yeah and it certainly was an arena crash
and Alice League you know they are just
making it to horse race they're so
impressive and they will be facing off
against each other tomorrow and then the
elimination bracket in that bracket
there is everything to play for remember
if you lose that's it you are out and
we're gonna see four players battle it
out so first up we have Tata sorry Nazi
she's playing against Tata abrahamian
who is very impressive defeating
Katarina ninsova and then we have vegan
who will be playing against newcomer
atusa and remember you lose you're out
it will be decided tomorrow so hold on
to your seats because it's going to get
bumpy tomorrow
nice well I I have to say guys this was
a a great match to watch I I it lift a
the expectation I want to say I mean
both players really played some really
great moves I I enjoyed this I enjoyed I
enjoyed it from the beginning actually
because every single player came to the
board in a fighting mood they wanted to
play combative chess they really wanted
to test each other in this battle of
wits and sometimes that's rare to see
when you're playing in this Elite level
chess
uh-oh I had Wesley okay yeah I'm good
Nakamura hello
[Music]
but now comes the crucial one what about
the ladies yeah and the ladies yeah
yeah well it's tough it's tough everyone
is still in the competition
we're on a similar path we got here
different ways but uh we picked the the
semi-finals yeah shall we say definitely
um very brave of you yeah very brave
well thank you very much
you were very loyal your loyal to your
student uh begum and uh loyal to uh Fabi
so we admire you for that Christian I
mean look I still have lives left in
both competitions I'm not out yet that
is true yes
um I just thought that Hikaru not only
did he play a great game and I mean that
genuinely he played really really well
but when he came into Studio
and he talked about his thoughts his
processes how he got to Knight C2 how he
did everything it was like he was right
on everything he he just had a great
feeling about the position yeah I have
to say I was also very impressed by the
amount that he saw and also by his game
plan as well choosing that opening you
know just making sure that lenia took a
long time because it was uncomfortable
position to play and I thought he just
did it beautifully I thought it was also
funny what he said about the G4 is the
best movement when you play it and lose
you know like you feel like an idiot why
did you play G4 because if you don't if
you go into that variation and you don't
know that G4 is the right move it's kind
of you feel a little reluctant you've
played G3 yeah yeah
our winner Wesley so is with Christian
Wesley a Titanic struggle between two
incredible players what did you feel
made that separation in this matchup
uh well
you know
can need some help you know help from
your opponent like I've gone either way
and uh try to get some good time
management and kind of help a little bit
that I got some practice in Berlin
playing speed chess but uh
yeah really the first game went quite
smoothly to to be fair I you mean the
first game of the playoffs yeah the
first you guys also play the classical
match you had some chances it felt like
you got that extra Pawn did you feel
like you were getting in the classical
any traction in that game probably
nothing really like I was very surprised
when he played the H6
I thought Queen takes C5 was pretty
what's the main line and it's pretty
easily holding foreign yes
and now I mean I analyze this with black
like if Rook C1 probably in this night
before check yeah
and then Knight D4 I think Rook to B3
Knight to D4 yes perhaps Knight to D4
this is what you analyze yeah
but this is the draw yes I was very
surprised when I started thinking a long
time and he played H6
and then I thought I had some chances of
probably nothing really big I was happy
except 96 if we played Knight A6 I have
C6
I thought Knight a66 but yeah computer
doesn't get much by that white as a very
big Advantage here yeah before it's
coming but yeah a computer gets all
serious G3 yeah like here I thought I
have a chances but couldn't really find
anything so I was kind of confused
during the game whether it's all part of
its preparation or I'm mixing up
something he was indeed taking a long
time to get this position but after that
he did precisely calculate everything to
make a draw yeah
that first game of the playoffs yeah it
felt like he went smoothly slowly well
you're gaining a nice Advantage out of
the opening if I like yeah for sure I
mean except D6 I thought D5 equalized
right away yes yeah but then he spent a
lot of time and then on move nine
but yeah I thought maybe it was a
mistake and here I had I was very happy
I think if I had a big Advantage I
thought but I
you know yeah it was unpleasant
defending for black I think he almost
equalized at some point
like the bishop is just
very test Bishop on basis was he going
with the Knight on B8 like what was his
plan with this uh Knight to C6 A5 A5
after Queen to A2 or yeah Queen A2 A5
p59
Knight d8 or 9 yeah doesn't matter yeah
97 Knight C5 yeah I thought I had a
pretty big Advantage but so I was trying
to push it but then I couldn't really
find anything concrete but I I mean he
probably almost equalized at some point
this was the big moment when he had this
opportunity to play D5 V4 D4 yeah V4 I
think I play C4 D4 yes yeah and then he
gained some space yes but still there's
some pressure left uh for a Blitz game
for a Blitz game yeah for sure but yeah
I was trying to put pressure but then I
realized it's just all about that time
and uh yeah he didn't really have a
clear way to equalize maybe oh here
maybe instead of uh at what point
instead of Rook D1 on move 40.
I guess Queen D1 also loses him because
I tap this night yeah 21 take take okay
okay two Rook 2 A8 and the Knight gets
trapped yeah I mean the difference in
the position of knights is huge that is
beautiful yes so I was very pleased when
I won this game yes and then but then
the second game I came up with the same
idea to what he did in the classical
yeah it was very search I was very
surprised because I thought white had
absolutely nothing if I go for mainly
with B5 but and if I did not to check if
analysis then after E4 couldn't really
remember I guess I played okay so yeah
but I was very happy on move um I
thought Bishop F4 was slightly a mistake
I was very happy when I took the bishop
on C2 I thought I was even a little
better yeah and better and you were
indeed yeah and then I messed up real
quick like I relaxed too early yeah
midnight before
prevents all the trades Knight A4 was a
good move yeah now I couldn't trade
pieces I guess I'm still better but
I couldn't
still not an easy position especially
with a low time control yeah and then
you found Knight F5 and now were you at
all worried at this point or did you
feel like you're very very close to I
happy to get the quality I'm happy to
get the opposite colored Bishops yeah I
mean that means it's very good throwing
chances no matter what happens but of
course I knew that I need to be very
precise
but then I kind of messed up my F6
probably a mistake
because of this bishop to B6 perhaps F5
instead of six yeah F5 I just forgot
about this bishop B6 business yeah yeah
F5 and then Bishop B5 should be a new
Oh I thought on move 38 38 oh 13 there I
thought yeah he should take a
F6 first and now Bishop to C3 yeah so
not allow you to close the position up
with F5 no sorry F6 was a big mistake
yeah yeah yeah this does indeed here
probably Fabiano will convert this
position serious chances yeah yeah yeah
actually it's uh yeah it's it also I had
very little time so he probably would
convert but still after F5 you you had
to defend accurately for 70 plus moves
you did so yeah you continue into the
Champions bracket tomorrow you will be
facing
uh the rating favorite going into this
event Hikaru Nakamura how do you feel
about that particular matchup you know
him so well I mean he's the only one
who's won any classical games right yeah
oh yeah he's the only one one in
classical games I mean he's in very good
form I thought since it streams non-stop
that these chess would be affected but
he comes to this event very very well
prepared and he's playing really really
well yeah so it's gonna be
interesting yeah I I thought that
with a full-time job
will be affected but no he's playing
like Magnus Carlsen this tournament
he is indeed but uh yeah
showing as well I don't shy away from
that guys any questions yeah quick
question for you Wesley uh at the time
that you did say to the Arbiter Chris
bird uh I'm gonna claim a draw on the 50
move rule in your mind
how many moves did you played
well I I was pretty sure that you were
comfortably above 50. but how many did
you think you might have was only like
56 I in the end yeah I thought for sure
that we'd reach 50 moves at that point
without any pawn moves just right so I
mean I mean I look at the TV screen and
I realized that we played like almost
130 movies
but you were you were getting close to
the 75 move where the Arbiter was going
to step in oh yeah not that close but I
claimed because I was wondering if I
could take the pawn on E5 you wanted to
stop yourself from losing the 50 move
rule chance I didn't want them but it
was also quite risky because if
if you're wrong then you you get uh then
your opponent gets a minute right or
something yeah too but so yeah big deal
yeah it's very risky you think it's
risky to give your opponent two minutes
so what what is he gonna do
you got two minutes
yeah in that position but when my king
was uh on was cut off on the G file I
was slightly worried that he could
attack The Rook for my Bishop at some
point like Rook takes B3 and A4 a59 I
had to be very careful that this is a
draw but um
yeah if it's they're going to say like
uh
of course I could just take the pawn E5
but then we keep playing right and uh
I was just pretty confident that it's
got to be 50 moves but but it's hard to
say in a Blitz game because
you can get penalized for for the wrong
claim so um I think I've done it before
Wesley uh we're very well done good luck
tomorrow in your match with Hikaru thank
you so much guys absolutely and another
thrilling day uh here at the American
Cup I know what a battle between Fabiano
and Wesley I mean I still can't get over
it I mean it was so difficult it was
tense I know well number seven against
world number eight they can't agree a
quick draw there has to be a decider
right I mean it was intense and I have
to say overall though I mean what a day
I think it's my favorite day so far good
stuff uh wrap it up for us uh Christian
with some final thoughts of uh I have to
say my favorite days every day because
we have every single day this type of uh
matches that take us to the end and this
is exactly what we want to see I am
mightily impressed with the favorites of
this event Hikaru Nakamura just
incredible Precision with the black
pieces and guts to play the Sicilian
against a player like Dominguez that one
quite impressive and of course Irina
Crush it's very difficult to touch her
at this moment in time but tomorrow we
will be seeing this huge clash between
her and the 13 years old Prodigy
earliestly I'm definitely going to have
my eyes peeled to that one guys so much
fun and exciting just here at the
American Cup no question about it that's
a beautiful wrap if I ever heard one
well done it's been really my pleasure
we'll see you all tomorrow
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited